me. [music]
Hey.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
[music] Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. [music]
[music]
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat.
[music] Heat.
Heat. Heat. [music]
[music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Heat.
[music]
Hey, Heat. [music]
Hey, hey, hey, [music]
hey, hey,
hey.
[music]
Hey,
[music] hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> whooping click.
[music]
Hey, hey, hey.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat.
Heat. [music]
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey, what?
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey,
hey, hey.
>> [music]
[music]
>> down.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey.
Woo!
>> [music]
[music]
>> down.
Black
[music]
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
>> Hey [music]
hey hey [music]
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
[music]
Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat. N.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey,
[music]
hey, hey. [music]
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey,
[music] hey, hey.
Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> The first chapter of the Hartford
regional qualifier has concluded and
Only nine players remain undefeated
headed into round nine. Out of all those
players, none [music] of them are our
returning champions. Only moments from
now, this entire hall will be filled
with Riftbounders from [music] across
the globe, but only eight protagonists
will ascend to the single elimination
phase. [music]
37 legends remained in this story, all
fighting for the title of main
character. So, don't go anywhere,
Riftbounders. The dramatic conclusion of
this epic tale starts right now, [music]
[music]
right now, and right here. I'm Barrett
Bryant, joined by the wonderful Kangas
to give you a wonderful hello to day two
of the regional qualifier in Hartford.
What was your favorite thing you saw
yesterday?
>> Favorite thing I saw yesterday? Well,
first before I answer that, I got to say
between the two of us, we got an average
haircut, so props to that. Favorite
thing I saw yesterday. Oh, that's a good
question to start it off with. We saw a
couple of really cool matchups. We saw
uh Diana deck list that were very
unique. The Vex offensive list might be
the most creative one that I saw. I was
like I think the last one of the day,
but it was this one typically think of
vex as the whole deck and said this one
was like no, I'm going to run the on
guards. I'm going to run the Aurelia and
try and fight in aggressive early on.
So, I love the creativity that duelists
have brought with their deck list.
Sometimes they're throwing us for a
loop.
>> Throwing us for a loop. You know, we're
going to talk about some of our favorite
players that have been coming to every
single one of these regional qualifiers
across the year. We call this our loyal
porro list. These are players, no matter
their results, they have come to every
single event so far this year. And you
too could join this list potentially in
the future. But we've got people like
Talion who have been at every single one
with varying close top cuts. Even people
like JRAD who have come here and had an
excellent time. I had the pleasure of
finally meeting him in person yesterday.
And then of course we got to talk about
some of these other players. Allen's EQ,
Prismatic System, Desiden, No Veggies,
and Villionaire really staying true to
the regional qualifier scene. And then
also showing up.
>> You might notice a lot of these names
also very consistent high performers. So
I maybe a correlation between going to
every event and also doing well at the
game. If you play the game a lot, a
competitive level, it turns out uh you
might get some results.
>> Exactly. So, a thank you to all of those
players that are still even in this hall
today. But that's not what our viewers
are here to look at. They want to see
what's going on here at day two here in
Hartford. Nine undefeated players coming
into today and a pretty diverse legend
spread as well within those nine. So,
we're going to talk about our metag game
breakdown.
>> Yeah, and we just uh saw last week in
Utrect again a very diverse top eight.
It feels like we might get a similar one
for this event as well. Uh it's a lot of
undefeated so far, but here's the
conversion rates that you see. Master Yi
still very popular deck. The uh rumors
of his demise were greatly uh
overexaggerated here. But Diana and
Leblanc still very respectable. New
additions from Unleashed.
>> The Leblanc one I think is actually the
one I'm mostly surprised about because I
think every single time I watch this
Leblanc list, it sometimes struggles a
lot during the Swiss rounds. But 33% for
the conversion is a good look for that
deck because I know a lot of people are
want to be playing it, but it's very
hard to pilot I feel sometimes. and the
match up dependency.
>> And it's one of those ones I think
because it's the last unleashed uh
regional qualifier, we're starting to
see people master the deck because
you're right, it's a hard one to learn.
A lot of different branching decision
trees you go down. A lot of different
ways to build the deck people were
experimenting with and I think most
people have figured out baited hook is
the way to go for Leblanc. So now that
we're kind of settling in on that, the
highest conversion rate on the screen
here, it might have surprised me a few
weeks ago, not as much today. Yeah, and
we have to of course make a shout out.
You talked about last week with our
eight unique legends. We've got Azir
here. Good representation. Victor as
well. Legends that we saw even convert.
Those are our two finalist decks from
last week. Still showing up here with 16
13 respectively for Azir and Victor. And
those are like the token generation. You
know, they they feel like there's never
a weak point in the game, but they can
somehow sometimes draw their deck in the
reversed order where if you just don't
have find the units early on or you
don't find the equipment for Azir side,
you can maybe run into a bad a bad game
because if you have a rises too early,
there's not much to do. But doing a good
showing here. Moving on to some more of
these legends. Annie conversion for 29%.
And that means it's not just a
prismaticism. From what I've heard,
>> the record to beat right now for the
Annies is X and one, and there's a ton
of them at that record.
>> Really, I saw a prismaticism post last
night a photo with one other 7 to1
Annie. I didn't know how many there were
in the field, but I know that he's aware
people are coming for his best. He wants
that six. He's Have you seen the full
five on his chest? He's got the chain
he's walking around with. I actually
have a personal photo on my phone when
he was handed it in Utre where I took a
picture and then of course they used a
similar one for the best of on that
article. But other ones that we have to
talk about that were even in last week
of course we have Rexai once again being
represented in day two and I believe and
one of them is even undefeated. Darius
as well one of those legends that we had
and Volibar actually having 19% is
pretty high in my opinion.
>> That is pretty high. Low population rate
at 27 only five magnets a day too but
still decent conversion rate. The big
one I want to point out is Lux. Four
Luxes making it. This was one that a lot
of people were like, "Is it good? Is it
viable? Can you pull it off in the
actual regional qualifiers when the
pressure's on, the time limits counting
down?" Obviously, four players were able
to get it. I don't know if all of those
are on the Limitless looks, but uh I
would guess because that seems like the
best way to play the deck.
>> I I think that's what a lot of
especially North American players as
well are gravitating towards. So, I 100%
agree with you. I I would put money on
that there would be all four of those.
>> That was Gretton's deck to win.
>> Yes, it was. Yeah. And also you think
about Josh about Kha'Zix who was on the
last slide. Another high representation.
So I'm excited to see some of those
lists. And one of those Luxes is one of
our undefeated decks as well.
>> Yeah. Imagine undefeated on Limitless
Lux. What's the average like game time
compared to anybody else in the field? I
feel like I always see those Luxes go to
the full hour. You know, it's really
really tough to play fast with that deck
just cuz you have to draw so much. But
really cool when you do pull it off,
>> but it works out because you said draw
so much, but not getting draws in the
tournament is also key for a control
style deck like that because I always
think when a Lux deck makes it to those
untimed rounds, if they make it to top
eight, I think that deck is unbeatable.
>> True. And also, uh, if they're even in
overtime, it's one of the few decks that
can win beyond the like, oh, you have to
win by two. Sometimes that's just
impossible. It's really hard to do in
overtime when you only have two more
turns. Lux is like, "Oh, two turns.
Perfect. I'm able to get there. Like,
I'm actually able to get the full combo
off."
>> We're going to check out some of those
names though that are making in our
standing. So, we're going to go through
a couple of pages here. Obviously going
to show off all of our players that are
currently 8 and0 going from Meiro down
at ninth all the way up to Vexer. And
like I said, the diversity of these
legend spread. We've got Ezreal, Diana,
Rexi, Rengar, Master E, and Alux on
that. And of course, the Pike all the
way.
>> The Pike's very exciting. And the the
Rengar I think is uh it's not who we
might have expected to be on it, but I
think that a lot of people are
respecting the Rengar a lot more. Rexi
again making a really good run on a day
one here. That was one of the big
surprises. That and the Darius were the
biggest surprises for me in top eight
and Utre. So happy that at least one of
them is finding a lot of success as
well.
>> I'm just happy that Order is finding a
spot into the format and that Rexite is
and we even got to watch something must
work yesterday. So really expertly
piling that and also had to beat
Prismaticism to do so. Ooh, moving on to
Yeah, next next page. Of course, you
know, Kai'Sa here to play as well. Azir,
here is Cactus King. We got to see on
the stream yesterday as well. June,
you're technically undefeated. Kha'Zix
right now at 70 and one. Had the
pleasure of showcasing that deck in
round one yesterday. And then Vex, of
course, we talked about on five up.
>> Vex. Well, first off, the this version
of the Vex is not the typical version of
Vex. I highlighted it earlier if you
didn't catch the beginning of the show
or the last feature match yesterday.
It's kind of like an aggro Vex. I I
wouldn't say it's pure aggro because you
have the ability to hold still. You are
playing a lot of the stun spells anyway,
but you're on the Aurelia Fervent,
you're on the Kha'Zixes, you have your
on guards, which I would never expect in
a Vex list cuz typically you think you
get multiple on one battlefield, but it
lets you punch a little harder, play a
little faster. I loved that. And also
June on the Kha'Zix. Man, this deck is
so slept on. One of, if not the
strongest individual uh, you know, um,
signature spells in the game. It's charm
and it's Ride the Wind in one.
>> That's crazy. No, I I agree with you. I
I I always have the fun conversation, a
little thought experiment for everybody
at home. What do you think in a vacuum
is the most powerful signature spell
or moonfall, right? Like, and it's and I
don't think it's really close. But we've
got our next page here. I miss my queue.
Returning Master Yi player here as well.
I don't know how you miss an alpha
strike. That one's a point click.
>> It's that seems unrealistic, honestly.
May maybe they made the name when
they're playing Ezreal.
>> Oh, yeah. You're right.
>> And then they switch to Ye cuz it's a
little easier to land your Q. But that's
where a bunch of these Yees are lining
up here at the seven in one area.
Another Rexai of course with Zolt here.
Here's some of the civers rising up.
We've talked about dazzling Aurora and
there's of course a little bit of new
tech that we had the pleasure of also
seeing in round one yesterday of these
Baron Nashers and maybe even these dead
bloom predators [music] being added into
this Dazzling list. So glad to see that
representation here. But I still don't
know how I feel about where Dazzling
Aurora is going to end up at the end of
today because that LA our first slide
not a high representation. Yeah, Dazzlin
Aurora is one of those decks. I will
always be a doubter on it for doing
particularly well at these long events.
There's so much variance. You eventually
will run into a game where you just
don't see the Aurora early enough in two
of your games out of three and that will
almost always be one auto loss. Most
Eland Aurora players I talk to at these
events are have similar stories. They're
like, "Yeah, I just didn't see it for
two of the games." We saw that on stream
yesterday with the Lee Sin Aurora deck,
which with the column rooms, you're not
actually able to get the the draw power
as much, but I feel like it's really
hard to get an Aurora into top eight
[music] specifically.
>> Now, some more legends that are
represented still in the running, of
course, being X and one. We got Bat
Smack with Teemo, which we had the
pleasure, I believe, as well having on
our stream yesterday. We've even got
extra ones, more Kai'Sa representation,
which I'm really excited for because I
feel like that legend is another one
that we've kind of stopped talking about
mainly because people are maybe doubting
the Fury domain. But like you said last
week, we have Pike or so we have Pike
that's an undefeated state status right
now. We've got Darius and Rexi that made
it in yesterday. But the people that we
want to start talking about, we've got
some spicy players now on this list.
Prismaticism still in the running at X
and one on that. Annie, of course, and
even Jeff Jones, who I think we had the
pleasure of doing some interviews with.
So
>> legendary card game player.
>> Yeah, it's so we have all these
incredible names, but it's now taken us
so many slides to get to them. And I've
got a special treat for you on this next
one as well because
>> Okay. Is it better than Carmen Hiego?
>> Yes, I mean maybe. I don't know
[laughter] as I don't know the pleasure.
But here is the most stacked fe at 7 and
one right now. Dewali, Allen's EQ, Colin
Kaiser, and Gonkra all here and
returning champions as well as, you
know, highly competitive players really
coming in clutch and still in the
running, but way further down than we're
used to seeing them.
>> Yeah, it's never guaranteed because we
don't know the the full math yet, but
typically X1's going to make that top
eight. X2 is where that bubble starts to
appear. Um, so all of these players are
in a pressure seat and you saw how many
names were before these legendary
players. If any of these guys drop a
single series today and five rounds
ahead of us, suddenly their top eight
run is on the line and I've noted that
all of them are still chasing [music]
kind of legacy at this point. It's a
competition between these guys that have
been able to consistently get top eight
in multiple events. Well, and I think
the most exciting thing to look out for
at least in these next five rounds that
we have before we cut to tops, what if
those players get paired into each other
and they are a win or basically lose
your running situation. So, that's what
we're going to be keeping an eye on, of
course, which means that XM1 bracket is
something we're excited to see, but we
still of course want to highlight our
undefeated players cuz it will
eventually probably only be one of those
by the end of the day today. But
>> that's it for the standings right now.
We want to talk about and have a
specialization of the best of right now.
And one of the ones that we talked
about, one that we've been talking about
for a long time is Volibar. For everyone
at home, if you're a fan of course of
challenger TCG, uh, Villionaire, he's
not here in day two today. And it is,
you know, not going to be represented
inside of this list, but there is still
a representation of five Volair players
still in contention to go home for that
best of, which means we'll see a new one
in a very long time that we haven't had.
>> Yeah, I mean, Villionaire, the Volibear
legend, and I'm curious. I'm assuming
most of these, if not all of them, are
on a dazzling Aurora list. But the thing
about Volibear is there are a few
different ways to build them. I'm loving
the pure dragon Volibear. I know it's
not the competitive way. That's my for
fun party deck right now. Um, but then
you can also just do a more of a
mid-range uh style. You can go for the
Aurora. You can do the high-end Aurora
or you can do the kind of middlebridge
Aurora where you're playing the Ferris
4Runners and the Rengar. There's so many
different ways to build Volibear and I
think that that's making a lot of people
excited to try it out and uh it's tough
to see Villionaire not able to make the
run for another one, but it leaves
opportunity now for somebody else to
finally claim the bear.
>> In the similar conversation, we have to
talk about another furry friend, Rengar.
Now, Sam Sherman has had the biggest
performance on Rengar recently, of
course, back in finals appearance
Vancouver, where he'd lost to Allen ZQ
taking home the second regional
qualifier.
>> He's not in first place right now. not
in first place because we have the
undefeated one on mom sky that we
highlighted on the standings earlier and
even still there are quite a few more in
fact to still be competing for this
Rengar. So it could be Sam, it could be
mom sky. The race is being
>> No, no, no.
>> Doogie. Ah, [laughter]
>> excited.
>> Again, another situation where there's a
player that took home a best of and got
second place with a legend that I think
no one was really talking about making
that finals appearance and it could not
be Sam Sherman again.
>> It could not. And again, this is a a
legend that a lot of the you best units
created in Unleash or releasing unleash
were things like Rengar, things like Vi,
things like Kha'Zix, Vex Apathetic. when
you have access to it as your chosen
champion, it really increases the
ceiling of what some of these decks can
do. Yes, it's not going to be as much of
a surprise when you're against the
Rengar, but still the fact that you just
have access to this like if you're going
second turn two play, just drop the Reng
Guard to Battlefield. It will win you
games on the spot in certain matchups.
Some of the slower decks just can't deal
with it. Um things like Vex that are
trying to hold really struggle with it
as well, unless they get their Vex
apathetic specifically out to a
battlefield, let alone AR. Like, good
luck if if you're an AR player out
there. So, I love Rengar and I love what
it's doing to the meta.
>> I just think the ambush mechanic is so
so fun. So, it flourishes in a deck like
Rengar. Obviously, with the repeatable
might that you get to give away to your
units, but it just incentivizes for you
doing this thing. And we saw exactly
even players like Prismaticism take home
regional qualifier wins on his Annie
list because of being able to play
reaction speed units instead of using
spells.
>> Rengar was making waves before Rengar
Legend even came out. Let's talk about
the next one here cuz we also have the
best of Lux still in contention with an
undefeated.
>> Yeah, four of these here, but Rivia,
like we said, one of the undefeated
Luxes right now. And like you said, more
than likely that almost all of these
lists in some capacity are doing some
sort of this limitless Lux that we've
been talking about. Of course, it's
going to be so hard to maintain that 8
and 0, especially because you're going
to be going against these other
incredible players that are playing
other legends. [music] And from what
I've seen as well and what we've been
talking about, a lot of aggressive
lists, which mean there's an opportunity
where this Lux doesn't have enough time
to set up and get what they need to do
to actually pull off their combo.
>> I think it's part of why things like the
Pike deck are seeing so much success is
because there's a lot of Aurora out
there and there's enough of the slower
decks like Lux, any of these rush down
decks like the Rex size, the Darius, the
Pike. Um, they actually excel against
these really slow decks. It's like what
is Lux [music] realistically supposed to
do against a Rex eye that's like sweet
I'm just going to keep spamming two
energy units and just conquer every turn
and maybe hold a couple of points as
well, but I'm just going to score an
eight well before you ever able to get
to your combo. That's where Lux is going
to struggle. So, it's very impressive
that the Luxes are still uh here with us
because I thought that these were going
to get chewed apart.
>> I think so, too. And speaking of getting
chewed apart, I want to see what Rivia
actually win against. So, we're going to
take a look at the Swiss run for Rivia
so far. And even at the tail end of the
game, Ireelia, Ireelia, Ireelia in six,
seven, and eight rounds, but still
having to take down some Aurora lists.
>> Aurora is probably the best matchup for
Lux. In fact, I would say this is I
would guess it's like a 90% win rate for
Lux cuz Aurora is also going to play
very slow and win very slow. If you're
an Aurora player, you do not want to sit
against the Lux. The surprising one is
beating the Rex eye. In my mind, these
are fast decks. I called it the honest
aggro deck yesterday. Um, and then three
Aurelia. Aurelia has the potential to
play very fast. Sometimes it's only with
one scuttle crab, but you can move it
in, give it ganking, send it over, ready
it again. You know, all these things
that the Aurelia can do. So, beating
three in a row, that's very impressive.
>> Even for me for the Aureliaex is the
deflect keyword, right? You know, defect
as well.
>> Yeah. It's just like it's trying to
already slow down what the Lux deck is
doing to get to those runes to pull off
the combo when they find more cards. But
at the same time, I guess if you can tow
that line like I think Rivia has been
doing all weekend so far is, you know,
just giving away enough points and then
finally coming in when it matters and
either ruinish in or destroy the board
and then set up your combo and get where
you need to be.
>> I will say I think another reason why I
don't expect Lux to go super far and
make top eight today cuz you get five
more rounds of Swiss and once you're 8
and0 you're against other 8 and0
players. competition's only going to get
better and the chances of matching up
against somebody who's either tested
against Lux or just understands
fundamentally the game well enough that
they can theory craft the win line. It's
going to get uh harder to beat those
types of opponents.
>> Speaking of harder to beat, we got to
talk about the Mind and Chaos decks
inside of the room. And I'm not just
talking about Diana. We're actually here
to talk about Ezreal. This is a crazy
and alarming stat right now because I
think this tells a very unique story of
what's been going on across Spirit Forge
and now towards the tail end here of the
Unleash season. Ezreal's at 84% win rate
over the Diana decks [music] right now
on the same domains,
>> which makes sense when I sit here and
think about [music] it. Yeah,
>> more control oriented, not so
wants to keep their units alive, whether
returning to all the same technology,
but Moonfall doesn't do as much work
against a deck that doesn't necessarily
care about a lot of their units or
they'll just bring them back to their
hand. And while they're removing your
units, they're in gaining card advantage
and eventually [music] tire out these
decks. So much so that even players that
have won on Ezreal, like Allen's EQ,
have lost to Ezreal decks in the past at
other events since making the conversion
to Diana. I think that's such an
incredible change and dichotomy of these
two decks, but the same colors.
>> One of the more popular ways to build
the Ezreal right now is with the pack of
wonders. You're returning your Ezreal
back to your hand, the Fizz, stuff like
that. So, you don't really care about
the enemy star cross as well cuz you're
happy to have them back. But here's a
deck list we can take a look at or
rather a match up. This is Vexar's run
currently as one of the undefeated
Ezreals. So again, what are we winning
against? Boom. Two two of these Diana's
towards the tail end of the day and
still has an incredible time against
these other decks that are even, you
know, we talk about LeBlanc.
>> Yeah, there's Doogie there then. And
then of course I look at Leblanc who I
think also is really good at playing
this long style of a game, but Ezreal is
so much better at doing it at least when
it comes to the idea of resources.
>> And this is an ideal match up I'd say
for Ezreal. Leblancs do not like to play
against the Chaos Domain cuz Gust is a
very popular card. And that turn one,
they send a unit in to try and conquer,
gust it back. Leblanc's like, "All
right, well, that's probably the game.
You're not really going to be able to do
much after that if you don't get that
initial reflect token." I mean, you
obviously can still play, but like it
really sets your uh pace of play behind.
>> And then on the other side of this
conversation, Diana. So, we're going to
take a look at Evans or him their run so
far on Diana, and it's going to be or
sorry, this is Linsanity's runity. Uh,
so in Linsanity's Oh, as we swap it.
There it is. Aspirin's climb. Evans are
him also playing Diana and had to beat
up four other Diana which just speaks to
this conversation I think a little bit
because if these were Ezreal's I think
this looks completely different.
>> Yeah. But if anybody has ever played a
Ezreal like uh mirror match and spear
forge before the ban list came out a lot
of people call it the miracle Ezreal. I
think that this is probably comparable
in complexity. like the Diana mirror is
very very complex and a very hard one to
win because you really do have to
outskill and outnowledge your opponent.
Uh a lot of the time you know if you see
the same cards which often times you're
going to um it's about you know finding
the right lines and the right ways to
outplay and uh usually be the reactive
use of the star cross as opposed to the
proactive use of it. Very patient
players are rewarded in that matchup.
Good shout out here too for the round
three against Ganushka only because as
or the Azir decks specifically and I
don't know if it's something similar to
Squirtle's list like we saw win last
week [music] but we have seen other
Diana decks right now kind of struggle
against that Azir matchup. So good to
see that there are still some of Diana's
out there that take it down.
>> It can get tough cuz Azir just goes so
wide. You just get so many units that
Diana's really good at dealing with like
one or two units at a time but once you
that rise hits the board you're like oh
boy. So yeah curious how that those
matches went. Well, speaking of matches,
we've done enough talking. The players
want to see some games at their tables.
The viewers at home want to see those
games being played. So, we're going to
send it over to the casters to get us
ready for round nine.
Barrett Kangas, thank you so much for
that great show opener. We are back for
day two of the Hartford Regional
Qualifier. Thank you at home so much for
tuning in and joining us once again. We
saw so much exciting action yesterday
and today the stakes are higher. Only
one player will lift that trophy at the
end of the day. Will it be a former
regional qualifier champion or will we
claim a new champion here in Hartford.
I'm Josh Schneider. I'm joined by
Charmer. We'll guide you through the
action today. And if yesterday was any
indication, I think we could be in store
for something special. Yeah, I'm really
looking forward to the matchups today
because uh day one is when legends are
played. Day two is when legends are
made. These are the players that have
been performing well throughout the
event. They know how to navigate the
matchups, but it's also the situation
when the pressure is on and they know
that they have to continue winning to
secure a spot in that top eight and
potentially cement themselves in the
history of Riftbound. I would like to
just say personally as we are looking
through the player lists, uh, I'm
rooting for you, Stark, because I picked
Civer to win this event, but also my
oldest son is named Stark and today is
Father's Day. So, if you're watching,
Stark, happy Father's Day. I love you.
>> Yes. Happy Father's Day to all the
[laughter] fathers out there. You as
well, Charmer. Yeah. No, that that's
awesome. I really love it. And I love to
see the diversity of the undefeated
legends coming in today, too. But I
believe we've got a vote for you at home
on which match you want to see being
featured here in round one. So here we
go. We've got Mom Sky, who I had the
pleasure of interviewing yesterday with
Rengar versus Brady Kin with Ezreal. And
then match B. Look at this. Darius and
Urelia.
Yeah, Asep Tofu on this Darius list is
very intriguing to me. I'm a big fan of
just slapping a bunch of might on the
board. I'm also a big hook enjoyer, but
it does right now look like it's a close
vote with a lot of people rooting for
Mom, Sky, and Bradyken to grace us on
the broadcast. Get those votes in, chat.
>> Absolutely. And it should be an
interesting matchup. Looks like the
Rengar match edging out this Darius
match here, but I'm excited to see
either one. I think the Darius is quite
explosive. It was really cool to see
Darius finally get a top cut appearance
last weekend in Utre. And who knows,
maybe we could see Darius in the top,
but Mom Sky
wins it. So, uh I'm still excited to see
this and there's a number of reasons
why. First and foremost, we just saw
that impressive uh statistic where
Ezreal is winning a lot of matchups
against Diana. However, I think that
Ezreal is as good into Diana as it can
be, but struggles into the rest of the
field. I think that's why so many
players like Alen's EQ, like Dewali,
like so many others have been moving to
Diana, because Moonfall is very good
into other decks. So, I want to see how
this Ezreal navigates against a Rengar
without a Moonfall.
>> That is a great point, and it's going to
be an interesting matchup. Let's go
ahead and take a look at the Rengar deck
list.
from Moms Sky. This is a deck that wants
to score points quickly. It can flood
the board early. We've got a total of 12
plays that you can make on turn one.
Lots of cheap units here. Great curve on
the three cost units as well. Just a
deck that wants to be very aggressive.
There's not a lot of tricks in the deck.
It's got that thrill of the hunt, but a
deck that wants to be aggressive with
its units, get on the battlefield
quickly. Yeah, the tricks that do exist
are typically things like the ambush or
even just the pike as well because the
pike can enter ready. Uh the Kai'Sa can
also enter ready with the accelerate.
Darius is a pseudo ready where you if
you play Darius, you play your second
card of the turn that becomes ready. So
those are really the true tricks.
They're just not done at action speed or
reaction speed outside of that thrill of
the hunt that you mentioned. The thing
that jumps out to me though is again
while this wants to play early, some of
the early stabilization tools like
irresistible faolk potentially lose
value into this Ezreal matchup because
again some of the units that you're
playing early as Ezreal are either going
to be returned to hand or are a bit more
expendable as opposed to decks that want
to stick might early and fight with the
Rengar. And something else that I want
to point out here is that Brin here
thundersong because in this matchup that
could be very interesting. We know these
Ezreal decks are more control oriented.
There's a lot of spells. So this Brin
here could be very interesting and
trying to close out the game and keep
Ezreal's options very limited and you
can thrill of the hunt that Brin here
back in if you needed to.
Well, we're going to take a look at the
Ezreal deck list now from Brady Ken and
we're going to see some of the ways that
they plan to slow down the Rengar. Of
course, two main deck Vex Apathetic that
is likely going to be an allstar in this
matchup. But other ways to slow things
down include the pack of wonders combo.
We saw this yesterday utilized
incredibly well from Pike. But this pack
of wonders is still in Ezreal. And look
at this. Also running the list, two
copies. We saw pack of wonders work
beautifully with that. The nice thing
about the list in this Ezreal deck is it
counts as a choosing of enemy units and
because you can use it every turn
because it's a gear that stays on the
table. It gives you so many more
consistent ways to activate your legend
ability and draw those extra cards.
>> Yeah, that is a great point. And
something else worth noting, we've got
that bewitching spirit as well. And the
Renguard deck is not a deck that is able
to draw a lot of cards. So that
bewitching spirit could be problematic
here paired up with that pack of
wonders. That way to essentially just
continue recycling that bewitching
spirit and shred your opponent's hand.
>> Well, we're going to see if that
bewitching spirit makes the impact
because we're going to be jumping to the
game now. The game is ready. We're going
to be joining the players at the table.
And I am again very excited to see how
this matchup plays out because we we
[music] saw the impressive stat of
Ezreal into Diana's. And I do think
Ezreal has a good match up into other
lists. I think something like a Rengar
will be the true test [music] of how
well it can do into a broader field
because it wants to do things [music]
every turn. You have to have the answer
as the Ezreal player essentially every
turn.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely [music] right.
going to have to pour out the removal
quickly and efficiently as Rengar is
going to be quite aggressive. Mom Sky
Brady
>> of wonder and pass.
>> Round number nine of 13. Pack of wonders
early for Bradykin as he starts things
out getting that pack online. We talked
about how important it will be to this
Ezreal deck.
This is actually a fantastic start for
Bradykin because this is going to enable
most of the game plan. So being able to
kind of pick and choose what you're
developing going forward
>> get a gold
>> is really important and that flourish is
going to be important as well.
>> Absolutely. That Kingu Initia earlier
for Moms Sky not getting the draw there.
No other units in play to get that might
needed to draw a card. And the deadly
flourish not only clears Mom's Skyy's
board, but also gets that gold token to
help offset some of these power costs
later as we go back over to Mom's Sky.
We'll once again look to develop
these plethora of units that we can find
in this deck. Yeah, I think Moms Sky is
just taking some time here to figure out
which units you want to develop because
you do lose some value as a Rengar
player when your opponent isn't playing
units because your ambush units lose
>> uh their kind of surprise factor and it
feels like a waste to just develop them
without using the ambush. That being
said, I think that Moms Sky also wanted
to go wide on that turn, opting for
lower might instead of just playing one
big unit like the Kai'Sa that we saw.
>> Absolutely. Being able to
>> go wide is strong here. Try and avoid
that one for one removal as we see Brady
can
>> Ezreal
discarding and drawing a couple cards.
And we are going to see the Bellow's
breath repeated. And that is going to
clear that backline.
Wow. Great start here for Braden. Just
cleaning up this board each and every
turn. And this is exactly what Ezreal
wants to do.
>> Yeah, that Bellow's breath repeat is
something that has been a nightmare for
opposing players ever since Spirit
Forged. Obviously during the miracle
days uh there was a lot of cost
reduction tricks but I think people
sometimes just forget as players have
moved on to Diana that Ezreal still
capable of these very efficient plays
with the repeat spells.
Kaisa
>> survivor coming out for mom sky
accelerated
moving into Emperor's Deis getting that
first point of the game
>> and that is going to be
>> the turn back over to Bradykin Ezreal
and Pack in that back line
up to seven runes.
>> Now I will say I liked the play from
Mom's Sky the previous turn [music] of
just accelerating the Kai'Sa at this
stage. Everything you've played has been
removed. you're starting to run low on
cards. Ezreal has already activated and
drawn one card. You see the pack of
wonders. So, at some point, you need to
not only score points yourself because
that was the first point scored in the
entire game, but also you just need to
refill your hand. Like, you need those
cards. Now, I will say there was a
potentially an argument to be made about
after the conquer on the day just
bouncing your own Kai'Sa back to prevent
her from dying to removal. There could
have been a play pattern where the
Rengar just keeps accelerating units to
the Deis and then returning it.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely right. Could do
that
>> for five purple
>> with that new ruling
on Emperor's Deis. You can bounce that
unit for no energy. You would not get a
Sand Soldier token at that battlefield,
but nevertheless could be effective at
just continuing to cycle the accelerated
units. As you mentioned, Kaisa is able
to get that card every single time she
conquers. So you go in, you get that
point, you get the card, but right now
it's three might to three might at this
northern battlefield.
And let's see if there's any reaction
>> from mom's guy.
>> Oh, thank you. My apologies.
>> Judge just giving a reminder that the
Ezreal legend is readyied and we are
going to see the thrill.
>> Uh going to which battlefield?
>> That thrill is going to banish Kaisa.
Yes. Uh, I was going to say that you
don't have to announce where the move
goes until it resolves. And you do want
to make sure it resolves because Ezreal
can run hard bargain.
>> Let's see where this Kai'Sa goes. Can
put it on either battlefield.
Could try and sneak this extra point
here at Sigil of the Storm.
>> Yep. All right.
>> Getting that additional
>> finishes first. I pass focus.
>> I go to one.
>> All right. And so Bradkin will get on
the board.
>> UFO focus first.
>> We'll see if there's any response at
this southern battlefield from Bradykin
>> to this five might Kaisa after that
stack deck.
>> Pride stalker trigger.
>> Going to dig for some options with that
stack deck.
And Moms Sky I think decided to go to
the sigil both because of the points but
also because you are trying to force a
big spell like a star cross if they want
to stop that conquer. Uh a lot of the
Ezreal stuff kind of caps out at either
three or four damage. So by playing
Thrill of the Hunt getting the legend
trigger you go up to five. It's going to
require something like a star cross to
interrupt it. Starcross great spot here
because not only does it bounce the
Kai'Sa back to Mom Sky hand, but Bradkin
will be able to reutilize that Ezreal
Prodigy
and dig for more cards here in the near
future. Getting an extra card as well
off the legend activated ability
because Bradykin did choose units twice
>> that turn.
Yeah, I will say the good news for Mom's
Sky is right now the cards in hand is
still pretty high.
>> So far Brady Kin has not been able to
kind of win the attrition war.
>> The downside is the score is one to one
and the later this game goes I think the
more that it obviously favors the Ezreal
player because we already have the pack
of wonders and as soon as Brady can kind
of assembles the rest of the combo
pieces, Mom's Sky will not be able to
keep up with the value. So again, I like
this play. You accelerate the Kai'Sa,
you get the points. It was just returned
with the star cross. I will say once
again, there is maybe an argument to be
made about returning it with the the
Deis, but
>> at the end of the day, leaving the might
developed is still going to force a
response.
>> Oh, is going to take my advice. Okay.
>> Yeah, just thinking that one through,
but will trigger that Emperor's Dea. So
>> Kai'Sa being bounced back
>> for no energy [clears throat] but no
sand soldier created. Inferno does come
down. It's two to one for Mom's Sky as
we go back over to Brady.
>> And you're absolutely right. Brady with
this Ezreal list has the inevitability
in the late game. So
>> it's on Moms Sky to put big pressure
here.
>> Yeah, I do not hate this from Moms Sky
at all. The reason I like just keep
accelerating the Kai'Sa and then
bouncing it is unless Brady Ken has an
answer in the showdown step or forces
them to uh go over the top of something
with some sort of hold which we know the
Ezrealists don't do very well. You're
essentially just going to score points
and draw cards every turn by playing the
Kai'Sa to the Deas rinse and repeat. So
>> uh we are going to see
>> see that flourish.
>> Okay, so once again Brady can he just
he's not leaving any units in play. I
don't think Mom's Sky has started a turn
with units in play.
>> Well, and again, that's why I like this
idea of just continuing to rinse and
repeat this Kai'Sa onto the deis. In
many ways, what you're doing is you're
doing a build my own pack of wonders,
right, Mom? Can we get Pack of Wonders?
No, we have Pack of Wonders at home and
it's Emperor's Day plus Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah, that is absolutely right. Let's
rinse and repeat the Kaisa Survivor back
into Emperor's Deis.
>> This would be the third point indeed. It
is three to one the score in favor of
Mom's Sky drawing another card off of
Kai'Sa. So very nice here that Kai'Sa
getting some really good card advantage.
So does mean that the bewitching spirit
wouldn't be quite as valuable right now
as this Kai'Sa just continues to get
some really nice value for Mom's Sky.
>> Now there is another Kai'Sa in hand. So,
at this point, if Moms Sky wants to
leave that, I'm okay with it. And that's
what Moms Sky is going to do. Uh, and
the reason for that is because now you
want to force Brady Kin to keep
responding to what's out there, but
still have the Kai'Sa next turn.
>> Because what's happening right now is
every time Brady Kin answers the units,
you'll notice that Bradykin is also
expending energy, which means he's not
conquering himself. So moms sky is just
going to try to collect points and force
cards out from Bradykin
>> and then eventually get to a point where
if you're at six, you can set up a
double conquer for the win.
>> This is I think a solid game plan from
Mom's Sky. This pickup of a list is huge
for Bradykin, though.
>> Yeah, it absolutely is. Naming the void.
So the list will give Kais
naming the voidus to one.
>> Yes.
and replaying the list because it gets
bounced back with the pack of wonders.
So that's minus four might on Kai'Sa
does still have that one might thanks to
the buff from the pit rookie that came
out last turn from mom's sky. But now
Stupify being played as well.
>> All right, so this is kind of signaling
a bellow's breath.
>> I would expect that to be the play here.
>> And it is Bellow's breath repeated
>> taking out both of these units. It is
not a It's not a response. It's an
activated ability.
>> Little confusion there. So, Bradykin had
definitely targeted more than twice. Uh
it was already online just from the list
bounce and replay, but
>> Mom Sky uh not correct. It is uh a
trigger. It's not a a trigger that you
have to take when it happens. it is just
online and then you can exhaust the
Ezreal uh as a reaction at any point for
the rest of the turn and draw the card.
>> Well, the trend continues for Mom Sky
once again starting the turn with no
units in play.
>> Bredicanin has
>> you have a lot in hand
>> successfully dealt with this board each
and every time
>> just asking
cards you have in your hands
>> over and over. [laughter]
Yeah, if the player is kind of comparing
hand sizes and realizing they're both
doing the same thing, which is, you
know, playing cards but then drawing
cards, rinse and repeat. Uh, again, this
pickup of the list though, I can't
>> I can't express how big this is for
Brady can
>> mostly because it means that for two
energy in that pack of wonders like
exhausting every turn, you can give
something minus four and draw a card and
that is going to be every turn. Now, you
can't do it at reaction speed or action
speed. It has to be on the turn of
Bradykin, but that means that Moms Sky
almost has no way of keeping anything
alive longterm.
>> I'm going to Eclipseer.
>> And we see that Kai'Sa
>> predict
>> coming down the second copy moving into
Emperor's Deis looking to conquer once
again, but Eclipse will give Kai'Sa
minus four might.
>> It can go bottom.
>> Yep. And the predict going through
Bradykin shipping that top card of the
main deck to the bottom.
>> Uh you regain focus. Do you do anything
with it?
>> It looks like focus is being passed back
over to Bradykin.
>> And Gust is going to attempt to bounce
Kai'Sa back.
>> Um
>> so we'll see if there's another response
here.
>> Just Inferna. So
>> we're going to inferna here at the
Emperor's Day before Kai'Sa is bounced.
So that leaves a unit there at Emperor's
Deis. And Mom's Sky will successfully
conquer up to four halfway home here in
game one. And that's the power of the
inferna card because yes, you've got the
assault, but the ambush also means that
when your opponents are trying to use
these one for one removal options during
a showdown, you can ambush it in for the
low cost of just two energy and kind of
secure the conquer point.
>> So, Mom Sky, I think, had a wonderful
turn there. This is going to be an
uphill battle, but because they were
able to still get the point and end the
turn with might on the board, they're
once again going to force Brady to spend
some sort of cards here. The downside is
is that
>> the cards are just going to be
replenished. Again, this pack of wonders
plus the list or pack of wonders uh
>> plus bellows or whatever the case may
be, you're always going to be able to
draw an extra card per turn if you're
Bradyky. Yeah, this combo is just
absolutely crazy here. That pack plus
the list and with Ezreal getting that
card. But now the bewitching spirit
comes out as we see Momms Sky discarding
the determined sentry. And a second pack
is down as well. Bradykin replaying the
Bewitching Spirit, shredding that hand
from Moms Sky as we see Inferna
discarded as well. And Brady Kin with
Ezreal just slowly taking away all of
the options from Mom's Sky.
>> Yeah, we are essentially a turn and a
half away from Moms Sky playing strictly
from the top deck because of two pack of
wonders and the found bewitching spirit
if Moms Sky does not have a way to deal
with the spirit. And this is a window of
opportunity because there is no energy
available to Bradykin. if you had some
sort of uh targeted removal or uh a way
to get rid of it, then you would buy
yourself some time until the next
Bewitching Spirit is found. But now that
it is online, Mom's Sky has to know I
either need to score two points now and
two points the next turn or just
understand I'm playing from the top deck
for the rest of the game. So, we're
going to see this Kai'Sa come down. It
will likely uh once again go to the
Deis.
>> Yep, you got a five.
>> Yeah, absolutely. that card
>> cycling
>> and we desperately need cards now that
this bewitching spirit is online.
>> So up to five goes Mom's Sky.
>> So I think what you're looking for here
if you're Mom's Sky is something like a
challenge where you could use that to
get rid of the Bewitching Spirit with
your Kai'Sa.
But I don't think I saw one in the hand
of Moms Sky. There are some in the main
deck, but I have not seen one pop up
yet.
Moms Sky still has five ready runes,
four cards in hand after conquering
there with Kai'Sa.
Moms Sky has to be thinking I'm I'm so
close to getting into position because
the other thing we have to remember
>> is Moms Sky does have that Brin here in
hand and that's a great way when you're
trying to get to that double conquer
turn from you know six to eight to kind
of ensure that you'll be able to make it
happen. The problem is you know again
with that bewitching spirit and double
pack of wonders combo there will sky
have enough cards in hand to kind of
protect it. So, I actually really like
this
>> uh just sending the Kai'Sa in twice.
You're going to draw two more cards, but
you're also again very importantly going
to be at six points to set up a threat
of a double conquer. Uh Bradykin is in a
great position to try to stabilize here,
but because he is so far behind in
points and because he lacks the the
board presence right now,
>> he's got to make sure that he plays
perfectly for the rest of the game.
>> All right,
>> absolutely. Mom's Sky up to six
>> and really all thanks to Emperor's Deis
being able to bounce Kai'Sa back for no
energy there. Again, it's not a part of
the cost to finalize that trigger on the
chain.
So, Kai'Sa really being used to great
advantage.
>> And now, Mom Sky in striking distance.
Let's see what Bradykin has for us here.
>> Still only one po point, but just trying
to
slowly get through these threats and get
this in-game state.
>> Thousand watcher. Thousand tailed
watcher is the play for Bradykin
>> and it is going to be accelerated into
the sigil.
>> I go to two. I recycle a rune
>> goes down.
>> I will go here passing
>> and now Brady Kin moving into the
emperor's deis with that bewitching
spirit and he'll take advantage of being
able to bounce the spirit back.
>> Up to three points for Bradykin. He
reinforces the southern battlefield
>> list to hand past you
>> and just going to pass it over with four
runes up. So moms sky will have to be
aware of the possible interaction here.
>> Interesting.
>> Now that was a very welltimed watcher
from Bradykin because
>> it doesn't just get rid of the opposing
units. It does represent a large amount
of might. So that plus the Ezreal on a
battlefield is going to make it that
much more difficult for Moms Sky to get
a double conquer. And because of the way
that the Ezreal deck plays, if Moms Sky
instead just takes the deis and tries to
pile on might there for the hold, Brady
Ken likely has a number of answers, has
probably drawn half of the deck at this
point. So it can pick and choose
whatever you want. Uh there's also
anything that's already been played like
a starcross for example, you know that
you have to uh account for Bradykin
likely having Fizz in the hand so you
can get those back. So Moms Sky even
though they're at six uh I don't think
they can rely on going to seven and
trying to hold. It has to be a double
conquer, but that 10 might that is on
the sigil right now is a lot to go over.
And then when you factor in of course
the four energy available for Bradyken,
you're also still playing around cards
like Starcross from hand.
>> Definitely a tough situation here for
Mom Sky.
>> Triple discarded though.
>> That's the question.
>> Just trying to see what possible units
he has available. We know that Kai'Sa is
still an option,
but as you mentioned, holding's going to
be extremely difficult. but he hasn't
been able to keep any units in play at
this point.
>> So, the the interesting bit is I just
heard Moms Sky say uh I don't know what
I want to hold through a triple discard.
So, I think Moms Sky is understanding I
can't double conquer this turn. So,
whatever I do, assuming Brady does a
triple Bewitching Spirit the next turn,
what am I going to have left after that?
So just trying to navigate not just this
turn but also the following turn and the
effects of it. And so that's why we're
seeing just the fa folk come down the
rest of the cards held in hand to
protect from the bewitching spirit.
>> Yeah. The double pack of wonders with
the bewitching spirit. Just crazy. And
we're going to see the spirit at the
southern battlefield as the hopeful gets
discarded. It's down to just four cards
in hand for Mom's Sky
>> pack replay spirit.
>> And so this is exactly what Mom's Sky
was worried about where you're seeing
Bewitching Spirit come down for the
second time this turn.
>> Going to get rid of the Fairest
Forerunner. And here comes Bewitching
Spirit number three. So mom's guy
properly identifying
>> Folks
crossed [laughter] instead
>> looking to bounce back that Faithful.
I think Mom Sky here trying to figure
out, okay, how many runes am I going to
have to play with next turn?
Has the Darius in hand.
We know about
>> Kai'Sa. Um, I think this is a very good
play from Bradyken. Even though it looks
unassuming, it's just one might. The Fay
Folk is something you want to get off
the board if you can help it because if
it were to drag the Ezreal over, it
might make breaking the might on the
sigil that much easier. So, you don't
want to have a situation where the
faithful pulls one of the units to the
deis and then you ambush in something
like a Rengar or another unit. you get
that victory and then thrill of the hunt
to the other side.
>> This is definitely a heads up play from
Bradykin to identify the ways that they
could break through this battlefield and
instead of being greedy and going for
the guaranteed triple bewitching,
instead played it twice and then opted
for the star cross and then still leaves
energy up for responses.
>> Yes.
>> Ringgar trophy hunter the chosen
champion for bombs sky still sits in
that chosen champion zone.
11 runes for Mom's Sky to work with
here.
>> Do we finally see the chosen champ
making an appearance?
[snorts]
>> Rough, rough, rough, rough, rough,
rough.
>> Kind of difficult situation. Rough is
how he describes it.
>> Worried about the round timer cuz we're
already past 20.
>> Here comes the trophy hunter down into
the sigil of the storm. Can be played.
All right,
>> the battlefield where those enemy units
are located. That's a seven might
>> chosen champion.
>> That's right. Because of the legend
trigger jumps up to seven. So
potentially trying to just trade with
this watcher. You know, thinking about
cards that Moms Sky hasn't seen yet. Not
only has he not seen challenges, but I
don't believe I've seen a punch first
roll through yet either, which would
have been uh likely very welcome here.
And it is just going to be the trade.
Watcher for the Ringgar.
Moms Sky will look to develop further.
Was contemplating another ambush there.
Does have Niti in hand.
>> I was going to say it doesn't have to be
an ambush. It can just be this Darius.
It's the second card played, but it sees
itself. So this Darius will essentially
enter ready as a seven might unit and
that will
>> star cross
>> start to threaten. There's the star
cross to bounce that Darius back that
tried to take over Sigil. Strong play
for Bradyin.
>> Five cards at hand.
>> We go back over to Bradykin's turn once
again
>> channel.
>> No units for Mom's Sky.
>> Okay,
>> have to plan once again.
>> The good news if you're Mom's Sky
>> is that's the third star crossed. The
bad news is you're going to have almost
no cards left in hand and there is still
fizzes you have to worry about. Now,
>> the fizz cannot be done at reaction
speed, so you don't have to worry about
those star crosss interrupting you
during the showdowns. Uh there are still
plenty of other removal options at
action speed that Brady can will have
access to. But uh that is at least a a
big hill that you have now climbed and
crossed over by getting through all
three of the star crusts at reaction.
You just over the Darius, right?
>> Well, there we go. It was the
triple bewitching spirit turn with the
two pack of wonders.
>> And he has it.
>> And here it is. Darius and Kai'Sa. And
that is going to allow Mom's Sky to
conquer both. Accelerating the Kaisa.
Darius, the second card played. He's
readied up. He can go and conquer. A
double conquer turn for Mom's Sky. What
an opening game
>> cuz it seemed as though Brady had that
inevitability, but Moms Sky was patient
and found the time to pounce.
>> Well, like I said, the good news was you
got through all the star crosss.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that meant that while they were
still available through a Fizz, there's
nothing at reaction. It also was a turn
in which Brady Ken had to expend all of
their energy. So, they had nothing up.
You knew that you had the window. And I
think that the important piece here is
Moms Sky correctly identified what the
game plan was from Bradykin went with
those Kai'Sa on the Deis early to keep
the hand up because otherwise you
wouldn't have had that ability to play
two cards that late in the game. The
spirits would have stripped it
significantly sooner.
>> So this was a great game navigated from
Mom's Sky.
>> Here we go. Game two
of our round nine feature match is
underway. Brady Kin started out with
that stack deck as the faith folk comes
down for Mom Sky and it is met instantly
with that deadly flourish.
>> Irresistible Faith Folk no more
[laughter] gold created for Brady Kid.
>> Just chuckling at some of the uh the
player banter there. Brady said, "Your
best friend is gone." And Mom's Sky said
that's unbelievably rude. [laughter]
>> And then
>> yeah, that's just too much.
>> You go. Here we go.
>> Double unit play for mom. Sky pit rookie
will buff buff up the grim apothecary.
>> I will play
>> there. There is something that's going
to be really important for this game two
of the series that we need to pay
attention to.
>> Uh that is the timer because Brady Ken
knows these games go along as the
control player and this is an aspirin
climb game. Bradyken trying to get some
additional time to make sure that the
combo comes online. Uh this means that
if this runs long, they might have a
hard time finishing game three. So I
expect, and we're kind of seeing it now,
uh players to play much faster in the
early going. The one other thing that I
would like to mention is that the deis
is gone. That was a big part of the
victory for Mom Sky in game one. You do
have seed to power. You can still draw
cards off of a double conquer, but
that's much harder to do against a deck
like Ezreal than simply going to one
location over and over again.
>> Are we going to be rude and gust me?
>> Apothecary down to the aspirin slime.
[laughter] And there's the gust
>> when pit rookie moves into seed of
power.
>> I will stupify the apothecary trigger as
legend.
>> Nice little combination here for
Bradykin to stupify that apothecary to
get the card off of that Ezreal Legend.
kind of slowing down some of the
momentum for Mom's Sky,
>> denying that extra card off of Seed of
Power.
>> Yeah, and again, that's going to be very
important because
>> the only reason Mom's Sky was able to
take game one was from having so many
cards in hand from that Deis and Kai'Sa
combo. Zeda power again you can draw
cards from but you have to be present at
both battlefields. That was something
that Msky did not do often in game one
and I find it being uh very difficult in
game two already with the early gust.
>> Um
>> we see pit rookie being replayed.
>> Play my monk
>> and the monk here actually going to get
a card. We do have five might between
those other units on Mom's Sky side of
the board.
>> Channel two.
>> Yeah, the Kinko Initia has been such a
wonderful addition for body decks with
unleashed
>> body decks prior really struggled to
find any sort of card draw. And while
this is conditional, it doesn't require
a power and it generates might. So, it's
everything you want if you're playing
body as a domain.
>> Watch out. We've got Thousand Tailed
Watcher for Brady. in each of these
units for Mom's Sky. Minus three might
for the turn. Does he have that Bellow's
breath on the two guys?
>> He does. Bellow's breath is going to
target these guys on the back line.
>> Yeah,
>> Mom's Sky board threatened here. The
backline is down.
>> Let's swing in here. huge massive
>> as Ezreal can move in now and threaten
to clear the board once again.
>> Just two runes left open for Mom Sky.
Does have that thrill in hand.
>> Yeah, it's
>> he wants to keep a unit in play.
>> It's such a powerful card that it feels
sometimes bad using it in situations
like this. However, as you pointed out,
you're not just keeping a unit in play.
>> You're also scoring another point this
turn and then another one from the hold
because you know Brady Kin has no other
options right now. All of the runes have
been exhausted. Oh, instead is just
going to do here. So saying I would
rather get rid of the Ezreal instead of
scoring an additional point. You will
get the hold still. You'll go from one
to two, but you had the option to go to
C to power score there and then go from
two to three. I think Moms Sky said,
"I'm tired of this Ezreal reducing your
costs."
>> Absolutely.
>> Let's just get rid of it now.
>> Reducing those additional costs and also
>> potentially generating extra cards if it
gets bounced back. Here comes Kaisa
Survivor. The MVP of game one for Moms
Sky moving to Seed of Power. Will score
to three. And we're going to draw two
cards here. One off of the Seed of Power
and one off of Kai'Sa. So, knowing that
the Kaisa play was coming, I now
understand why they decided to just get
rid of the Ezreal. Now, if you're
watching at home and you're saying,
"Okay, well, you could have still sent
Apothecary to seat and then sent Kai'Sa
over the Ezreal and then
>> still got rid of the Ezreal, right?" But
the difference here is you get to draw
an additional card by having the Kai'Sa
conquer the seat. If the Apothecary was
already on the seat and you conquered
the other side, you only get the draw
from the
>> Kai'Sa.
Now we go back over to Brady again. He's
staring down three units from Mom's Sky
as Thousand Tailed Watcher is going to
start a showdown with Kaisa.
>> That's seven might to five might in
favor of Bradykin.
>> Show me the minus.
>> Here comes that punch first. Plus five
might would be the number on
>> Kaisa.
>> And it is Eclipse that will give the
Kai'Sa minus four. So, the Watcher has
enough might to break through
>> and conquer for the first point for
Bradkin here in game number two. Both of
these players looking to remain
undefeated here in Hartford.
>> So, I will say I'm very impressed with
Mom's Sky as we listen to the player
comps. Every time he does something or
goes into an interaction, he's already
predicting what Brady Kin's going to do.
In that instance, if you were listening,
he said, "Show me the minus4." And there
it was. And earlier he was like, "You're
going to be rude and gust me now." And
then Brady can gusted him. So he's very
clearly uh used to this matchup. Perhaps
maybe used to it with Diana being across
the table, but it's still something
where you can tell a lot of reps uh into
this card pool have been played.
>> And now Brady can able to develop the
Vex
>> uh six
>> at that northern battlefield with the
Thousand Tailed Watcher. So, this is a
little bit of a problem for Moms Sky.
Each of these units being played will be
stunned while Vex is at the battlefield.
Another King initiate will come out
getting a card, buffing up the
Apothecary off that Pride Stalker
trigger.
>> Now, that's actually a very important
buff on the Apothecary. There's only one
energy available to Bradykin. That makes
the Apothecary go above Gust range. And
now by playing a second unit, you have
the option to go in and get rid of the
Vex. Yes, you're going to lose your
unit, but getting rid of the Vex is so
important that this is a very worthy
trade.
>> Absolutely.
>> So, we get the Vex apathetic off, but
Gust is going to bounce back that pit
rookie.
>> Uh, yes.
going to 10. So,
>> but something that has been pretty rare
>> for Mom's Sky.
>> I'm good.
>> Yeah, playing around that gust, making
sure you get rid of the Vex. I'm so
impressed with the way that Mom's Sky
navigates this matchup. Uh whether it's
making sure that there's enough cards in
hand for when the spirits are going to
be impactful to making sure that you get
rid of the key cards at the moment that
you need to.
>> Sure. Legends
>> breath [snorts] taking out that
irresistible faith fula damage to the
initiate.
>> Um
>> able to draw off that Ezreal legend once
again. Here comes
>> another watcher.
>> Another thousand tailed watcher for
Bradykin.
>> And that is going to be enough to take
out the backline for Moms Sky
>> as the other watcher moves back. It's
three to two going back over to Moms
Sky. board wiped and staring at
2,000tailed watchers in the backline.
That is not something you love to see.
>> Yeah. And if you're watching at home and
you're kind of curious about that
interaction, maybe you're new to
Riftbound, the damage put on the
Bellow's Breath stays and does not clear
until a combat happens when the Thousand
Tail Watcher comes down and gives the
minus three might to a minimum of one.
That means that the Kinkyu Initiate goes
to one might and then has one damage
still on it, which is enough to kill it.
So, you do not have to uh die from the
damage right away. You can combine it
with minus effects like that. It's a
neat interaction if you're new to
Riftbound. So, keep an eye out for it.
>> Sabotage coming out for Mom's Sky as we
look at a double star cross hand.
>> Oh, can a double star cross hand, but
also this is the second time this
weekend on a broadcast that we have seen
that angller beast come in from people's
sideboards. That scary fish is
uh apparently the new tech for maybe
dealing with some of these go wide
decks. Again, maybe predicting
popularity increases from Azir or Victor
after their performances in Utre.
>> Yeah, that Angler Beast so good against
the tokens.
>> I mean, you're looking at right now it's
going to likely come down and just
bounce this board.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely right because
both units developed on the back line
for Moms Sky. Just two might total right
now after that buff from pit rookie but
Bradykin has the thousand tailed watcher
moving in.
>> He'll score a couple points.
>> I trigger seat
>> the Vex reinforcing the aspirin climb. A
card off of seed of power and Brady into
the points lead for the first time in
this match. And there's the angller
beast.
>> The pit rookie and the sentry back to
mom's sky hand. And look at these
battlefields. 12 might and 11 might
respectively
represented at the battlefields for
Brady Ken. And this is getting tougher
and tougher for Moms Sky. Brady Brady
Ken of course playing against that clock
as you mentioned. Need to try to lock
this game two up.
>> Yeah, the big difference between game
one and game two is that in game two,
these watchers have given Brady Ken
actual might on the board to work with.
game one for a large part of the game it
was simply Ezreal and/or bewitching
spirit and yes you can get some points
or try to conquer with those but you're
not really going over the top of things
that means you're relying on removal and
then maybe sneaking them in. That's why
we saw the Bradykin was at one point for
a large portion of game one here in game
two. Getting the big might units means
that you can be aggressive. And we're
already seeing Brady Kin all the way up
to six
>> at six. And Mom's Sky just fully
developing on that last turn to try and
make a big push on the next turn.
Bewitching Spirit
>> going to rip a card. And there's only
two in hand.
>> And it's a double. Bewitching Spirit.
>> No runes open for Mom Sky. No hand left.
>> Passing over.
Massive amounts of might. Brady Ken
threatening to win here with a double
hold.
>> Yeah, now we are seeing Momms Sky
playing from the top deck. It's not
where you want to be. Moms Sky was very
good in game one and making sure this
was not the game state that he entered.
Actually did, I think, a very good job
of trying to avoid it here in game two.
But uh again, unfortunately with
Bradykin finding both Watchers, being
able to get the Watchers Bellow combo
off at least once early on to slow down
the board presence of Mound Sky meant
you had to commit more cards to the
board and we have just hit the natural
attrition stage.
>> Sure, I pass.
>> Okay, so we're moving into Aspirant's
climb.
>> Sure.
>> 13 might in total for Brady Kin there.
The Bewitching Spirit and the Vex fall.
Thousandtailed Watcher left alone, but
Vex off the board,
>> which means that Moms Sky can play units
and they will not be stunned immediately
when playing them. The Rengar Trophy
Hunter still in the backline moving in
to start a showdown with that Thousand
Tailed Watcher at Aspirit's Climb. Here
comes the Apothecary ambushed in
>> plus one might
>> again
>> for Rengar.
All right, I will
>> be eight might to seven in total.
>> If you're wondering what's happening
here, the apothecary
>> went uh ambushed in,
>> gave the thrill of the hunt trigger or
not thrill, excuse me, the pridealker
trigger from the legend of Rengar and
then he returned just the apothecary
back and replayed it. So that's why it
went from plus one to plus two and why
you saw the six energy expended. They
kind of shortcut it.
If you're wondering, that's what the
interaction was.
>> Uh, the star cross unfortunately stops
>> discard the apothecary.
>> The conquer from Mom's Sky. And now
Brady Ken is just back to
>> ripping cards from the hand of Mom's Sky
is already
>> going to do it. We are going to game
three. Brady can
>> sending us to a decider. Both of these
players again looking to remain
undefeated. And it's worth noting that
both of these players have made a top 16
appearance at a regional qualifier.
These are seasoned players at this
point. They are familiar with this
pressure on day two. And for game three
should be interesting. Charmer, we've
got the arena's greatest forms sky
>> and Brady Ken will be playing with the
frozen Fortress. So this game
>> will be a little bit quicker with that
arena's greatest. Yeah, this is I think
going to be the tightest of the three
games.
>> Game one, we saw Moms Sky use that deis
to make sure the the hand was always
full. Game two with Brady Kin both going
first and having Aspirants climb meant
that Moms Sky had a slower start by
going second as well as had to score
more points to try to win. But now Moms
Sky is back on going first and has
Arena's greatest.
If the Moms Sky can get units down like
we're seeing with uh this double pit
rookie
>> and get some points early stay on the
board, Moms Sky could take this. Brady
is going to need to have every gust or
every answer at the moment
>> that it's needed. We're going to see a
stack deck now. And again, this is
likely looking for a gust if there's not
already one in hand
>> cuz these early points are critical.
>> Another stack deck. Yeah, the double pit
rookie start here for Mom Sky. Double
stack deck for Brady Ken as that pit
rookie will conquer
>> at the Northern Battlefield. Two early
points here
>> for Mom Sky.
>> Mom Sky cannot be happy about that.
>> I'm sorry. I didn't mean to cut you off,
but that was such a backbreaking
double stack deck to not find the single
Gust that you need in this arena's
greatest start. they uh got on the
battlefield, but on top of that have two
units in base, one of them also
ungustable with the hopeful. So, as far
as starts go,
>> uh that was catastrophic for Brady.
>> Yeah, you're absolutely right. Nothing
in play yet either for Bradykin. We'll
continue to dig a little bit here. The
stupify
>> will give the pit rookie minus one
drawing a card. And there's the wages of
pain to clear the arena's greatest. and
Bradykin going to create a gold. All
three stacked deck early here in this
game, but Mom Sky has the green light.
>> No ready runes for Bradykin and two
units in that backline.
>> Yeah, this is absolutely going to be a
double conquer turn. Also, the sabotage,
so you get to see what you have to play
around going forward. And you see
something that is a big green light.
There is no units in the hand of
Bradykin. There is wages. There is the
fountain, which sprite fountain is
representative of units, but they uh are
just temporary. So, when I'm looking at
this, I really feel like uh the choices
are either Starcross or the Sprite
Fountain. The Sprite Fountain because
it's their only way to contest on a
battlefield.
>> Yep. And and that's the choice. Uh, and
I was just about to say and when you see
those two copies of the list, even your
your hopeful is still going to be too
small to actually hold. So, I really
like getting rid of the only source of
actual might in the hand of Brady.
>> Be great start continues for Mom Sky.
Exactly what he wanted here in this game
three as the pit rookie
>> will move in first to the Southern
Battlefield. Up to three points
>> goes Mom Sky.
>> Of course, the hopeful still available
>> to get that fourth point at the arena's
greatest. And we'll see how Moms Sky
develops further past these double
conquers here.
>> Now, the the one kind of weird thing
that you have to play around is you do
know Brady Kin still has the bellows and
the two copies of the list. So you don't
want to put yourself in a situation
where a repeated bellows plus list
activations is a complete blowout. And
that's why we're going to see only one
unit at each location. It is the safest
way to play around the list bellows com
uh combo.
>> So here we go. The list coming out
calling buildwater. And with that damage
from the frozen fortress,
>> each of the units there getting a damage
dealt at the start of each beginning
phase. Pit rookie with the might being
reduced is killed
>> and the battlefield cleared.
>> Stupid.
>> Using the list in combination with
frozen Fortress to kind of make it
impossible to hold is a wonderful combo
for Bradykin as this game progresses. Uh
again, Momms Skyy's plan, however, is
likely just to try to uh force a double
conquer every turn as opposed to get any
sort of hold points. Uh again, I'm
concerned at this point about Mom's Sky
cards in hand. So far, the start has
been everything Mom Sky wants in terms
of playing units, getting them on
battlefields, rinse, repeat, get your
points. But I believe Mom Sky is
starting to get very low because we
haven't seen cards like Kai'Sa to get
those cards back.
>> So now Gust attempting to bounce back
that hopeful after the stupify did bring
that Nox's hopeful at the battlefield to
three might.
>> Oh, I think that's a thrill of the hunt
in the hand.
which might be a consideration just to
save the unit because you're so low on
cards.
>> Definitely contemplating the play. Also
has the inferna in hand as well, but
>> the bounce will go through. Hopeful back
to moms sky's hand. Ezreal
>> Prodigal Explorer and pass
>> legend ability use a card. And here
comes the Vex in the backline
>> for Bradkin. finally able to develop a
unit here in game three.
>> And I think that was a Kai'Sa survivor
that was just picked up from Moms Sky,
which will help with potentially the
card problem. Might consider
accelerating it this turn cuz it's the
only turn you'll be able to do it. You
have to assume Vex is going to land on a
battlefield next turn.
>> The window of opportunity there
currently and as you mentioned could be
closing very soon.
And also Brady can no runes up right now
for any interaction.
>> Uh we'll go here.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. To the fortress.
>> Like the hopeful to the fortress here
because if you're going to accelerate
this Kai'Sa, you don't want Kai'Sa on
the fortress.
>> You want them to expend more resources
to try to get rid of it. It's not likely
going to stick around.
>> Uh there is also an argument to be made
about not doing the Kai'Sa.
But again, with this being your only
window of opportunity
to get the accelerate off, it it's
really hard to turn that down,
especially when you're so short on cards
at this stage of the game.
>> Yeah, just four cards left in hand for
Mom Sky.
>> We know the Kaiso is there. Has another
hopeful and inferna in hand. And you can
see Brady can just just itching here. He
knows the clock is ticking and he's way
behind in points. So, he knows that he
needs to get through this game quickly
if he wants any chance.
>> So,
>> we get into overtime.
>> So, the other option here for Mom's Sky
with the Kai'Sa if that is the thrill of
the hunt in hand. You're at uh 1 2 3 4 5
6 seven runes. You could accelerate the
Kai'Sa to the greatest and then if Brady
can takes the bait and deals with the
frozen waste or frozen fortress, excuse
me.
This does feel like slow playing the
clock, please.
>> And Bradykin mentioning that this feels
like slow playing, which is a valid
mention because right now if they go to
the overtime rules,
>> there would have been
>> uh a victory to Mom's Sky cuz he's up by
two. What I was going to say is if the
Kai'Sa was accelerated, you'd still have
up for the thrill and then that could
[music] go to the other spot and get a
conquer on the opponent's turn.
>> But didn't accelerate. Kai'Sa decided to
just leave three up instead.
So wages of pain the play for Brady
canin would be three damage to the Nox's
hopeful and the thrill of the hunt comes
out the signature spell for Rengar and
Hopeful is moving into
>> the arena's greatest getting that
additional might from the pride stalker
trigger
>> and we conquer up to six for Mom Sky
>> in striking distance here in game three.
A second list coming down. Knox is the
tag named swing here.
>> And here comes Vex into that northern
battlefield. It's enough to take down
the shrunk. Knox is hopeful.
>> Um
>> Brady up to two points.
Kaisa remains in the backline for Mom
Sky
and still five more runes to work with
for Brady Ken. What more do we have on
this turn? Is there a way to answer
Kai'Sa?
So, in a strange turn of events,
>> Brady Ken currently only has three cards
in hand, which is rather low for Ezreal.
>> That's about to go up by one after this
starcross is discarded and Ezreal draws
two.
>> Uh, there is two copies of the list, so
you could also activate the legend. It
was just interesting that for a brief
moment there, Brady Kin was at a measly
three.
>> Play Sprite Fountain.
>> Yes.
>> So, now we see the Sprite Fountain
coming out. Ready Sprite for
>> Brady
>> in the base. Where does it go?
>> Put it here
>> up to that northern battlefield.
>> We'll leave seven might at the arena's
greatest. Another card picked up off
that Ezreal Legend ability. We pass back
over to Moms Sky. No runes open for
Brady Kenn. And keep in mind that
Ringguard trophy hunter is still an
option in the champ zone for Mom Sky.
>> So it's three
>> double conquer and it's over.
You do still have to deal with the Vex.
That's the the big hurdle for Mom's Guy
right now. What I do find interesting
from Bradykin is the sprite token going
over to the arena's greatest as opposed
to the fortress if only because if you
think this is going to go to time, you
want to try to catch up on points so
that your opponent can't win by two. But
Bradykin, I think, is properly
identifying that overtime doesn't matter
if I lose before the clock runs out. And
you have to make sure that whatever
plays Moms Sky has, they're difficult to
go over the top of that Vex on the
greatest. Uh, sprite plus Vex is not
enough to account for a punch burst, but
I think if Moms Sky had one, that would
have been a windmill slam play here to
go into that spot. So instead,
we wait to see what Moms Sky chooses to
do. We know there's the hopeful and
inferna
and I couldn't quite see what the third
card was.
>> Sure.
>> And we are going to see a trade. Kai'Sa
for Vex.
What is next? There's the Ringuard
Trophy Hunter to the Northern
Battlefield with the Sprite. Mom Sky
conquering up to seven.
>> If there's a red pike, oh, it's the
apothecary. Okay. I say a red pike would
get the job done here because you could
pay the three and then pay the power.
eyes. I get a sprite
channel two.
>> All right, so Braden getting another
spite off the or sprite off the fountain
>> and has to deal with the Rengar
>> at that northern battlefield.
>> All right, lots of ways to deal with it
because I did see another star crossed I
believe in hand. There's also another
Vex apathetic.
So we could see a situation where
>> move here pass focus. The starcrust is
actually just used on the sprite token
so that you don't have to return
anything
>> and Brady can also putting this Ezreal
out there. I think this is fine because
again you need to catch up on points if
you're worried about things going to
overtime.
>> Flourish on Rengar.
>> Okay, deadly flourish would be dealing
three damage to the Rengar. Now the
sprite moves in threatening a trade at
Arena's greatest and the grim apothecary
coming down with the ambush
>> onto the arena's greatest. That's four
might for the apothecary off of
pridealker.
>> Brady has to have some sort of answer
for the apothecary or else mom sky will
just win when it comes back off of the
hold.
So, this might be a forced
star cross
>> or
needed to see what was in the hand.
Anything like a stupify. Yep. Single
bellows.
>> There's the bellows. He's got the
answer. The northern battlefield
cleared. No units left in play for Mom
Sky. And Vex apathetic back down on a
battlefield for Brady. And
>> the chosen champ has been used. We're
just under four minutes to go here in
round nine in Hartford.
>> All right, this I think has to be for
Mom's Sky. Just play as much might as
possible and pass. I believe there is 10
only nine runes available. So, uh that
should still be enough for Rengar plus
double hopeful pass and then just hope
that Brady can cannot answer everything
in your base.
Two cards.
>> Two cards.
>> It looks like double Nox is hopeful.
>> Just going to do double hopeful. Save
the Rengar.
>> Rengar being at hand is known
information. So
>> yeah,
>> I feel like saving that feels a little
awkward. if only because you know that
your opponent is playing around it.
Uh perhaps you're saving it in case uh
Bradykin develops something to the
arena's greatest. And then what you
could do is you could run one of the
hopefuls in to the fortress, clear the
ambush the Rengar to the other side as
>> so now the star cross bouncing a hopeful
and Ezreal. Ezreal coming back out right
away.
could go back to that battlefield.
That's the contemplation here.
>> I'll replay it here. Sorry.
>> And that is going to be the call.
>> Discard draw. I will discard
>> Gust.
>> Brady will pick up another two cards
after discarding the Gust. Has five
runes to play with.
>> Hopeful.
>> Flourish. Hopeful.
>> Stupify plus deadly flourish takes out
the other Noxis. Hopeful. And we go back
over to Mom's Sky with Vex still on the
battlefield at seven to four with two
minutes on the clock.
>> This is why I think I would have
preferred also just playing that Rengar
from hand. I don't think that you can
count on Bradykin falling for the bait
and putting another unit on the other
side. And more importantly, you'd still
enter this turn with at least one unit
up. And if you're not crashing in to get
rid of the Vex, which I think would have
been valid at a minimum, sending it to
the greatest draws you a card as well.
You don't obviously score the point, but
you're low on cards in hand. Giving
yourself additional outs, I think, would
have been beneficial. So, we'll see if
the play pattern changes this time
around. But last turn, uh, I felt like
perhaps Mom Sky should have just played
as much might as possible and said,
"Okay, answer everything.
because now we're back to square one.
And as long as that Vex is there, you're
out of options that you can do
immediately.
>> Vex is such a menace in this format. One
of the
better units coming out of Unleash. So
difficult to deal with sometimes.
Limiting your opponent's options. And it
is just going to be another development
turn here. All the might with the Rengar
hopeful and the pit rookie.
>> So this is what I would have loved to
have seen. [laughter]
>> Well, you get it this time, Charmer. It
is one turn after, but we do see all
that might developed. It's Rengar that
is buffed. So a total
>> of seven plus six, 13 might on that back
line for Mom Sky. And Brady can now
within two points. It's 7 to five
>> with that clock still ticking. Closing
in on overtime.
>> Repeat bellows. Two damage to each.
>> Oh, here comes the bellow's breath. Two
damage to the backline. The pit rookie
down.
>> Another card off of the Ezreal legend.
>> The Noxus list minus the hopeful.
>> There goes hopeful off of the list.
>> Um,
>> still a lot of options available to
Brady to slow this down.
>> That's the Noxus list. replay it as cat.
>> Oh, the pack of wonders getting another
list back out. Being able to replay it.
>> Oh, another pack of wonders. Replay the
list again.
>> And that buff from the pit rookie is the
only thing keeping this Rengar alive at
the moment.
>> What does he have?
>> Fizz.
>> Oh, Fizz
>> into Stoop.
>> Here it comes. Fizz into Stupify. The
backline is cleared yet again.
>> It's impossible. Brady Kin
>> um pass.
>> Yeah, and unfortunately I think Brady
just realized it's impossible for him to
win because the timer ran out,
>> but he can force a draw.
>> Mom Sky likely does not have an answer
for what is on the battlefield. So Brady
will score that hold point when it comes
back.
>> What does Mom Sky have once again? just
has to.
>> You are correct.
>> Develop that Vex continues to be a
menace.
>> There almost certainly is. There might
be two. There's one.
And that is a a look of out of options
on the face of mom's sky [laughter] at
the moment. I have definitely been there
more times than I would like.
Thinking through is there any way to get
this last point and or is there any way
to get rid of what's on the frozen
fortress because that would be another
way you could try to secure a win.
However, that Fizz in the base also is
threatening a conquer point which would
still take Mom Sky out of that twopoint
lead.
>> I can't hear you.
>> Sorry. Have you played Stupify or
Bellow's Fizz?
>> Uh with Fizz, I played the Stupify.
>> Oh, you're right.
>> Oh,
>> you're right. Uh
>> so that stupify should stay down there.
>> Yeah. And then this
>> Yeah. All good.
>> So judge identifying that the Fizz
played the stupify. So that was what
needed to be recycled. And the bellow's
breath is still in the trash.
>> The specs card is
>> all is
>> good here.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I think it's just
>> quick easy fix.
[snorts]
>> Yeah. Mom's Sky saying, "I don't know
that I can win
>> that Vex card is." And then trailed off.
And I think we're all thinking the same
thing. Uh it is a problem if you are an
ambush based deck.
>> All right. So, this is turn
>> Sky just going to pass back over to
Brady. Ken
>> holding up to six. Has Fizz in that back
line. Just affirm I'm not losing in my
mind. It is you need to win by two
points otherwise it is a draw. Okay. So
getting another point doesn't matter.
>> Yeah. Unfortunately, even if Brady pin
was running
>> like ride the wind tricks or things like
that, even if Brady pin uh went or Brady
pin went to the greatest, you can't then
like ride the wind back over to another
spot that you're already occupying. So
>> just no way to win from here.
And that is going to do it.
>> Wow.
>> What a game. And I tell you, it really
felt like such a great start for Mom's
Sky until that Vex was able to get on
the battlefield and the whole
>> complexion of that game changed.
>> Well, and specifically the second Vex. I
think that mom's guy did a great job of
getting rid of the the first,
>> but
>> yeah, they didn't pick an
>> that uh that second Vex was very
problematic. And I really do feel like
potentially Moms Sky had a window where
when Bradykin had all of the runes
exhausted and you had the option to do
the Rengar, hopeful, hopeful, uh it's
not ideal. you don't feel good about
that and I can understand why they chose
to just do hopeful hopeful but I really
feel like as long as Vex is on the board
and you know in your hand you don't have
your challenges you don't have your your
natural answers to get rid of the Vex
>> you have to just play enough might and
hope something lives that you can trade
with the Vex. So, I I think that it
probably doesn't change the outcome in
the end, but it really feels like that
might have been a line that when Moms
Sky watches it back, they'll reconsider.
>> Yeah. And it's interesting because
you're in a tough spot there. These are
two fantastic players again that have
been in the top 16. They're undefeated
going into that game. They're searching
for the best of. They're looking to
finally make the top eight. there's a
lot of pressure and and it was just such
an interesting back and forth game and
really loved seeing the pack of wonders
plus the list. I think that was crucial
multiple times in that game to really
keep Bradykin in it.
>> Oh, absolutely. And we saw it yesterday
utilized by Pike. Yeah, but I got to say
in this Ezreal list, being able to reuse
the list over and over again with
effects like Bellow's Breath or some of
the other targeted damage, uh allowing
you to kind of set up your mini watcher
combos in some turns as well. You were
able to keep everything clean. And then
on top of that, the list because you're
choosing an enemy unit means that your
legend ability is essentially always
online. So
>> yes,
>> obviously the list designed for Pike,
but Ezreal reaping the benefits as well.
>> That is absolutely right. Well, let's
take a quick recap here of this match.
>> Thank you so much, Josh and Charmer.
That was a very interesting match with a
lot of key moments. Actually made it
kind of hard to identify some of the
biggest ones. So, we're going to take a
look at game number three cuz there's
actually one turn that I think really
set the page or rather the pace for how
the rest of the game plays out. This is
when Mom Sky is making a pivotal
decision of am I going to play the
Inferna at ambush speed to uh go to the
battlefield and hold for another point.
So far, Bradykin has hit with um the uh
the stupify as well as a gust. So, it's
been targeted twice. This Nox is hopeful
is going to go back to hand currently
for Mom. Sky has a reaction window, has
the runes up to play that. Let's play
this out here cuz you'll see even the
hesitation like Moms Sky knows like I
have the the chance to do this. I don't
think I want to do it. I want to save
the Inferno for a different play in the
future. Lets it go off. And this is a
point denied then that would have been a
hold point for Moms Sky. Maybe could
have been uh an opportunity for Moms Sky
to then, you know, close out the game
later on because was at seven for quite
a while. We see that later on other
turns he's able to push in and do a
little more. Um, but unfortunately that
time now the boss has hit the field.
Let's pause here because this is the
bane of every Rengar's existence. They
talked about it in game two. The cast is
recovering it. Getting past one is
doable. Getting past the second one's
tough. But even when one single Vex
apathetic hits the field immediately
once it's out of battlefield, you're
going to slow down your opponent. And
this kind of pressures Mom Sky to try
and score really fast. Had already been
scoring pretty fast up to this point.
Um, but now the pressure's really on.
We're going to jump ahead though towards
the end of the game cuz basically what
happens in every turn after this as
let's take a look at the next clip here.
Every turn Bradykin is able to answer
the units from Mom Sky. Charmer was
mentioning the fact that maybe there was
that turn you could go Rengar Knox
hopeful. Knox is hopeful. There's
another line where you go inferno with
the Noxis hopefuls, but getting three
bodies on the board in any previous turn
might have been enough for Moms Sky to
get it, but Momscout chose to go two
units for a couple of turns. Bradykin's
clearing them out. But then this is the
final turn. You see uh actually I
believe this is not the correct one. Can
we go to right before Yeah, here we go.
Perfect. So that one right before the
time's about to run out. You see Brady
can have a perfect answer to the three
units. Let's play it out from here
because I want to walk through exactly
how Brady can handles this field. This
is the first time Moms Sky actually
commits three units to the board. It
just accepts I have to play the Rengar
to base. The trophy hunter is great as
ambush, but sometimes you just need to
play it to your base instead. Still has
the inferna in hand. Now Bradykin is
going to start off by uh the bellow's
breath spreading damage or actually just
the the double bellow's breath to clear
the pit ie and now there's two damage
marked on these. Then the list congrats
no hopeful. You just made it taken out.
And then this is the really fun part. A
lot of Ezreal players are on this
version of the deck. It's not going to
surprise a lot of people but the pack of
wonders. First one hits the field.
Returning the list, playing the list.
Rengar, congrats. You just made the
list. Going to go minus two. And then
again, the second one. And uh it's
incredible. This is a picture perfect
hand from Bradykin. Also has the Fizz to
reupify. That's minus five might plus
the two damage. Rengar goes down. So you
see the Mom Sky was a little afraid to
play three units a turn because Ezreal
has a lot of answers. But if you just
keep letting Ezreal target your stuff,
Bradykin was drawing an extra card every
turn with the uh legend ability because
Moms Sky just didn't want to commit
three units, was only committing two.
And I think that Moms Sky if at any
point had just committed three might
have been a different ballgame. Also
ambushing that Inferno in might have
been a different ball game. You can save
your Thrill of a Hunt for a future turn.
Tight tight margins of error in this
type of match. Two very very impressive
players though. It was a draw, so both
of them still technically undefeated. 80
and one. Uh, very, very fun match to
watch though. Watch out for the double
pack of wonders. That's all I got. Back
to the casters.
Double pack of wonders indeed. It is a
dangerous thing. And as much as we hate
to see the draw, as Kangas mentioned,
these players are still undefeated. So,
they are still in the running for the
best of and a shot at the top cut. What
a match to start here in the day two.
>> Listen, if this is going to be
indicative of the type of play that
we're going to see for the rest of the
day, I am incredibly excited because uh
I thought that game was navigated very
well. Uh yes, like we can nitpick about
what Moms Sky could have done at the
end, but I was incredibly impressed with
the way that Moms Sky played through
game one, understanding the assignment
with the deis and one also making me
look good cuz I was like, "Hey, maybe
you should be bouncing this." and then
he started doing it and he won the game.
So, uh, you love to see that, but I just
feel like, you know, Kanga shouted out
double pack of wonders. We are in for a
pack of wonders as far as our gameplay
goes for the rest of day two.
Absolutely. Well, thank you so much for
tuning in, but don't go too far. We're
going to take a quick break and we will
be back for round 10 of 13 here in Swiss
of Hartford.
Hello everybody, Kangas here at the
Riftbound Regional in Hartford. I'm a
fan of puzzles. So, I created a puzzle
for some of the best players in the
world to solve. We got prismaticism here
across the table from me. Prismat,
you've never seen this puzzle before,
correct?
>> You kept the cards face down.
>> I kept the cards face down. It is now
time. You can reveal your cards. You
have two units that are going to be on
the field. You'll have three cards in
your hand, 12 runes, and zero points.
>> Your mission is to win in one turn.
>> I see.
>> Your opponent only has a singular Vex
Cheerless and nothing in hand. Nothing
that they're going to do outside of
holding this battlefield.
>> And I've got to score eight points in
one turn.
>> You got to score eight points in this
turn. Can you
>> This costs four. This costs four. This
costs two, but maybe three. And this
costs two.
>> Yep. So, you got two spellongers and a
ride the wind
>> with Yasua Wind Rider and Draven
Audacious.
>> Okay. I thought you were going to give
me six points and some garbage units and
some some [laughter] trash to try to win
with, but no, you got to get all aces.
This is a bit trickier. Okay. So, two
points can come from the battlefields.
Okay.
I like this. You're doing the math
already.
>> I can get
>> one from each of these. So, that's
another two points.
>> Mhm.
>> And then the spellers. Oh, I'm going to
have to re-equip them, aren't I?
>> Can I get them killed?
>> I could get It's plus zero. So, I could
get him killed cuz this is four. This is
six. So, the last two will have to come
from the speller ree equips then.
>> Mhm.
>> Interesting. Okay.
>> So, what are you thinking? What's the
sequence here?
>> So, this is four points coming from
here. That's going to cost five from
each, which means I can't use both of
these. Okay.
Uh, okay.
I also need to win combat.
Okay, then. It looks like everything's
falling into place now cuz I can
>> He figured it out. He He's backwards
engineered the line.
>> Yeah. So, I think I'm going to play and
equip both of these to Yasuo. I guess
the runes are okay. Yeah, I've got six.
So, that's going to cost eight and four
green.
Okay,
>> he'll go here. That'll be one.
>> Yes. So, you get your first point.
>> I'll ride the wind back to base. That's
his second move.
>> Yep.
>> Then this is his third move.
>> Mhm.
>> He'll give me three points.
>> Three. Exactly. Yep.
>> And then die.
Then I'll spend the last two equip to
the Draven.
>> Nice.
>> And then he'll go in,
>> win the combat.
>> Yep.
>> Win three points,
>> and then conquer for the last point. I
conquered both battlefields, so it
worked.
>> You got it. Eight points. Well done.
That I And I must say that was so much
faster. I had every caster try this out.
>> Okay.
>> And they all got there eventually.
Everyone was able to solve it. But that
was by far the fastest I've seen. So
talk me through like the the thought
process there. Like how were you able to
come to that conclusion so quickly?
>> Uh well, eight points in one turn is
pretty tough. So yeah, just reverse
engineering that. How do how do you even
get the points out of the what I have
available?
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. You're starting with the end goal
and then working your way backwards. I
think a lot of people got hung up on
like, oh, they can get to six points
consistently. How do you get the other
two and then you realize you got to
crash? Uh this is kind of a bait. You
know, like it's not actually doing
anything. It's basically just a fine.
>> No, you're never doing anything with the
ride. and the windswept hillock or the
hall of legends and even the yaso legend
don't do anything.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Not that is like with puzzles there's
like the start is easy and probably the
end is easy but then the middle is
somewhere tricky but if you get as much
done from the start and the end as you
can then it's a lot easier to figure out
the middle.
>> All right, we are live for another
interview here in Hartford. Got a
special guest that's on an incredible
run today in Hartford. You want to go
ahead and introduce yourself?
>> Uh yeah, I'm mom Sky. Um, best of Yaso
Atlanta. Now I'm playing Rengar. So fun
times.
>> Best of Yasawo. Now that is an awesome
feat. And now you're on Rengar, you
said. Now, first, before we kind of get
into what you chose today and what
you're running today, what is your
favorite legend? Is it one of these two?
>> Yeah, I like I like Yaso. I've been
playing League since like season two. Um
he's he's an OG. So started with him in
set one, got the best of in set two,
tried again in Vancouver and got second.
Uh so swapped it up now for Hardford on
Rengar.
>> There you go. And you're off to a great
start. I believe seven and0. Is that
right?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. So you are locked in day two.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Ready to go. And we know that back in
Vancouver, Rengar went all the way to
the top cut and to the finals and was
one game short of taking it all. So,
what are your goals right now looking
forward for this event?
>> Yeah, I mean getting best of and top 64,
maybe going for the top cut. That'd be
sick. Um Sam is also playing as Rengar
again. Last I checked he was 6o. So,
>> we're in the headtohead. Got to fight it
out tomorrow, I guess. So, see how it
goes, but
done well so far.
>> Hey, it's going to be a battle of the
juggernauts with you and Sam. Now, what
led you to switching out from Yasawo
into Rengar for Hartford?
>> Yeah, so I was 5-0 in Vancouver on Yaso
and then I lost three rounds in a row
and that sucks. Um, so I I had fun with
the list, but I was like, look, I need a
top 64. I'm gonna I'm gonna amp it up a
little bit. I saw Sam play it in
Vancouver. Um, it looked really fun, and
it has been really fun. Uh, so was just
tinkering with it. Seemed good into
quite a few things. So, it's it's a fun
deck. I like playing it. Uh, my
opponents have no idea what's going on
half the time, so can't complain.
>> There you go. Now, you said you like
playing it into some matchups. Can you
talk to us a little bit about some
matchups that you feel really
comfortable in and maybe some matchups
that you don't feel as comfortable in?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think Master E. Master E
is a rough one. I don't I haven't played
any today, so that's probably why I
haven't lost. Uh maybe I'm jinxing it
for round eight. I just played a civer.
That matchup's really fun cuz it's me
just slinging like units around and or
using my signature spell to like flash
stuff all over the place. So, that's a
it's a fun little matchup. It's it's a
little random, but we get to my opponent
and I are like, "Let's go gambling when
every other turn." So, it's it's fun.
>> Okay. Okay. Now, one last question. You
got any spicy tech that you've been
throwing out at anybody that you can
share with us, or is the list pretty
similar to what we saw?
>> Not really, but I I like my my 4Erunner.
Uh maybe I'll get a Toyota 4Erunner,
too. I got a couple of those guys.
They've served me well, so
keep it up.
>> Awesome. Well, we certainly appreciate
your time and best of luck throughout
the rest of the weekend. We'll see you
tomorrow in day two and hopefully all
the way through to a tough day.
>> Yeah, hopefully it's uh you see me at
the end of day two, too.
>> Yeah, that's what we want to see. Thank
you so much. Congrats on the great run
today.
>> Welcome back, Riftbounders. We are
getting ready for round 10 of Swiss here
at the Hartford Regional Qualifier. the
last regional qualifier of the unleashed
season. If you're just tuning in, we saw
a very interesting matchup last round
with Ezreal and Rengar, two of our
undefeateds, which was really cool to
see those two legends undefeated in day
one. But now we look forward into round
10 and it's really starting to be crunch
time for these players, Charmer. Yeah, a
lot of these players are trying to
ensure that they can keep a path to the
top eight, but they're also trying to
keep ahead of the rest of the pack when
it comes to the best of prizing. We know
that there's a lot of people vying to
win that coveted prize of being the best
player on a particular legend at these
events. And so, let's check in on the
best of victor race currently. And we
have a huge tie
>> at the top. A lot of players at 7 and
two.
>> That is quite the race right now for
Victor. What is that? Six players at 7
and two. All in the hunt. That's
exciting. I mean, this is going to be a
tight race over the last several rounds.
Charmer.
>> Yeah, and I'm being told that Dragon was
7-1, was the leader of this pack, but
just dropped a game in that round nine
of Swiss. And that's why we have this
big tie. And that's going to open things
up for all of the rest of the players
playing in day two. You know that
they're going to be hot on the tales of
Dragon, but that's not the only tight
race here. We do have the best of Vex
with five up in a big lead, but there's
still a lot of games to be played before
that top cut. And if five up were to
stumble a bit, players like MX Knicks or
Nightingale could close the gap. Yeah,
we saw Five Up get that awesome start
yesterday, 7-0 and then ended the day
with the draw, but clearly off to a
great start today, getting that eighth
win and really just has to keep this
momentum going to lock up the best of
Vex. But how about best of Pike and look
at Awesome Rosom up here, but he is in a
close race with Meu. Yeah, they are
obviously duking it out, but as I had
pointed out, uh, still quite a few
rounds to play before we get to the top
cut portion. And we did get to see
Senbon on the broadcast yesterday, and I
was impressed with their play as well.
So, don't count them out at 7 and two.
>> Yeah, that is absolutely right. They are
right there in the chase. So, let's see
what we've got next. It's the best of
Rexi and we've got a tie right now, 8
and one. So going to be interesting.
Couple 8 and one players and then two at
seven and two that are also right there
in the running.
>> Yeah, again this is the point in the
tournament where you have to win every
game. Every game matters when you're
trying to keep these best of because
there are so many players hot on your
heels. Uh I think that in this case
something must work is working very well
for them because something is working
there at the top. Well, how about this?
Tofu on top. 8-1 with Darius. And this
race not quite as tight. It's 8-1 down
to seven and two. And then that's it,
right? It's those two players that are
that are right there at the top. So,
we'll see if things tighten up as we get
through the end of the day.
>> Yeah, this is a situation where Asip
Tofu is essentially in the uh control
your own destiny position, but another
huge series of ties in this best of
Kai'Sa race. Yeah, I actually had the
chance to talk to Dear Ambbleina this
morning. Was pumped coming into this
day, too. Having great success and
really hungry for that best of. So,
right there in the running for this best
of Kai'Sa. Yeah, and Dark Lazero, I know
we saw on the broadcast yesterday as
well, currently in that top spot based
on tie breakers, but with so many seven
and twos, it's kind of anyone's game.
Yes, you see somebody down at position
193, but all it takes is for you to win
and the rest to lose and suddenly you're
in the front running.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And uh Misfortune best
of we've got Dr. Snuffles on top at 8
and one, but Jahuna not too far behind.
71 and one. Yeah, Jahuna not far behind.
And then also we do have two more
players there at 7 and two, but I think
that right now Dr. Knuffles again in
that control your own destiny position
is probably feeling the pressure knowing
that the person behind them has that
draw so that if they win and you also
draw then you have to go to tiebreers.
So even a draw doesn't keep you safe
because somebody else is already in that
same position. I just can't state enough
how cool the best of prizing is and how
much the community loves it. I mean it
is the talk of the town in Riftbound.
Now, we love best of prizing and we love
you, the community, and we want you to
make a vote for what match you want to
see featured here in round 10. So, we
could see Rexi and Pike there in match
A. We've got Azir or Annie in match B.
Yeah, all of these are really kind of
featuring people that are in that best
of hunt. We were just talking about Poke
on the Rex Eye. Uh, Meiru is currently
the leader for the best of Pike. And
then down below, as weird as it sounds
to say this, I believe Funks is also
tied with Prismat as far as the best of
goes. So, if that was the choice, we
would be watching somebody competing to
maybe steal one of those coveted Annies
from the demon known as Prismaticism.
[laughter]
He is on a run. Five best of Annies
looking for number six here in Hartford.
The vote leaning towards Pike and Rexi
though. Of course, Rexi got that first
top cut appearance last weekend in
Utrect and that is going to be the match
that you chose. So, Rexi versus Pike.
Poke versus Meu. Yeah, we're going to
start with that one. The viewers have
spoken and I'm very excited for this
because one, Rexi deserves some love.
She is the queen that she deserves to be
and has really had a a a showing ever
since Utrect. It was kind of a a deck
that I think when Spirit Forged came
out, people thought was going to be a
bit splashier. There was a lot of talk
about it and then it maybe
underperformed a bit during Spirit
Forged and then when Unleashed came
around, received some help. people
thought, okay, might make a resurgence.
And and maybe she was just tunneling,
burrowing her way along to the finish
line and is now popping out to show
everybody what she can do. Well,
speaking of burrowing, let's check out
this Rexi deck list and what we're
getting into. Absolutely love this deck.
Love the RNG factor of the Legend and
that ability to get card advantage and
find what you need off the top. But one
thing this deck can do very well,
Charmer, is it can flood the board. It
can flood the board and then it can do
something else. Whenever I think about
Rex Eye, there's one card that comes to
mind. I love it. It's one of my favorite
cards in the order domain and it is
Undertan because when you flood the
board, you want to be able to do
something with all those units. And
while Undertitan gives all of your other
units plus two might for the turn. So,
this represents uh a lot of additional
might if you do flood the board. It's
also very very satisfying when you get
to play it off of the legend ability
because you can play it cheaper. And
there's just no better feeling in the
world than when you pull that off.
That's absolutely right. Not to mention
that additional energy that you can gain
off the Undertain when it's revealed off
of something like your legend ability or
the signature spell. But something that
I really want to talk about here is that
Falling Star because in a matchup like
this against Pike with things like the
Bewitching Spirit or Ezreal, Fizz, cards
like that that Pike [music] wants to
bounce back to hand if it gets stuck in
base. That Falling Star could be the
opening you need to take it out before
the cycle continues.
>> Yeah, I absolutely agree with you.
Falling Star could be the key card as
far as cleaning up those backline pesky
units that Pike is trying to save.
And speaking of pike, we're going to
take a look at that list. Now, we do see
the three of bewitching spirit that is
uh pretty standard here. But the other
thing that jumps out to me about this
pike list as opposed to the one that we
saw in the broadcast yesterday is the
inclusion of Rengar. The red Rengar, the
pouncing Rengar is so good in lists just
in general, but it gets additional value
when you can return it to hand and kind
of represent this combat trick that is
plus five might every time you're
attacking.
>> Yeah, that is so so good. And another
thing that really stands out to me,
Charmer, the blighted battle axe.
Something that we haven't been seeing a
lot in the top decks, but this is a deck
that can really put out a lot of might.
Yeah, the bladed battle axe is going to
be something that you use to ensure that
your conquers work. Uh, one of the
reasons I think the pike that we saw in
the broadcast yesterday ultimately
didn't win that series was because yes,
it did great things with comboing the
pack of wonders using bewitching spirit
to strip the hand, but it struggled to
sometimes score or maintain a board
position. Bladed battle axe helps you
with that as well as the inclusion of
Ferris 4runner. That's another big might
unit that's also sticky if your opponent
answers it. The deathnell gives you
additional might. So unlike the one that
we saw yesterday when Senbon was
playing, Miro here has a lot of ways to
keep might on the board. Yeah, this deck
feels a little bit more aggressive. It's
got a lot of additional might and it's
going to be interesting to see how this
plays out. But I believe the players are
ready and we are ready to get down to
the feature match area for round number
10.
here in [music] Hartford. So much on the
line for these players,
Poke and Meu.
>> Game one, Candle Lit Sanctum for Poke
and [music] it'll be Rippers Bay for
Meu.
>> So, one thing that I want to pay
attention to [music] as we navigate game
one is whether or not Poke tries to plan
around the Pack of Wonders [music] combo
because the the thing is Miro isn't
running Pack of Wonders, right? We did
not see that in the main deck. you're
just relying on the legend ability when
you're talking about bewitching spirit.
And I think Mero's decided that that's
good enough. I don't need to go overkill
into that. I can just play a good chaos
fury base, right? Because that was
historically a a very strong combat
oriented domain combination. That's why
Draven was so good. That's why Annie
continues to be good. But then also just
run bewitching spirit and make use of it
with the legend ability. So if Poke
maybe overemphasizes trying to keep
cards in hand, expecting pack of
wonders, it could slow down their start.
Whereas normally Rexi, as we've talked
about, wants to flood the board. So I I
think we'll learn a lot about what Poke
expects in this matchup if they are
playing a little bit more timid or if
they still just go all out right out of
the gate. Yeah, it is interesting
because when we saw Sinbon on stream
yesterday, he did have that pack of
wonders. And so we don't see it here. We
see Meu playing a list that can develop
even more might. We're going to have Meu
starting out with that traveling
merchant.
>> And now going over to Poke with the
faithful manufacturer to get multiple
bodies on board. That when playability
getting the recruit token there in the
backline as well.
And again, multiple units means
potential to conquer multiple times the
following turn. Get that additional
bonuses from cards like Undertitan
later. This is a great start for poke
when you are on the rune because you get
to play two units. And if you've got
something that buffs your might or deals
with the merchant, then you can just get
the double conquer and start that, you
know, two point per turn cadence
incredibly early.
>> We see this.
>> I'm going to replay the unit. Little bit
of ramp going on here for Miru
>> going into Rippers Bay. Getting that
opening point and then bouncing back the
merchant with the legend. And because it
was at Rippers Bay, Meu was able to pay
one energy to channel an additional rune
and then just replaying the traveling
merchant as we go back over to Poke.
Yeah, and that works out great for Meiru
because it protects the merchant. Uh
Poke now doesn't need to use any
additional might to get this double
conquer. So they have that going in
their favor. They will also likely get
this uh candle lit Sanctum trigger
because there's nothing Mero will be
able to do with no energy open.
>> Um
>> that being said, we're going to see also
a reinforce after the conquer on Ripper
base. So just trying to take that option
away from Miro and and force them away
from their preferred battlefield. I like
it from Poke.
>> Yeah, very interesting line early. Do we
see the Rex eye trigger after the candle
the candle lit sanctum is conquered by
poke for the second point
>> from candit.
>> So candle lit Sanctum resolving first
recycling both of the cards that were on
top. And now we see Shadows Call on
Falling Star
>> and Poke declining to play either of
those cards.
>> Well, the Falling Star can't even be
played because there are no fury runes
on the side of Poke noticeably here.
It's been an an awkward start as far as
the runes channeled, but uh you did get
to see the really cool interaction
between Sanctum and the void burer
because you can use Sanctum first to
kind of take a peek and then line
something up for your burrow. But in
Poke's case there, didn't like what they
saw the first time, so just recycled
both and then took an even deeper look.
And even when you're not selecting
stuff, this gives you a lot of vision
into your deck. You can filter your
draws and kind of sculpt your hand for
what you need.
So now back over to Meiru. We'll see if
he's able to get back on the rippers bay
>> as the traveling merchant will move in
>> trigger
>> seeker.
>> We know there are things like cleave in
Meiru's list. And we are going to see
the cleave now.
>> And it's going to be
an additional three might here for the
merchant. And that is enough to go over
the top and get back the rippers bay.
Miru up to two and reinforcing at the
rippers bay with that Ferris 4Erunner.
>> I see you.
>> And that is uh a very big play from
Meiru there. And it might speak to what
Poke was expecting from this pike. You
know, I talked about how you might
trying to be playing timid, worried
about the Boing Spirit, but also the
other pikes, as I said before with
Senbon, not very good at generating a
lot of might. Perhaps the cleave caught
Poke by uh surprise a bit there and then
seeing the Ferris 4runner come down as
well. We'll see how Poke responds. Does
finally get a Fury rune.
We're getting there. [laughter]
Poke up to three as he holds that
Northern Battlefield. Taking a look at
the hand here.
Hopeful in the backline, but that's
eight might that Miru is covering up
that Ripper's Bay with.
back.
>> Of course, the Ferris 4Runner will put
additional might in play when it goes
down.
All right, I like this from Poke
understanding I don't have enough
resources to go over top on the rippers
bay. So, I'm just going to take all of
my runes, turn them sideways, and play
as many units as possible
>> so that I have might. And given what we
just saw with the previous game in round
nine, I love this. Give yourself the
most options the following turn. Make
your opponent have the answer so that
you can uh you know, give yourself
options, right? You you are a unit-based
deck, so that means play as many units
as possible. Poke understands the
assignment. I love it.
>> Absolutely. Able to develop six might in
that back line
>> with units played last turn.
Now over to Mero. Holds up to three.
>> Both of these players eight and one
coming into
round number 10.
>> Is there a place where we can see the
time?
You just ask him.
>> And as they think through what to do
here, Meiru, I think, is trying to
figure out how to
>> respond or react to whatever Poke does
next turn. I think that's the critical
position here. If you're Meu, you've got
some units on the board. You don't have
to like overcommit a ton of units on
your side if you have reactions and or
even just actions that you can play
during a showdown to slow them down. But
you also kind of need to
guess what your opponent is going to do
in that situation so that you can
respond accordingly. Uh I like this move
of the merchant back to base just so
that you can cycle the card out of your
hand and
get something else. Uh we're going to
see the bewitching spirit strip a card
as well. Uh but it would not surprise me
if we see some Oh, okay. Never mind. And
I was going to say if we see some number
of
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Um, so
>> equipping this axe though because the
ferris waruner didn't conquer. This
should actually just
>> detach. They're missing that this is
supposed to unattach. Yes, it takes the
damage.
>> If he doesn't conquer, right? Yeah. If I
don't conquer, it takes four damage,
>> but it also unattaches. I think this is
what they're trying to clarify.
Oh, it does.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely it does
unattach.
>> And that's why I was that's why I was uh
a little bit curious by that play
because you're not going to have the
extra might for the hold. I was about to
say going into that and that's why I
paused. It wouldn't have surprised me if
Mu left a bunch of energy up for
reactive stuff.
>> But in this case now the 4Runner is just
left on an island.
>> Yeah, interesting play here. So
essentially the blighted battle axe just
getting developed. Yeah. So essentially
what should be happening here because it
was equipped is the axe goes on to the
4Runner when the turn ends because
4Runner has not participated in a
conquer it takes four damage. The axe
attack uh unattaches and then because it
has six might and it doesn't kill the
unit. It just sticks around and then the
damage heals because it's end of turn.
So ultimately, as you pointed out, Josh,
it's really just like you developed the
axe. But obviously, I think if Meiro
knew that it was going to unattach
there, then the choices would have been
a little bit different.
>> So once again, we'll see this nice
combination of the Candleit Sanctum and
that Rex Eye Legend.
>> Candlelet Sanctum first. Both cards once
again going to the bottom. Poke really
digging for some specific cards here.
And he finds Void Rush off the top. and
he is going to play that off the Rexai
legend ability.
>> And we'll get to look at another couple
of cards here.
>> Oh, it's the Undertan. That's two
energy.
>> Th This is exactly what you love to see
when you are playing Rex Eye. You do one
effect that reveals stuff. You do
another effect that reveals stuff that
gets you void rush, which lets you
reveal more. you reveal under Titan and
now that's going to becoming a uh a
crashing down Under Titan and it will
buff all of these units again. We see uh
the recruit tokens. We see the small,
you know, two energy drops, but they're
all going to be plus two might because
of this under Titan. And suddenly uh
Poke has an army that they have raised.
This will be an an easy way to get rid
of that Ferris Warrunner.
All right.
>> See the plus two might going out for uh
the undertitan entering play going on
all of the units.
And now Poke has to decide what
resources they want to expend.
>> In a situation like this, if you know
that you are going to lose some units
still to trade with the 4Runner, it
usually makes sense to use your smaller
units because they have the plus two.
>> And so that's exactly what Poke does.
Sends in two recruits. The mechs will
still be made at the base of Miu, but
again, I think Miu is wishing that that
trade was a bit more costly on Poke's
side. Was expecting to have 10 might
because of the axe. Forgot about the
unattached claws.
And uh Meu is still in a good position
to kind of claw their way back in the
following turn. That axe represents a
lot of additional reconquer power. It
makes these bewitching spirits a lot
less measly, but still we'll have to
keep an eye on whether that, you know,
potential misplay begins to haunt them.
>> So now Poke just going to further
develop with the chosen champion.
>> And Rexai Breacher is so important to
this deck. We've seen the popularity
rise in almost any fury list simply
because it allows you to give accelerate
to your chosen champions if you're not
running it as your chosen. But in Rex
Eye, because you're using your legend
ability and cards like void rush to
potentially play from banish, this also
gives any of those potentially
accelerate as well.
>> Yeah, unlimited possibilities with the
combination of that chosen champion and
the Rexside Legend.
That's fine.
>> We go back over to
>> Miru.
>> Does have a nice backline here as the
mechs were developed.
>> Not a lot of decks play it, so I don't
know what it
>> honestly. Chinese cards are the worst,
but
>> total of 10 might in the backline.
>> Still has that
>> battle axe there. That does represent a
possible four more might.
do see a fizz in hand for Meiru as well.
Something to
>> keep in mind as we move forward in this
match as the Bewitching Spirit will
>> go into the Ripper's Bay.
>> And up to four points goes Miru.
>> Yeah, right now Fizz doesn't have a ton
of targets, but Void Seeker is still
spicy enough. does represent killing
something on the battlefield as well as
drawing a card.
And we're gonna see Miro make some
decisions here
with the rest. I would not be surprised
if we see the battle axe on something
and then still going to the sanctum
because then it will have conquered and
you'll have all that bonus might
holding. Like that's the neat thing
about the battle axe is like on the turn
that you conquer you get the benefit of
going over top of whatever is there and
then for one turn you get that bonus
might for holding it just becomes a
detriment after the fact if you don't
have a way to unattach it and then
re-equip it somewhere else. Uh we did
not see any cards like angle shot in the
main deck for Miro. So likely just
relying on the axe for the conquerors
and some bonus hold. Uh, but all of that
being said, there is uh a fun
interaction with cards like Bewitching
Spirit where because of your legend
ability allows you to return a unit, you
could go in with the spirit and having
the axe attached and then return spirit
to your hand anyway cuz you want to
replay it and then you don't have to
worry about the axe killing your own
unit. But here, the axe is going to be
worn by a mech token instead.
>> Yeah, that spirit loop has started. Two
cards stripped from Poke's hand on this
turn down to just one card in hand as
Meiru conquers up to five
with the help of that battle axe. It's a
big unit on or a big unit with the mech.
Seven might with the battle axe.
Traveling merchant is going to reinforce
and Meiru hiding a card there as well.
Yeah, the candle sanctum will be very
tough for Poke to break through. Oh, and
here's the falling star to hit something
on the back line. Rexi Breacher plus the
manufacturer is down. We talked about
Falling Star being so important to hit
that back line coming into play here.
So, a lot just happened there. The card
that was hidden was the chosen champion.
So, we know that that's the red pike. Uh
the merchant when it moved to the
Sanctum, even though it wasn't part of
the conquerors, does still trigger the
cycle. So that allowed me to find
>> uh better cards. Then we see the falling
star take out two units, but notably one
of them being the Rex eye breacher, the
chosen champion. So that's going to
temporarily turn off the accelerate
unless Poke finds a backup Rex eye
breacher somewhere in the list.
>> Just making sure that we can clearly see
the might totals at the candle at
Sanctum.
Wait, void rush. Yeah,
>> here comes that void rush once again for
poke.
>> See what we find this time. It was an
undertitan last time around.
>> Going to be a Noxis hopeful. That's
going to be a free Knox hopeful because
void rush reduces the cost by two and
the Legion effect is activated at that
point.
So a free form might unit in the
backline for Poke.
And now Poke is probably wishing that
that breacher was still around because
you could have accelerated it if you
wanted to go over the top here. Right
now we're going to see Poke kind of
daisy chain units in to make some
trades. Wanted to get rid of that
merchant and turn off some of the
filtering Miro's been doing. Going to
put the under Titan on the Ripper's Bay
just to make conquering over there
harder for Meiru.
>> And also going to reinforce with their
own Ferris forunner. So incredibly
difficult to get onto that rippers bay
now.
>> Yeah, Ferris 4Erunner off the top with
that Rexi Legend ability.
Really strong find here to put some big
pressure on Meu.
I think I think there might be a second
guess here from Poke about whether to
reinforce or not. Uh, I can understand
the hesitation just because at some
point you need to reconquer on the
sanctum side, but I like the idea of
reinforcing on Ripper's Bay. And the
reason I like it is because when you
pass here, the mech token is going to
die from the axe. So, if Meu wants the
hold point, they're going to have to
react to
the
uh start of the turn. Well, the start of
the turn, the mech token won't die, but
it it's the axe is stranded essentially,
and it will die at the end of the turn.
>> Um, so Miru's at some point going to
have to react with that red pike over on
that battlefield as well. But going into
the following turn, unless they re-equip
the axe on something and then send it
over, there's just no way to get over
that might. And even to re-equip, you're
going to have to get rid of your own
mech token cuz it doesn't die until the
end of the turn. Uh if you're Meu, what
you're looking for if you're trying to
move the axe and then go in the other
direction would be something like a
starcross. Starcross here. You could
bounce the mech token, holding the axe,
respond by replaying uh the pike from
hidden so you still have presence on the
sanctum if you want and you don't lose
your hidden card. But then by using that
mech token as part of your starcross,
you could put Ferris 4Runner back in the
hand. Get rid of that. Re-equip the axe
on something like bewitching. Send that
into the bay. So starcrust would
actually be fantastic here for Meu. This
Ezreal might be digging exactly for
that.
Yeah, ditching the falling star to draw
a couple cards here.
>> Six more runes to work with. We'll see
if that star cross line is an option for
Meu.
Going to be
spending a couple runes here.
The tide turner. Okay, so the tide
turner swapping positions and now the
mech ready coming back to base and that
battle axe still attached representing
seven might.
Yeah, I was talking about finding a
starcrust, but tide turner is also a
very good option because that allows you
to re- attack with the mech.
>> Undert
>> and you can force a trade here and does
opt to get rid of the under titan
instead of the forerunner.
>> Oh, of course.
>> Yeah, the hidden card still there as
well. Oh, Meiru has to be
keeping an eye out for a possible hidden
blade.
>> Thinking,
>> yeah, I think if you're Meu right now
and you don't know your opponent's deck
list, uh, against Order Fury in the
current meta, you should be considering
Hidden Blade and Red Pike. Those are the
two most commonly played hidden cards.
>> Now, here comes the pike from Hidden for
Meu.
And Miro pointed to the Ezreal. So uh
this is uh going to have the plus two
might I believe because the cost
reduction of the optional uh trigger
comes from Ezreal.
>> And it is a pike as well for Poke
>> getting that additional might.
>> I'll go to the seven.
>> And that is enough for Meiru to take
down that Ripper's Bay.
a big play there getting the
>> Ferris 4Runner taken care of.
>> Yeah. So, Starcross
>> Starcross was eventually used.
>> Yeah.
>> Did result in a big play like I thought.
Didn't go in the direction I thought,
but I was unaware of the tide turner.
Uh, expertly navigated here by Meu,
though, understanding that your Pike,
even if it's hidden in one battlefield,
does still have ganking, so can go
across. Was able to cascade that axe
across multiple units. Uh, Poke is still
staying in this game.
>> Bird token does trigger on the Sanctum.
This is going to allow Poke to kind of
extend the hand. You're going to get a
look with the Sanctum and then a look
with the Void Burrower trigger as well.
And Poke needs some help though because
Miro is holding currently with six might
on a battlefield and at seven points
that would result in a victory if you do
not get rid of it. So the
>> things that Poke is looking for are
cards like Undertitan that would boost
these hopefuls and allow you to go over
the top or something else that will help
you deal with the pike. The other
problem you have if you're poke right
now is that even if you do get that uh
pike off the battlefield, you have to
make sure that Miu cannot double conquer
you for the win next turn.
>> And even though there's just a
bewitching spirit and an Ezreal, there
is also the mech token and the battle
axe. So if you go over this pike, the
battle axe will be free to equip onto
anything else. Uh this is this is a
tough spot if you're poke.
Scary situation for sure here in game
one.
>> Okay.
>> Looks like one goes to the bottom. What
do we have on top? It is an under Titan
and the manufacturer. So you get the two
energy
>> and then that Undertitan will come out
buffing up the Noxis hopefuls
to try and go through that southern
battlefield.
Titan reinforcing at the candle lit
Sanctum
>> and a trade at Rippers Bay. Six might on
six might
>> and then the other hopeful is free to go
and conquer.
>> I really like the reinforcing of the
undertitan here. Again, poke
understanding that Miro has to double
conquer next turn to win and if you
don't make that difficult for Meiru,
then you're just kind of going to lose
the game on the spot. So, uh, Poke
putting everything on the sanctum, also
leaving the hopeful on the other side.
And now Miro again has three units, also
has the battle axe, has the potential to
cascade the battle axe into the Candleit
Sanctum. Like that's the the big issue
at the moment is you could put the
battle axe on something uh send it in
and then trade for, you know, the
majority of the might, put it on a
second unit, send it in, and then as
long as you have enough to go over the
hopeful on the other side,
>> uh you will just win. So
>> we're going to see first the six.
>> Uh which five, right?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> So there we go. It's enough for Miru to
take over the sanctum.
>> Conquering drawing a card and that is
enough to go over Knox is hopeful and
Meiru taking it down. Finding a way to
double conquer and get the early lead
here in round 10.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. [laughter]
>> Judge was trying to get confirmation on
who won so that they could put it on the
graphic and Miru thought that they were
calling for a a handshake. was so
confused and uh right there you saw like
a quick shake it off from Poke. I think
Poke just understands that uh that was
close. I think Poke did a great job of
trying to navigate that final turn. Like
I said, you kind of needed to find an
Undertain, but you were still facing an
uphill battle because of the presence of
the units in base and the battle axe.
The battle axe is such a big deal
because of the ability to cascade it.
Even though Meiru had another answer
anyway, the battle axe alone would have
been enough to just push through what
Poke had on the table. And so, uh, Poke
going first here. And this is going to
be a rough start because they were
forced to pass.
>> That is not what you want to see for
Rexai. The bewitching spirit early for
Meiru here. Aspirants climb arena's
greatest. So, we start with one point,
but we are going to be playing to nine
here in game two as the blood rush is
discarded for Poke. Going to need to
develop here.
Missing that opening play. Not what Poke
wanted to see.
And now we're going to see
I was going to say what what the options
are. And already playing the chosen
champion early. Uh, as I as I peaked at
the hand, I think that maybe some of the
cards from either the sideboard or uh
maybe they're in the main, but we just
didn't see them in game one are kind of
clogging things up at the moment. I
thought I saw a call the week.
There's a falling star. So perhaps the
more like responsive options are the
reason that Poke did not have that turn
one play. But uh Miro here, I was going
to say, is going to take the point for
sure. Bounce this bewitching. would not
be surprised if they don't replay it as
well because if you see your opponent
miss a turn one play, you know their
hand is not great and you want to take
advantage of that. And even if that
means kind of slow playing a little
yourself, if you can just shred it
before uh it's relevant, then you have a
a great way to capitalize on that slow
start.
>> We are going to see that Bewitching
Spirit come back down. Let's see what
the discard is here.
does feel like a much more reactive hand
for Poke here in game two. The falling
star
>> going to be discarded.
>> So, a bit more of a peak that time as as
he was fanning it out. There was a call
of the week. There also was an
undertitan. So, that explains, you know,
again why it was some of the more
expensive stuff. There was also another
falling star, so that's why one was
discarded. So yes, uh, Poke just with a
clogged reactive start
>> will finally score here with this Rex
eye breacher will hopefully try to
extend the hand. Does the ender titan
and this is the the recovery that Poke
needed to get back into this.
>> Yeah, getting that additional energy
playing out the honest broker.
So now we are developed in the backline
with the inferna as well. And now we see
the coal the week to get the bewitching
spirit out of there as well of the
honest broker. But a gold token created
for Poke.
Two to two going back to Meiru.
I think Poke likes using that call the
week to guarantee that the bewitching
spirit goes away. Even though normally
call the week is used for bigger
targets. We want to use it against your
opponents that want to go tall like
Ireelia in this matchup. Understanding
that you've had a slow start and they're
going to start stripping your hand. You
you have to deal with it.
>> So Ferris 4runner developed for Meiru
really setting up a strong
>> closer
>> push next turn as Poke will hold up to
three with Rexi.
All right, so poke here happy to hold up
to three, but seeing the Ferris 4runner
probably wants to just generate as much
might as possible this turn would not
surprise me if this is just a
development. We do see that the Rex eye
is coming back to base as well. Uh,
Inferno, you you want to take the point.
So going up to four important,
>> but again I I would expect Poke to maybe
just generate as much moist as possible
this turn and try to set up for a
reconquer on the following turn.
>> So another Rexai Legend trigger
>> and we're going to see the faithful
manufacturer in the hopeful on top.
shuffle it back in. Can you recycle for
a moment?
>> Oh, so while Poke was doing the reveal
for the Void Brewer Legend ability.
>> Poke is saying that I accidentally saw
the third card down. So, right now, the
judge is uh trying to figure out the way
to resolve this. This likely will end up
just being a shuffle. I've played one
from the
>> but we are going to I think take a
moment and listen in and see if we can
hear what the judge is saying.
>> Um so I played so the reveal before this
one was under attack broker
>> correct.
>> I played the broker. So that's one
recycle and I recycled two from
Mulligan. So there should be three on
the
>> Going to take the bottom three and put
them aside.
>> Put them where?
>> Yeah, you can put the bottom three.
>> Okay. So this is going to be a shuffle.
However, uh the judge is taking the
bottom three and setting them aside
because that's known information. they
were recycled.
And so you want the known information to
stay the same and you want the unknown
information to go back to being unknown.
So again, Poke saw an extra card. So
it's going to result in a shuffle, but
they want the recycled cards that have
been seen from other, you know, void
burrower activations to stay where they
are. So that's why you're seeing uh the
cards on the bottom set aside. I think
the judge is just talking him through
it, but that should be the resolution
here for uh seeing the extra card here.
It wasn't drawn to hand, so you don't
have to do anything uh where you present
it to your opponent and they get to pick
which one you uh choose. You just want
to get the jack back being to unknown
information.
>> And I do love in this situation because
you could see it happen very quickly
when Poke went to reveal those cards,
but he immediately caught it, stopped
everything he was doing. And that's
important when a situation like this
happens. Just stop things immediately.
Let the judge know so that way it's the
easiest possible fix. We don't move
along any further.
>> Love that quick call from Poke.
>> Yeah, it makes any sort of resolution or
rewinds that are required that much
easier if you don't continue through the
turn. Uh also just big respect, big
props to Poke for immediately notifying
the job as well. He turned and just
said, I I saw this extra card.
wants to make sure that the game is
played properly
>> and this uh is still saying at the judge
call
>> um Miu just making sure that they are
going to get the extension here. I
imagine that this is something where
they're just getting confirmation on the
resolution because again usually in
these situations it's just a shuffle so
that the deck returns to unknown
information uh minus anything that had
been recycled up to this point. I just
double checked.
>> And at this point,
>> if you're just tuning in, round 10
>> here in Hartford of 13 Swiss rounds.
Both of these players eight and one.
Poke and Meiru. This showdown between
Rexi and Pike
here in game number two. Meu with Pike
able to take the first game of the set.
And here in game two, an interesting
Arena's Greatest versus Aspirants Climb
match.
>> All right, so here is the shuffle. I
hope that somewhere
I'm making Greton proud that I properly
identified what the resolution would be.
>> I hope he's back there watching like a
proud father.
>> If you are Greton, happy Father's Day to
you. as [laughter] the uh the father of
our our judge calls on this broadcast.
But
>> so now we have the resolution and we
will move forward with the recside
trigger
>> top
>> and Poke is going to play that. Knox is
hopeful for two
>> and then I'll play this to base
>> off of the Legion effect getting that
energy reduction.
pass
>> and just going to pass the turn with
Inferna there at Aspirants Climb. Meu
down by a couple points here, but Ferris
4Runner in that backline set to really
take over whatever Battlefield needed
here moving into Aspirants Climb.
Inferna goes down up to three points
goes Meiru.
>> And now we see Ezreal coming out as
well. So Miro will start to do some
cycling, discarding that switcheroo and
drawing a pair.
>> So I will call out that if you're poke
in this particular matchup, you're not
very excited to have seen Ferris 4Runner
come down. A lot of times you're just
trying to have your units be bigger than
your opponents, but the fact that you
have to kill Ferris 4runner twice and
you have to do it fairly uh is typically
problematic. Uh here this is a wonderful
long sword play to keep the breacher
alive. We saw the breacher die in game
one and it kind of slowed things down
for poke. So uh this is a beautiful
response and uh just kind of finishing
the train of thought here. The ferris
4runner
might be answered by something like
combination of damage plus a smite if it
comes in from the board. Uh, again, we
did not see what the sideboards were
when we were shown the deck lists
earlier, but Smite has been slowly
rising in popularity because of all of
the popular Death Nell effects and
Leblanc decks. So, if you see the Ferris
4unner in game one, like you did if
you're poke and you're running that in
your sideboard, it might be worth it to
bring it in because it gets you a lot of
value in this matchup.
>> It is worth noting that four minutes
have been added to the clock for these
players.
As we go back over to Poke, very timely
long sword to save that chosen champion
from the falling star.
>> Did get the bird token
>> from the carry and dredger death nail
triggered ability.
>> And now let's see how that Ferris
4runner is contended with.
Yeah, Poke is in the unenviable position
of not having great ways to deal with
the 4Runner unless they have an
additional buff
>> or something else. The breacher only at
five might hopefully at four. Hey,
speaking of uh great ways to deal with
it though, those are two solid options.
Call of the week would likely just
result in Ezreal dying, however. But Vi,
we know is an incredibly powerful card.
Uh the problem here though is that if
you're playing it from the void
burrower,
like we're seeing this activation now,
you then can't ambush it. You just have
to play it to the field. So it would be
a turn slower before you start getting
the stun effect. But it still if your
hand is clunky and we have seen Poke's
hand be you know a bit more spellor
oriented than most Rexi decks like to
be. We might still see Vi played just
either to base
>> or
>> Oh okay.
>> Oh going to accelerate Vi with breacher.
>> So paying that additional accelerate
cost and this is massive
>> VI peacekeeper off the top. Here we go.
This is the answer that may be needed
for that Ferris 4Runner.
>> Now keep in mind that Mirror does have
four ready runes. So there could be some
interaction here in this showdown. But
hopeful and VI moving in that will stun
that Ferris 4Runner
>> when Vi attacks.
>> I'll stun the Ferris.
>> Now Miru.
>> Oh, it's the Void Seeker. He's got a
void seeker which would take out the
hopeful and leave Miu in that
advantageous position of one might over
Vi. Three ready runes for Poke. Is there
any any interaction here? Needs it
desperately.
I was about to say Miu only needs to
answer one of these units to repel the
attack. So, if you're unfamiliar with
how stun works, it just means that the
unit doesn't deal combat damage, but you
still have to have enough might to get
rid of it.
>> Okay, so that did repel the attack, but
with Ferris 4runner still being stunned
and that breacher in the backline with
the long sword moving in.
>> Going to play a falling star
>> taking out Ferris 4Runner. And now the
falling star is going to hit that back
line, leaving just one mech unit for
Meiru.
I will admit I'm slightly puzzled as to
why the Rexi was able to trade with the
4Runner. That should still just be five
might.
>> The assault on Rexi.
>> Ah, the assault. There we go.
>> Yeah, that was the one extra might
needed.
>> Just barely got there.
>> So thankful for the stun. Otherwise,
that would have been a trade. But how
about that VI off the top? That was so
key for Poke to answer that Ferris
4ERunner.
Good old Rex Eye Breacher surprising
people with the assault.
[laughter]
I will say that I think Poke wanted to
get rid of the Ferris Warrunner, but as
we saw, didn't want to commit the
breacher unless it was necessary, likely
because they know how important that
accelerate is.
We'll see if Miro has a way to
capitalize or punish that by getting rid
of the breacher. This would be a great
time to have something like an axe in
hand, and I do believe I see one. Uh,
you could also just use something like
the cleave. Your mech token would
survive with that as well because the
assault only works on offense.
>> Yeah, the mech token in the backline
very important for Meiru here.
Taking out Rexi Breacher priority number
one. There is the cleave. Assault three
on Mech. It's six to five going into
Aspirit's climb in favor of Meiru. It's
enough to take down the breacher. Long
sword falls off. Meiru conquering up to
four.
>> And now we will see Pike, the chosen
champion, coming out. The power cost
paid to have it ready. And plus two
might moves in conquering the northern
battlefield. It's six to five. And here
comes Fizz. And Fizz will allow Meu to
replay the falling star and take out Vi
in the backline. And that's no units in
play now for Poke.
>> This is a big play from Meiru. I think a
lot of players might be uh a bit timid
or weary of recycling so many runes to
play that Fizz into the Falling Star.
But when you see Via across the table
and a long sword, you have to get rid of
it now because once the long sword is
equipped, it's outside of Falling Star
range. So Meu says, "I'm okay with going
down in runes. I just want to make sure
you have no board presence. I have units
on both battlefields. I've got the Fizz
in the base. I can make you answer my
stuff and take a turn to redevelop if I
need to. But more importantly, I'm
threatening jumping ahead in the point
race. Again, this is an Aspirin climb
game. Arena's greatest made people start
at one, but you do still have to go to
nine. So, as weird as it sounds,
normally we talk so much about, you
know, 2 4 6 8. Here you're on the odd
numbers. Miro at five. A double hold
means going to seven and then you're in
striking distance to close out the game.
>> Now Poke able to develop a little bit
here off of that void rush
playing down the faithful manufacturer
and then the honest broker. The long
sword will be equipped to the
manufacturer.
And now it is that double hold for Meiru
up to seven.
>> Hold to seven.
>> Seven to six in favor of Meiru. Uh
>> yeah, Miro just confirming that that is
the score. I expect Mirror to pull both
units back to base. We're seeing that
happen now. Uh potentially some more
might development if Miro has it in hand
and then just trying to play for a
double conquer the following turn.
Putting the onus on Poke to stack things
in a way that Meu cannot solve as far as
like a puzzle goes. Uh that's going to
be I think difficult for Poke because
there's not a lot of might on the side
of the board and we know in hand that
there is not just a battle axe but also
a red Rengar. The one thing working in
Poke's favor at the moment is that Miro
has no fury runes which is going to
limit those options unless there's a
double fury channel in which case you
could play the axe equip it and
potentially do the Rengar as well.
Actually, you would not because the
battle axe is one of the few equipments
that has a one energy cost as part of
the equip. So, it would be one energy
short of doing both next turn.
>> But still, Poke has to feel like their
back is against the wall
>> knowing that Miro has the units and is
within striking distance.
>> That calls two power from Fizz.
>> Yes,
>> it's only the only the only restriction
is three.
>> Okay. Okay. I wasn't Yeah. Okay. Just
getting clarification on Fizz here. And
Meiru is going to develop on the
backline with double treasure hunter.
>> So again,
uh sorry to cut you off again, but uh
this tells me that Miro might have been
trying to set up for hoping uh you get a
a double fury rune channel and then you
could cascade your battle axe into a
double conquer.
>> Yeah, definitely trying to set that up.
needs the fury runes though. Will Meu
find them
>> on the next turn? We're back over to
Poke.
The battlefield's open, but we're three
points shy.
>> And you cannot let Meu double conquer
next turn. So, first off, the recruit
moving into the arena's the arena's
greatest. Here comes that Rex eye
trigger. What do we find off the top?
It's a porro and a shadows call.
Porro represents more might, but
Shadow's Call represents more options.
Yeah. So, we're going to see the Shadows
Call be played on the recruit. I like
this from Poke.
>> You want to try to find enough might to
be above rate as opposed to just paying
one energy per might. That's likely not
going to get the job done and get you in
a position to prevent this double
conquer. Also, uh, if you draw off of
the Shadows Call your own answers, you
know, cards like Falling Star, and I
think that's what we're about to see,
then you can slow things down.
>> Falling Star taking out the two three
might threats in the backline of Meiru,
the mech and Fizz
>> as Poke will conquer up to eight.
>> And we close in just under 20 minutes
left on the clock.
And now Poke can reinforce with another
four might
>> thanks to the long sword equipped to the
manufacturer. Another
>> reinforce coming here.
>> Knox is hopeful for two
>> onto the arena's greatest and a hidden
card as well.
>> And game one, Miru saw
>> both of the hidden options, the red pike
and
>> the hidden blade.
So Miro has to consider both when trying
to crack into this uh because
Poke is at eight now. Miro also
has to at a minimum get rid of the
units. A double conquer wins the game.
But even if you can't double conquer, if
you can just clear the battlefields and
prevent a hold, you're still in it.
This is very likely the deciding turn on
whether or not we see a game three here
in round 10.
What a match we've been treated to so
far. Two legends that we're excited to
see at the top of the standings.
three.
>> That falling star was so clutch from
poke to just reduce the might on Miro's
side, but also the number of bodies,
>> reduces flexibility
in terms of what you can send. We did
get the double red channel that Miro was
looking for to potentially cascade the
axe, but
the the problem there is that you don't
know what the hidden card is. And now
that you have less bodies as well,
a clutch hidden blade for example
>> becomes incredibly problematic. I think
this might be a fizz coming down. It is
going to be a fizz.
>> Okay, what is the play? Looks like he is
recycling too. So it is going to be the
falling star
>> or Void Seeker.
>> Void Seeker, excuse me. Yep, Void
Seeker. Recycled one for Fizz and one
for the Void Seeker.
And that does take out the manufacturer
that had four might with the long sword.
>> And more importantly as well, it draws
an additional card because
>> Miru was not liking the options.
>> Leaves five might at the arena's
greatest alongside the hidden card
and four runes still ready for Meiru.
So, the axe is off the table now because
you do not have the energy to equip it
if you play it. You do still have the
option to play that Rengar
>> as a reaction because there is a fury
rune.
>> The problem is is that you need the
Rengar to go over the top on the arena's
greatest. So, uh if there is a hidden
blade and they can use that on the
Rengar and we see the Rengar come down
now, then that will be very problematic.
We're going to find out. It is is hit
blade. Down goes Renar Miru is going to
then scoop it up. Poke forcing game
three
>> here in round 10. What a match we are
being treated to.
>> My starting head was five.
>> You see a showdown here in round 10.
>> Like not good. And then
>> yeah, you could hear the players
chatting there a little bit and Miro
said, "Yeah, that falling star was
good." And uh I agree because that was
the game decider. So game one, Poke just
couldn't get over the hump. Meu had more
might than could be dealt with. Game
two, despite Poke having a slow start,
was able to claw back in. Uh I think
that Poke, if we go all the way back to
when the call of the week was played to
get rid of that Bewitching Spirit. I
think if Poke did not take that action
and Miru could keep chaining that, we
would have seen a completely different
outcome. But instead, Poke was able to
get into the late game, generate enough
might, and get the win. And now we're in
a double forbidding waste game. So, this
is going to be spicy. Fireworks here in
the final game. Meu starting things out
with the treasure hunter will score the
first point, generating that gold on the
move trigger and developing Kai'Sa in
the backline. Poke starts things out
with the inferna on his first turn of
game number three.
>> Yeah, that double for bidding away is
quite interesting. So defending alone
here in game three not where you want to
be. Inferna moving in taking out the
treasure hunter. Rexai trigger will
bring an honest broker off the top for
poke that will be developed in the
backline. And now it is going to be cold
a week taking out Kai'Sa and maybe
Inferna. And it is going to be Inferna
there
>> off of the forbidden waste. But great
answer to the survivor. So I will admit
I'm a little surprised to see the
inferno chosen. A lot of times the
broker is chosen both because of the
deathnell but also the inferno was on a
battlefield would have at least
threatened a hold. The problem is of
course you have the chosen champion on
the opposing side which could just be
played to base as a ready unit and
because of forbidden waste being the
location any unit walking in is
essentially going to force that trade.
So uh that is why poke decided to keep
the broker instead not threaten that
hold point. I think that was uh the
proper recognition. Bewitching Spirit
stripping a card here. And that's not
what you want to see if you're poke
because you know that if you don't have
an answer for it, we're going to see the
rinse repeat of Bewitching Spirit
getting a point and then going back to
hand from the legend ability.
>> Okay, so we move into the northern
battlefield. Poke scoring up to two.
Rexai trigger. It's Inferna and Pike
Doside Butcher on top. Pike to the
bottom. Inferno will be played to base.
It leaves two runes up. And the
question, as you
proposed here, is there a way to deal
with that bewitching spirit and the
possible loop that could be incoming?
>> Here comes Void Rush.
>> We will reveal another two. There is a
Falling Star. It would cost two less.
and getting the undertitan. So, an
additional two energy generated here.
Really interesting finds off the top for
the void rush. Yeah, Poke is right now
trying to decide if it's worth it to do
the recycle just for this bewitching
spirit. both are going to
>> Yeah, I was going to say I I am okay
with I I like the idea of not doing it
here simply because
>> yes, the Bewitching Spirit loop is
threatening. But one of the things I've
noticed as far as a play pattern goes
from Poke is every void burrower
activation, if an option to be played
was present, Poke has been doing it. So,
you're extending your hand size just by
making sure that you're maximizing your
legend's value.
And once again, we see the value of the
forbidden waste as the bewitching spirit
is able to go in, take out the honest
broker that went down to zero might.
Bewitching spirit gets bounced. The loop
begins with the spirit and that pike
legend ability and it is falling star
discarded here
>> from poke. We go back over
>> to Poke. It's two to two. Keep in mind
that long sword was developed onto the
daring porro last turn.
So that porro will be a five might unit
on offense.
>> Yeah
>> comes another copy of inferna
and we're going to move into forbidding
waste and it is a void seeker to take
out. So interesting
>> porro.
>> Interesting interaction here. The Void
Seeker is only taking out the Porro
because there's no unit there to defend.
Assault only triggers when you are
declared the attacker.
>> That's right. Yep.
>> And so Void Seeker is still four damage
on four might as a result.
Look at this backto back Rex eye
triggers where Poke finds the under
Titan to generate an additional two
floating energy
manufacturer alongside it.
>> I'm going to play the manufacture.
>> I was just about to say I would be
shocked if this manufacturer is not
played because every time Poke has had
an option to play something from there,
he has taken it. again understanding the
threat of this bewitching spirit. Yes,
Miro did not uh
>> play Rexai. I'll recycle,
>> you know, shy away from the fact that
I'm going to be sending this in and then
replaying it every turn. So, poke needs
to shift understands the assignment.
Also, kind of again extending the hand
further by developing the chosen
champion and that's also going to
increase your flexibility by being able
to accelerate some of these triggers in
the future.
just trading back and forth at this
northern forbidden waste. Meu up to
three points as the spirit
>> conquers taking out inferna pike once
again bouncing that spirit back. More
gold generated for Miro and it's double
bewitching spirit to empty the hand of
Poke.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah, that is not what you want to see
if you're poke. I was also just getting
ready to comment that the one thing that
Miro is also doing here since the game
is going so slow and Miro is basically
just answering stuff but then playing
these spirits and bouncing them. The
number of runes on Miro's side is
significantly more than Poke. And Miro
has also had to avoid recycling because
of the gold tokens generated from the
Pike Legend ability. So, we're going to
hit a point where the tide turns in
Miro's favor because of the cards in
hand and having the energy to play them,
but Poke is now just stuck having to
>> I mean, it's fine. It's fine. You're
going to do it right here. It's fine.
It's fine.
>> So, we see the void rush off the top and
that will be played off that Rex eye
trigger. Looking at the daring porro and
a Cole the week
of the week.
>> Yep.
Call of the week will be played for two
less energy. The porro to hand one
spirit down and the recruit.
>> Poke will develop the porro and just
pass leaving the Rex eye in the
backline.
>> Yeah, I
>> threatened by that spirit.
>> I like that Poke did not send in the Rex
eye to get what's considered a
meaningless point. I know that
technically no points are meaningless,
but if you're at four, you probably
understand that your game plan is to go
to six and then eight. And you cannot do
that if you're poke by losing the
breacher. You need that to be able to
accelerate whatever you're finding off
of your triggers. So, you develop the
porro. Next turn, you can send that in,
hopefully get your conquer, trigger your
legend, and then accelerate out whatever
else it is you're finding. Now I say
hopefully because
>> oh the star cross is going to bounce
that spirit anyways and bounce back the
Rexai breacher
>> after stripping the hand. The under
Titan was the final card in hand. It's
four all as we close in on the
fiveminute mark of round 10. Daring
Porro moving in.
>> Poke goes up to five. What do we find
off this Rexside trigger? It's a hopeful
and a call the week.
>> Wow,
>> man.
>> This is such a tough decision if you're
poke. The call obviously gets rid of the
second spirit
>> again.
>> Yeah, but you lose your only unit as
well because your porro is going to go
away and now you're still down cards in
hand whereas Miru has a ton. However, I
do think Poke is making the right call
simply because as long as that spirit
stays, you're going to continue to be
operating from the top deck. So,
instead, uh, Poke plays the VI to base
after getting rid of it. Wisely puts the
long sword on to take it out of the
Falling Star range. And so, we're going
to wait and see what Miro does now to
respond and change their play pattern.
We've just been seeing the spirits. What
has Miro got now that they're gone?
Miru has
all the runes to work with.
Down a point. Here comes Docside
Butcher.
>> Yeah, I've got five.
>> Pike moves into the southern
battlefield. It's five all here in game
three.
We will see the chosen champion returned
to Meiru's hand.
leaves eight ready runes.
>> Mirror wants to go to six to try to
threaten a double conquer. They could
replay the pike, go to the other
location, and then just develop might
with the remaining runes. Does look like
that's going to be the play. I like this
from Meu.
>> You need to get within striking
distance.
>> Tie Turner is also going to protect the
pike. I love it.
and Rengar coming out as well.
>> So that back line is set up to
potentially double conquer next turn.
The tide turner rests at the northern
battlefield and it's just vi peacekeeper
for Poke. He moves in to the northern
battlefield. Tide turner down. It's six
all. What did Poke find off the top?
>> Also,
>> now we'll see that Rexside trigger. We
can dig some more. Okay,
>> I was just about to say also, what do we
get? This is a really big reveal.
Hopeful uh even without
>> having Legion active, still entirely
worth it when your hand is stripped.
>> Oh, okay. I think that there's a
consideration for Poke to play the
hopeful as a reinforce because that's
going to turn off the defending alone
for the Forbidden Waste. Miru could
still have some sort of answer if it's
another star cross or a removal spell to
then make it be solo again. But uh I
think Poke is yes going to reinforce
this here to turn off the battlefield
text at least temporarily.
>> And we'll see what that one card in hand
was for Poke that he drew at the start
of the turn. It's another Nox is
hopeful. So this will add another four
might to his side of the board
>> and just deciding where to play the
hopeful.
>> Even if we go to turns, it's going to
the game's going to end like final turn
here.
>> Yeah, the timer is coming down, but Poke
is saying even if we go to turns, game's
essentially ending here,
knowing that there's only a couple of
turns left before one of these players
claims it. Uh the thing you have to
worry about if your poke is obviously
that Rengar goes up to five when it
starts attacking back. You have 11 might
on the forbidding waste. So I think
that's why there's the consideration of
do I reinforce with this? That also
further makes it more difficult for Miro
to turn the forbidding waste back on if
they had something like a star cross. So
Poke wants to put as much might there as
possible.
Yeah, that's 15 might at the northern
forbidding waste. Meiru conquering up to
seven, bouncing back his chosen champion
with the Pike Legend ability and
replaying it,
>> paying the additional cost. That's a red
form might chosen champ in the backline.
>> So nine on offense currently for Miro,
15 on defense currently for Poke, but
Miro still has seven runes available and
a number of cards in hand.
Okay, here we go. Rengar moving in. He's
five on offense and it's another Rengar
>> bouncing onto
the northern battlefield. And we do see
a trade with the two Nox's hopefuls. And
now Docside Butcher moves in. Cleave is
the additional might needed for Meiru.
He moves on to 9 and one here in
Hartford.
>> That was such a fun match to watch.
these players fighting for the board,
going back and forth. You got to see the
Pike obviously do the Bewitching Spirit
stuff, but you also got to see the power
of the Rengars in this Pike list. You
got to see the power of the Ferris
4Runners being sticky and hard to deal
with. A completely different version
than what we saw yesterday with Senbon.
And here we see it pay off because Poke
was just unable to deal with the might
and the trickery with this version of
Pike. Well, that was the difference and
it's really the thing that jumped out to
me when we first looked at the deck list
was just the sheer might that Meiru
could present in this pike list, but
also have that bewitching spirit and all
of those control spells as well that can
really manipulate the game state and
then you can also play offense very well
also. So, just a very interesting list
and he is on a run here. 9 and one with
just three more rounds remaining. Could
we see Pike in the top eight for the
first time in a regional qualifier? I
hope so. I I honestly hope that we see
this version in particular make it to
the top eight. And I want to see how it
competes against some of the more
metading lists, right? What does this
deck look like against Ireelia? What
does this deck look like against Diana?
I think that this is a very cool version
of Pike because you're not all in on
just pack of wonders bouncing. You're
saying my legend ability is enough and
then I'm going to play that good fury
chaos, good stuff that has been good.
I'm saying the word good so many times
trying to drive this point home uh for
the entire history of the game, right?
We know that fury and chaos has been a
wonderful combination and this pike list
takes the best of both worlds. I am a
fan. Yeah, Fury Chaos has been so good
for quite some time. And when you add
things like
>> Starcross into the mix with Fizz and so
you've got that trickery as well and
just the great fury removal spells and
Void Seeker and Falling Star that were
both used very very effectively in that
match. But let's take a look now at
Meiru's run and see what he has played
against. We see he's played against a
couple Annies, but he's really had a
vast majority of legends that he's had
to face up against.
>> Yeah, we see a lot of victories against
just numerous decks. There's only been
one repeat. That's the Annies.
Everything else is a different
experience. Did lose one game to
Lynsanity to start the day. Uh we got to
see Linsanity on the broadcast yesterday
and they were a phenomenal player and
Diana is obviously a very powerful deck.
So, uh, not a knock against Meiro for
taking a loss there. But, uh, again, if
anything, I'm saying, uh, this run, what
this says to me is this is a versatile
list because every experience besides
the double Annie was different and
unique. And that means that the Meiru
list was able to adapt well to whatever
it was paired against. And one thing I
want to point out as we left Meiru's
screen there was at the bottom in round
11, it looked like there was going to be
a Meiru versus Colin matchup. and
they're both X and one and we know that
X and 2 could potentially be on the
bubble. So that is going to be a
fireworks show. But we look at Poke's
lineup of matches so far has only fallen
to the Pike that we saw here in this
round in the Kai'Sa early in the day
yesterday.
>> Yeah, we see that Poke also went through
a plethora of yees there on their way to
a strong start. Still in it at X and 2.
But uh with that in mind, I think we are
ready to throw things over to an
interview with our winner, Meiru. Let's
hear from the Pike player himself.
>> Incredible round 11 here with our
feature match with Meiru taking it down
two to one against a Rexi List. And I
got to ask you, I want to just get your
kind of immediate vibe check on that
deck. Obviously, you've been playing a
lot of Riftbound, top 16 in Las Vegas,
back in the Draven era. Good to see you
back on those uh those domains because
watching you play was just very clean
and very very practiced I would say.
What's your opinion on that Rexile list
though in general because we just saw a
top eight new track. What do you think?
>> I think Rexi is pretty good right now.
Actually, it was a deck that I feared
the yellow in general. I think my deck
is a little soft too and I actually
decided to main deck Ferris 4runner in a
meta where Ferris 4Runner is not really
that good because of Starcross right
now. It's a lot of tempo loss,
especially against like Diana and stuff,
but uh I figured, you know what, I'm
good enough into those matchups that I
can sacrifice that main deck a lot slot
and it came in clutch both games. Um I
didn't get to g win game two, but it was
the reason I was competitive in that
game, right? Um so I think that you have
to respect them. You have to respect
them. I think yellow's in a good spot
right now. Um just the combination of
cold the week keeping you off the board
and the the token spam. It's just not
many bellows breath running around
anymore. There used to be last set, but
not anymore. Well, well, we even saw
that in game three where that cold the
weak from the recruit conqueror, right?
And you know, he doesn't mind getting
rid of the recruit and so helps you keep
a little bit off of those units cuz I
mean we saw the success of your deck
being able to play those bewitching
spirits over and over and over again and
get those cards out and eventually
getting to that same game state, right,
where you get all those cards out of
their hand. Even I love the course
interaction where you can starcross a
specific thing back to their hand, make
them discarded like that's not coming
back even though it's normally the
biggest downside of things like
starcross. Exactly.
>> So, it's great to see that sort of
expertise. I mean again you came
undefeated coming into today. Tell me
about your loss because you had a loss
last round before coming in here. How do
you think that went?
>> I think it's a favored matchup. I think
you're very I lost to Diana which I
think he his deck was very teched. He
had a lot of deflect. He was running a
full play set of the four drop vex. Uh
he was running abandons which are really
good against Fizz. Um and he was running
Baron. So there's a lot of stuff I have
to play around. So he had a very tech
list but I still think it like almost
evens the matchup. That's how favored we
were. Um because if you draw Bewitching
Spirit and Falling Star, you can kind of
keep them off their engine, right? If
you can take out the hue in the
backline, you're in a really, really
good spot. And then Bewitching Spirit
slowly will whittle them down as it does
with most decks that don't, you know,
once you take out their draw engine,
they can't keep drawing. So, I think
that match up's favored. Unfortunately,
I didn't see what I needed to. You need
both Falling Star and Bewitching Spirit.
Miss one each game. So, it is what it is
what it is. You know, it happens. Um,
but yeah, overall, I feel really good
about the Pike deck. I think the nice
thing about it as especially after
Draven has gotten like a little bit
neutered or nerfed a little bit um it
gives you a way of doing a proactive
game plan where it doesn't involve your
opponent interacting with you right so
Annie kind of requires your opponent to
come in and fight you on your turn on
their turn right um so that you can use
those runes and the same thing with
Draven you kind of need them to go in
and fight Pike just says I don't need to
fight I can just remove your board
remove your hand and play a slower game
I'll give you point tempo but I'll win
in the long run and I think that's a
really cool aspect to that domain We're
actually we're even seeing a lot of
Ezreal decks right now have a little bit
of that sort of same emphasis and in
certain matchups the Diana decks do a
lot of similar game plan. So it is
interesting to hear that because that is
a different dynamic that we see for
these other Fury Chaos decks like you're
alluding to and like you said back in
the Draven era people were just avoiding
combat so much that you weren't actually
getting that generation whereas I can
tell how good your legend is not just
from the the interabilities of your
units so when you get to play them again
but the gold that you generate across
the game. So
>> it's huge. It's huge. But still tailored
for a top cut run here for you Miru.
Congratulations on your round. More
tournament to play though. So we're
gonna go ahead and send it back.
>> Yeah, what a great interview there. A
grueling best of three between that
Rexai and Pike list. And I want to
actually dive into how that series ended
up closing out. It really goes to
showcase how creative you can get when
you're playing Pike. Obviously, here we
have a double forbidding waste match,
which is very tricky. Both Rexi and Pike
don't really want to stay on a
battlefield. They just want to conquer
uh for Rexai's sake to get that legend
ability and for Pike's sake just to get
on that battlefield and bounce back to
hand. As we can see right now, all we
have is a bunch of runes for the side of
Meiru. We have a Pike and a Rengar. We
are at six points. We can win this turn.
So the most important thing here is we
want to make sure that we can get onto
the first four bidding wastes. And then
with the ability of pike, we can bounce
our other pike back to our hand. And
then what we'll be able to do is move
this Rengar pouncing in here. Play
another Rengar bouncing from hand. And
with that assault, we'll be able to kill
both these Noxis hopefuls. Notably now
this VI is going to be all alone on this
battlefield, which is going to give it a
minus two might. And when we replay this
pike, we can pay its additional cost,
give it an extra plus two might, swing
in into that now five might vi who gets
that minus two from the forbidding
wastes, use that cleave to get on top
and close out this game. So what we're
going to do is we're going to go ahead
and roll the clip now so you can kind of
see it. And this is a very creative line
from Meiru able to kind of go up to
seven, get that pike back to hand,
obviously knowing he has that Rengar
pouncing so he can set up that board
state and obviously poke on his side did
all he could, right? really stacking
that battlefield saying I know this is a
tricky deck. I know Meu can kind of get
move through it and break these
battlefields and especially with a
double forbidding waste game. It's so
difficult cuz once that unit's alone,
it's going to get uh that negative
might. So now we're going to see the
plus two get assigned on the side of uh
Meiru. We're going to move that Rengard
pouncing in and we're going to be able
to uh to take control of that
battlefield by playing another Rengar
pouncing from our hand. So, just doing
some math here on Meu's side, trying to
figure it out. Last turn of the game,
and here comes the Rengar Pouncing. Now,
what we're going to do is instantly
exhaust those three runes. Pay that fury
power. Put another Rengar Pouncing. The
assault going to allow us to trade with
those Noxis hopefuls, making sure
there's no, you know, reactions or
anything like that on the side of Pokey.
And now it's a four might versus a five
might. Cleave brings it up to seven, and
we can close out the game. So, a kind of
masterass on how to play Pike. I've been
really enjoying seeing the different
pike lists that we've seen on stream
over the weekend, but picking up their
ninth win. We're going to be moving into
round number uh 13 soon and stay tuned
for that. We're just going to take a
short break, but we'll be right back.
>> Hey everyone, my name is Grenton and I'm
Charmer and we got some pretty big spice
uh for you all today. It's a deck that I
actually really enjoy playing. Uh, so
I'm here to explain to Tormer how to uh
create a Limitless Lux. Yeah, I
definitely need this explanation
probably two or three times, but give me
your best shot at why this deck is
limitless and why so many people are
talking about it. Yeah. So, like
anything that, you know, creates some
waves in the Riftbound meta, uh, it's
going to get talked about, but this is a
very unique situation we're in where
Lux, who when you just take a look at
her in a vacuum, she just says, you
know, when you play a spell that costs
five or more, draw a card. Pretty
balanced, I would say. Uh, and then when
we actually take a look at the deck, we
can take a look at the fact that almost
every card in this deck draws you a card
in some sort of way, and that's on
purpose. So, there's some combos in this
deck that allow you to create a bunch of
energy and a bunch of power and make as
many recruits as your heart's desire.
And there's also stuff that, you know,
you're able to do that's a bit more
cheeky. Uh, and there's some cards that
are near and dear to my heart that I
want to actually take a look at when we
dive into the combos here.
So, the first thing with this deck is,
as you can see, the entire deck list is
just draw, draw, draw, draw, draw. So,
you want to get to a point where you
have no cards left in your deck. And
when you actually think about it, that's
very dangerous because if you draw from
an empty deck, you'll burn out and
sometimes your opponent will be at seven
points and you'll just give them the
game. But this deck allows you to loop
cards back into your deck and continue
to generate resources and continue to
generate power. And that for me is super
exciting. U so we're going to jump in
here and we're going to take a look at
the first combo of this deck. There's
many combos in this deck, which is
funny, but we're going to assume now
we've drawn our entire deck. So we have
no cards in our deck, Charmer.
>> Okay, we have no cards in our deck.
>> Perfect.
>> Zero.
>> Uh we have a bunch of cards in our hand
admittedly,
>> right?
>> And to start this combo, you need three
very specific cards in your trash. And
those cards are Forge of the Future.
This card here, it's when you play it,
you'll make a recruit token, but more
importantly, when you kill it, you can
recycle up to four cards from any trash.
Okay,
>> make sense? Next card we're going to
need to make sure is in our trash is
sacrifice. So, this is a very important
card in the combo. As an additional cost
to play this, you have to kill a mighty
unit and then you'll be able to draw two
and channel a rune exhausted.
And the final card we need in our trash
is Shadow's Call. This is another new
card with unleashed. So, Shadow's Call
says you can choose a unit that doesn't
have temporary.
>> Okay,
>> give a temporary
>> and then draw two. So, the name of the
game here is you need to have these
three cards in your trash. You also need
to have these same three cards in your
hand. And you need our favorite our
favorite guy. You need Ekko in your hand
as well. So, Ekko is a very unique card
that reads Death Nell. So, when Ekko
dies, he will recycle himself and you'll
be able to ready your runes.
>> Okay.
>> See where I'm going with this?
>> No, that's why you're explaining it to
me.
>> Perfect. Awesome. So, we now have an
empty deck. We have Forge of the Future,
Sacrifice, Shadows Call, and Echo in our
hand. And we have Forge of the Future,
Sacrifice, and Shadows Call in our
trash. So, step one of this combo is
we're going to play the Forge of the
Future.
>> All right.
>> Okay. We're going to do this now. We're
going to make a recruit. That's not
super important right now. We're going
to then instantly kill our Forge of the
Future and we're going to recycle the
aforementioned Forge of the Future,
Sacrifice, and Shadow's Call. And now
our deck will be a random order of those
three cards.
>> Okay,
>> follow me so far.
>> Yes.
>> Great. Next step is we're going to play
our friend Ekko. We're going to play him
to our base. We probably don't have a
battlefield at this point. Ekko is going
to come in. We're not going to
accelerate him. We don't need to yet.
We're then going to play Shadow's Call
and we're going to choose our Echo as
the target. What's cool about this is
we're going to retain priority. We're
going to tell our opponent, hey, I'd
like to hold priority and I will respond
with my sacrifice and I will sacrifice
Ekko with the Shadows Call on the chain.
This will kill Ekko as a cost which will
then trigger Ekko's death nail ability
which will recycle him. So now our deck
is four cards, Forge of the Future,
Sacrifice, Ekko, and Shadow's Call.
>> Okay. And in response to Ekko's trigger,
we will then exhaust the rest of our
runes to float that amount of energy.
Then Ekko will ready all our runes and
we will resolve the sacrifice. Draw two
of our four remaining cards in our deck.
Resolve the shadows call, draw the last
two cards. And now we're back where we
started where we have a Shadow's Call,
Sacrifice, and Forge of the Future in
our trash. We'll have another ver an
echo in our hand, a Shadow's Call, and a
Sacrifice that we just drew with the
forge of the future. And then we'll
start again, play forge, kill it,
recycle those three cards, play Echo,
Shadow's Call, Sacrifice, and go again.
Does that make sense? It does. But
for the people at home who are
definitely not following along like I
am, it's definitely not me. Uh, Echo
costs a power.
>> Yes. So, how are we making sure that we
can keep playing Ekko without running
out of runes?
>> Yep. So, the you have some seals here to
let you kind of do it at the beginning.
Uh, the rune you're going to channel
from sacrifice. If you're at 12 runes
and you recycle a blue, you'll channel
it from your sacrifice. So, you always
have rune fodder to pay for echo.
However,
>> all we did here was was we made, I don't
know, let's say 700,000 energy.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. That's all we've done. We haven't
really done anything else, right?
700,000 I think is pretty fair.
>> Now, what we have to do is we have to
create,
>> you know, let's do, I don't know,
600,000 power. So, we've kind of we
forget about Ekko now. We don't need him
anymore. and we're going to start
playing uh lecturing yortle.
>> Okay.
>> Right. So, lecturing yord is when you
play me, draw a card. Pretty simple. We
have the forge, right? So, what we'll do
is we'll kill the forge uh and we'll
recycle uh a retreat that we'll have in
our trash probably from one point. If
you don't, you just put it there. Yep.
>> Um and we'll recycle the other forge
that's in our trash. So, now our deck is
two cards.
>> Okay.
>> So, when we play the lecturing yortle,
we'll draw either the retreat or the
forge. And then we will play another
retreat from our hand to bring the
yortle back to our hand. And then we'll
replay it because we have 700,000
energy.
>> Yep.
>> And we'll draw the last card. And now
what we're doing is in response to this
retreat, uh, we will once again recycle
a rune in response to the trigger to
float a power of our choosing. So we'll
float a blue or float a yellow or we'll
do that over and over again. And we'll
make 500,000 power, 250,000 order,
250,000 mind.
Okay.
>> Have I blown your brain yet?
>> You're getting there.
>> Okay. [laughter]
>> But what do I do with all this energy
and power? Okay.
>> Yes.
>> What do I do?
>> So, there's a lot of different
variations to the what I call game one
list. So, the game one list runs
something like this. So, what you're
going to do at this point is your
opponent has just been sitting there
watching you create all this energy and
all this power. Now, we want to interact
with them a little bit. So, first thing
we're going to do is depending on the
game state, either we'll Ash first,
which Ash is one of my favorite cards
from Unleashed, where when you play her,
you'll be able to look at your
opponent's hand, banish a card, and they
have to hold to get that card back. And
like we just mentioned where we had ways
to loop retreat and ways to draw cards.
We'll continue to do that where we can,
you know, shadows call and ash retreat
her back to hand. Draw the cards we need
to do that again and do that as many
times as cards you have in your hand. So
now at this point you have no more cards
in your hand.
>> No more cards. Next step is to get rid
of your board. So we're going to cast a
ruination because now we have a bunch of
energy and a bunch of power. So we'll
kill all the units. All those recruits
we worked hard to make, they're gone.
Oh, we lost them all. [laughter]
>> And the last step of this is just in
case you want to add insult to injury a
little bit and they have a gear out,
you'll just salvage all their gear away
and you'll use draw stuff to be able to
to draw into those. So now at this
point, you have a bunch of energy, a
bunch of power, the board's completely
wiped, my opponent's hands completely
wiped, and then I will just go back to
the initial combo where we're using
echko to make as many recruits as I have
energy. So, I'll have, you know, let's
say at this point, 6, you know, 80,000
or whatever the math comes out to. We'll
just make a bunch of recruits. And then
now I have a base full of recruits and I
pass the turn to you and you're playing
top deck mode. Most players here would
scoop. Now, a quick question. Yeah. You
said play to the base, but because Ekko
has accelerate and you're using him for
the loop, could you also put Ekko on a
spot and then play the forge and then
start amassing there as well? So you
could use cards sprite burst uh to and
echko to get battlefield presence. The
thing is that a lot of people forget is
that forge of the future specifically
says that you need to play the the
recruit to your base. However, sprite
burst and echo you can have some you
know you can expedite the clock by one
turn by finishing your turn where you've
made a bunch of recruits with you know
an echo on each battlefield and then
pass the turn to your opponent. So that
way you only really have to do four more
turns if you start this at zero points
to win the game. And your opponent at
that point is in top deck mode. And even
if they top deck some sort of board
wipe, you just do the loop again. And
you make sure that before you pass your
turn, you recycle enough that you have,
you know, a forge, a sacrifice, or a
shadows call on your main deck. And then
you're able to do that again if you need
to.
>> That's the game one thing.
>> Okay. So game one, we make all of the
might and then we just win. Yeah. What
do we do in game two?
>> Well, in game two and in game three, uh
this is kind of what popularized uh the
deck is this one turn win combo.
>> So So we don't have to wait.
>> We don't have to wait. We don't
gratification. All right. Correct. Yeah.
>> Now, now I'm in.
>> All right. So the combos stay the same.
We're still making infinite or sorry,
we're still making 700,000 or a million
or 5 million energy. We're making a bit
less power because we need to use that
energy to make the power.
But we have a way to close out the game
right then and there, which is awesome.
So, the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to make sure the
battlefields are clear or at least one
battlefield is clear.
>> Okay. Then we need to get onto that
battlefield. So, like you just
mentioned, you can use a card like Echo
to accelerate to get onto that
battlefield just like you can use a card
like Sprite Burst to make two sprites
and get onto that battlefield. Once
you're on the battlefield,
one of my favorite sayings, this is
where the fun begins, right? [laughter]
So, we're going to play Rally the
Troops. One of my favorite cards. And
ironically, who's there in the middle of
Rally the Troop? It's Lux. It was meant
to be. What this says is when you play a
friendly unit, you get to draw a card.
Sorry, you draw a card, excuse me, but
when you play a friendly, you get to
buff it, which is very important this
combo.
>> Then the next thing you're going to do
is you're going to play Fiora to your
base.
>> And Fiora says when you play a unit or
when a unit control becomes mighty, you
can pay a order power to ready it. And
why is that important?
That's a good question.
>> Perfect. And we have Ranata Glask. So
Ranata Glask has a couple abilities here
that are important, but more
importantly, you can only use her
abilities when she's at a battlefield.
So this is why you need a battlefield
control to do this. So where my sprites
are at or where my echo's at, I'll play
her there.
>> Okay. Fiora will uh trigger because the
Rally the Troops is going to buff my
Ranata from four to five might, thus
becoming mighty. I will use
>> Oh, I get it. No, I don't. Finish.
>> We're connecting the dots slowly but
surely. Uh we'll then with that trigger,
we'll be able to pay an order uh an
order rune of power to be able to ready
our RNA. Now, she's at the battlefield.
She's ready.
>> Yes,
>> we have, I don't know, 3 million energy
and 2 million power. Her second ability
here says pay four and four blue power.
Exhaust her and score a point. So now
I'm at one and you're at seven, right?
How do I win from here? I use my friend
retreat. I retreat the RNA back to hand
and I do that over and over again until
I win the game.
I get it. I get it. I appreciate you
showing this to me.
>> This has reinforced my preconceived
notion, which is to play Lilia.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
Yeah. Yeah. Lullabi is a very good card
into this match for sure.
>> Oh, all jokes aside though, seriously,
uh this is I think a very fun combo. I
always love whenever we get to see some
of these neat interactions take off in
Riftbound and this just scratches the
surface. I know there are other similar
decks floating around and as we start to
get some of those uh enemy domain
pairings, when we get Vendetta, it's
going to get even more fun. So, I'm
really looking forward to it. This
really promotes
creativity in deck building cuz cards
like Promising Future, they don't really
see play in 1 v one. They're more for,
you know, 2v2 or, you know, a
free-for-all multiplayer format. So,
when I saw that the card was that this
card was being run in the deck, not only
am I a lux player from Spirit Forge, I
was playing control lux and spirit for
when I saw this, I was particularly
excited, but it is like you mentioned
opening up avenues where people are
trying to look for these limitless
strategies in decks like Jin, in decks
like orange. And so we're kind of seeing
them pop up all over the place, which I
find super cool. Uh, and I'm very
excited to see how they do this weekend.
That's all the time we have for this
beautiful little I'm going to call it a
pet project of mine cuz I'm still
optimizing on this. That's all we have.
Thank you for taking the time with us.
We're at the regional qualifier here in
Hartford and we'll see you soon. Hello
everybody. I'm here with George at the
uh Riftbound Regional Qualifier in
Hartford. Happy to have you back. I know
you took a bit of a break for set two,
but we got you back for set three. How
you enjoying the format?
>> I'm having a lot of fun. I'm playing
Diana, so I have the purple cards now,
which is which is a good time. They do a
lot of stuff.
>> Okay. Uh is uh you didn't play purple in
set one then? Cuz I know you played a
lot in Origins format.
>> Yeah, I was a Kai'Sa gamer. Strictly
Kai'Sa.
>> Okay.
>> And Falling Star was not overpowered.
>> Oh, really? You don't think so? I think
it's still is still overpowered right
now. Yeah, it looks it looks great right
now. Maybe it looks better right now.
>> Kai'Sa are actually doing very well on
the field right now. Have you played
against a Kai'Sa with Diana yet?
>> I played like one or two games.
>> I I have Mundo in my side deck. So,
>> that's a fun spice. What has your
matchup spread been so far to uh this
weekend?
>> I played so much Azir and so much
Aurora. Man, I prepared for Leblanc and
Ye. So, I've been seeing cards I've
never read before. I started started
playing it on Monday and it's been
tough. There was a camel that had like
four swords in one of the games. I had
never seen that
>> stuff for Diana to deal with. Did you
win that game?
>> Yeah, Mundo. Mundo beat up the camel.
>> There we go.
>> Mundo is a fun oneup. I like that
inclusion. Uh back in the old like
Origins TBO list, you know, we saw Mundo
creeping in. But um speaking of, you
actually had a couple of really good
runs back in Origins format. So you top
eight Houston. You won a Chinese
tournament, correct?
>> Yeah, mostly known for going to China
before the game released because I don't
know why I did that. It was crazy. I was
a different man that day where I decided
to do that.
>> Feeling adventurous.
>> Yeah, I was feeling adventurous. I I top
eighted the first Chinese regional ever.
So the first rift regional ever I was in
top eight. Uh for got knocked out of
that one and then two events later in
China I took home my first win uh in
Chongqing and that was that was so
exciting. I always wanted to like hold
the trophy on stage. That was cool.
>> That's so cool. What was it like playing
cuz I I got to imagine I mean you can't
be reading the cards. You have to have a
good encyclopedia in your head of what
everything does. I would say I prepped a
little bit for set two and I prepped
like four days for this tournament, but
probably 98% of my games are in Origins
and I still probably think I have the
most games ever found of a lot of
people. There's exceptions obviously,
but man, I played so much that one.
>> Yeah. Yeah. How long would you say or
how many games would you say you played
before it was released in the States?
>> Thousands. Thousands. That's crazy.
That's awesome.
>> I know every every rogue matchup. I know
everything going to China.
>> Well, we're happy to have you back. What
are your expectations for now in
Hartford in unleashed format? A lot of
new cards you're reading.
>> Yeah, this was a for fun event for me
for sure and I definitely learned that
halfway through day one. I learned that
it was a for fun event. Um, it looked at
people kept doing stuff I didn't know
what it was funny. My expectations for
this event were to have fun and see my
friends and I did I did that. So
>> awesome. So are all about you succeeded
on your on your mission
>> for the most part? Yeah. Maybe we'll
have fun at dinner tonight as well.
>> Having fun. Perfect. All right. Well,
thanks uh for the interview. Happy to
have you back, George. Back to the show.
Hi everyone.
>> Awesome chatting with George. Uh I did
not know how big of a legend he was
going into that interview. So then I got
to learn how cool he was live in person.
That was awesome.
>> Yeah, he's super fun. I've I've spoken
to him a lot in uh at kind of grassroots
tournaments. I've been
>> look like him.
>> Don't say that. Don't say that.
>> Just a little bit, you know.
>> Okay.
>> If you had a hat on, I could see it.
>> I mean, I it's one of the few people I
have more hair than, so I'll take that.
>> Ooh. Well, uh, hey, you're you're
winning in that department here on this
desk for now. But I'm winning the
department on the rings. People were
highlighting our rings earlier. Check
this out. I got more
>> I got more rings than you right now,
Gren. What are you doing?
>> Four, five, six, seven.
>> I got eight cuz I got two pinky rings
on.
>> All right. Well, if you're in Hartford,
if you're at the RQ and you have two
rings, bring them to me so I could beat
>> Congas here.
>> Okay. Well, bring me an extra one then
cuz then we can m Well, what if we had
10 each? Just one on each finger.
>> That's cool.
>> Yeah, there we go. I I cuz I got the two
pinkies on right now. I would need three
regular size ones kind of.
>> Okay.
>> Whatever a regular size ring is. Do you
know your ring sizes?
>> I do. Yeah,
>> you do.
>> Yeah. 9 10 11
>> Oh,
>> and 12.
>> Okay. 12 thumb. You got some I got a
thick thumb.
>> Let's show that to the camera. That's a
It's a sizable thumb. All right. Well,
we're getting ready for round 11 here uh
in the [laughter] regional qualifier.
And uh we're going to decide our next
matchup, but it's not us that get to
decide. It's you at home, Chad. Get
ready to vote because we're going to
take a look at our matchups. We have
Rivia on Lux versus CTG Allenz Q on his
Diana. A fan favorite for sure right
there. Otherwise, you're going to vote
for Funk Monks on Annie and HXN Strog on
Azir. I mean, I know what I want to see.
It's not even a question.
>> You want to see Funk Monks?
>> Yeah. I want to see Rivia on Lux for
sure. Especially against someone like
Allen's, right?
very explainer
as it's not going to be very easy to,
you know, pull off cuz you have to get
to the point where you can do the thing.
>> Also, keep in mind Allan uh is currently
wearing a suit.
>> Yeah.
>> He said he was going to wear a dress
shirt and if he made day two, he would
wear a suit. He is in a suit. Uh I saw
him. He had a nice pocket square and
everything. He looks dapper. He has a
better pocket square than I do.
>> Better pocket square than you do. Yeah,
>> we're underdressed.
>> Nice as well, though. I will say I
appreciate it.
>> And it looks like that's the win. So,
Rivia versus Allen's EQ will be our
streamed matchup. Shout out Funk Monks
and Strog. We might get to see some of
their match depending how quickly this
goes. But considering the match up,
something tells me it's not going to be
very fast. Why do you feel like I'm on
uh I'm on the the ball there?
>> Uh maybe. The thing is with Allen's list
is he's playing a very tempo Diana.
>> Okay. which if he can go fast enough in
the early game, he can actually probably
close it out before Lux can get to do
the combo.
>> Exactly. Yeah.
>> But uh I know Rivia is on a different
list than the one I showed for the
explainer where Rivia is actually
running three time warps.
>> Oo.
>> And the time warps kind of serve two
purposes. At the end of the combo, you
can just, you know, instead of making a
bunch of recruits and passing the turn
to your opponent, you can just go time
warp, time warp, time warp,
>> and I win the game. Um
>> it ends it faster, so you don't have to
keep doing the combo every turn.
>> Correct. Yeah. And it also acts as
almost a extra draw spell. So when
you're at a point where you just need to
dig through a few more cards in your
deck or you just need an extra turn or
two, you can time warp with your seals
of insights out. You don't really damp,
right? You'll dramp one, for example, or
you could at the very least just have
two seals out to keep your runes even.
You'll draw one off the Lux Legend and
then you'll draw one for your next turn
and you keep your opponent from scoring
at that point. So you kind of get two
turns to to do things and draw more
cards.
>> Interesting. And I'm also noticing
things like down downstage dramatics as
more draw power less two might or two
energy units. There's a soaring scout,
but there is not the watchful sentry. So
uh I'm imagining a turn one's going to
look like either soaring scout or just
uh you know like the the map or the
downstage dramatics just to get draws
immediately. You're not going to
actually be establishing much of
anything on your first turn with this
type of list.
>> Yeah. And also notably uh there is two
Rally the troops in the main deck.
>> Oh yeah. Most lists are only kind of
bringing those in for games two and
three. But this also does acts as a draw
spell as well.
>> True. Right. If you have nothing to do
on turn one because you're only, you
know, running a few things that cost two
energy, you can at least just rally the
troops, start digging early and then get
kind of getting in that lux on your
second turn and, you know, trying to
make things happen. One promising future
as opposed to most of the lists who are
running two. And that will kind of allow
you to dig into the um the progress day,
excuse me, much quicker. And as we can
see here, uh the first Diana that Rivia
played against was actually uh their
first defeat.
>> Yes.
>> So that's obviously very notable. Ulia
is a very tricky matchup for this uh but
three in a row with victory is very very
important. And then now going up
arguably one of the best, you know,
Diana to touch the the legend at this
point. Uh so Rivia does have their work
cut out for them.
>> Yeah, Allen's EQ is uh no slouch. So
let's see if Rivia is able to actually
get over the hump. Uh Lux was one that
you had your eye on saying could make
top eight, could take the entire event.
And uh I this might be the last
opportunity that the deck has cuz going
X2 means it's almost impossible to make
technically possible, but you really
want to be X1. Let's take a look at
Allen's EQ's matchups so far. He lost
earlier and has won out since. So, uh,
only got one loss to a Master Yi, but
seems like some Aurora matchups and, uh,
also a couple Diana mirrors in the last
few rounds. Yeah. So, playing against
some obviously, uh, very notable names,
right? Carmen is a very notable, you
know, uh, Riftbound player who's been at
a lot of the RQs, a Kaido as well. So,
Allen's kind of going through the
gauntlet here in day two, it looks like,
right? Playing against, you know, pretty
professional players now going up
against Rolivia. And if anyone can do
it, it's Allen, right? We've seen him
kind of play against the best and be
able to put up results and no one knows
their deck better than Allen's. Uh he'll
go home after RQ. He'll land, I don't
know, 5:00 a.m. and he'll ping his
Discord. All right, who's down to test?
Like he he does not he does not take
time off.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um so Allan, one of the kind of uh
superstars of the format so far and just
of the community, has uh made many many
deep runs. Known more for the Ezreal,
but has switched to Diana. Here's his
current list now. Um, any big surprises
you're seeing on this one, Grant? It
seems like a pretty standard list from
what I'm noticing other than maybe two
smoke screens. Sometimes I only see one
and an eclipse, but it looks like
there's no Eclipse in the main here.
>> Yeah, it looks like we're we're going
all in on the smoke screen, which which
I [music] like. Um, notably, we do have
um the two hard bargains main deck as
well, which could help against this Lux.
You can hard bargain that promising
future. Yes, it's kind of awkward where
you're like, I don't really want a hard
bargain in this promising future because
I get an extra card, too. But if they
promising future into a progress day,
they're now drawing six cards and you
got to play one. So, they kind of go up
on uh obviously a card economy. But at
the very least, you kind of hold a hard
bargain for a progress day in itself to
slow down that lux deck. But with
>> what looks like two, six, n eight two
drops it looks like. Uh if we can find
one of those early, we're able to kind
of start that tempo and try to beat this
Lux player before they can combo off.
>> Yep. Eight uh two energy units plus
flash and ride the wind means that this
Dionist can, if you see the right amount
of cards, play fast and not let the Lux
get to that late game point where you're
able to actually get the combo off.
Let's see if Allen can do it cuz we're
ready to hop in to game. Allen's EQ on
Diana trying to make a name for himself
on a new legend going up against
Limitless Lux. a very exciting new uh
adaptation for Lux builds. [music]
Typically was more of a control style.
Now Rivia might be able to show us the
strength of this. We've seen it on uh
some other streams before, but uh would
be the first time here in Hartford.
>> Yep. And we have a Rockfall path for
game one for Allens. Obviously Allen
also knows that the kind of one turn win
isn't in the main deck, right? The these
players talk to each other a lot. We do
find that two drop here for Allen. So a
great one, but unfortunately we do have
a forgotten monument. So kind of going
to slow down that the points that are
able to be found.
>> If you have like the flash or the ride
the wind, you're not going to be able to
score uh to that third right away, but
Allen can at least go in score one off
of his own rockfall path. And that is a
soaring scout for Olivia. So does have a
unit to play with early on.
>> Alen go in, discard a card, and fishing
for like you said things like the hard
bargain, things like the the fast spells
like ride the wind flash to let us get
in quick. Also, something notable that a
lot all the Diana are running is
acceptable losses.
>> Uh, and you have to be very careful
about when you play your uh forge of the
future. You you don't want to play it
too early because then it could just
start a showdown. Acceptable losses,
your forge of the future, and then one
of your ways to kind of loop that combo
is gone. So, most players here are going
to probably wait until they're ready to
do the thing before they do it. They're
not going to do any showdowns until
they've generated that energy and power
that they need to do. Uh, Bolivia does
have some a pretty tough decision here,
right? You're at five runes. There is a
world where you can perhaps try to
punish uh get rid of this traveling
merchant by sprite uh sprite bursting
and drawing a card. You can maybe
develop your lux here, but it is
dangerous into Diana because it could
just get pulled in by a moonfall. It's
now zero might and it looks like we are
going to be doing that sprite burst and
we're just going to try to get a couple
points on the board here early for the
Lux player. And again, these early
points are not super important.
>> Yeah,
>> but there is a world where you just win
through sprite burst.
>> And it's also more about uh slowing down
Allan. Don't let them have that extra
unit. You're getting some points. You're
getting a draw off of your um Lux Lady
of Luminosity as well. So, you know,
you're still accomplishing some tasks,
but you're also given a showdown window
here for Allen's EQ to use the Diana
legend. Still has one other rune up. So,
that would give two energy to play with.
>> Yeah, and I think debating if we want to
smoke screen here to try to get uh rid
of the sprite.
And it looks like we are going to smoke
screen. Damping
to put that sprite down to one. notably
smokec screen was uh you know negative
card that was printed in origin. So it
does have that minimum of one
stipulation that a lot of the new cards
don't
>> uh but enough to [laughter]
>> let's get I think I believe that those
were um uh Grace's uh handrawn sprites
before they were great. If you're at the
venue you can go find her. She's the one
dressed up like a ward in a brush.
>> Um fantastic cosplay. But the
interesting thing is that yeah you saw
the first sprite but you do not stop the
second. What you do is you maybe
convince the SAR scout to come out there
to get uh if Rivia wants that other
point here.
>> Well, we can't right because the
forgotten monument.
>> This is turn two for uh both players
going to Allen's turn three. So, he'll
be able to score that forgotten
monument. Um and I think the the goal
here was just to avoid a you know seven
might battlefield that it's a little
more awkward to break through if you're
a three might Diana. Um, and because
that soaring scout is there, there is a
world maybe where you want to push it
off, but you also don't want to ramp
this Lux. It's very dangerous.
>> Well, Lux currently no runes up, so
Allen will be able to just play this
turn. Diana goes in and we'll find a
Moonfall off the top
>> two.
>> Pretty solid against most matchups. I
don't know how much it actually gets
done into the Lux. That's a the weird
thing about Lux is that traditionally
very strong cards don't actually do as
much against this deck because it's not
playing the normal riftbound game
>> temporary.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, we're just going to kind of
hold up some interaction here. Having
that soaring scout there when the
temporary does pop from that sprite,
you'll still be able to hold to two. So,
this kind of late game combo deck is
keeping up with point tempo for now, but
this is kind of where now you need to
invest in drawing cards. You can take a
develop, but now it's a little more
aggressive and figure out how I'm going
to start a lot of
stupify is one way to do that. A single
energy cost and you'll get a draw plus
the minus one on the Diana. I doubt
that's going to matter. It's probably
just for the draw here for Olivia.
>> Yeah.
>> And giving temporary to the Soren Scout
to draw two cards.
>> Yeah. So, we've drawn three so far this
turn. One from Stupify, two from that
Shadows Call. Going to try to find a way
to draw some more. Ideally, if we're uh
if we're Rolivia here, uh three a turn
is kind of meh. There it is. Now, four
is okay.
>> Sure. Yeah. I was thinking like
downstage dramatics could be one. Uh
obviously uh Rally the troops can do it
as well. And here is the forge of the
future. You mentioned it can be
dangerous to play this early. Was Rivia
on uh two copies of it in the main or
just one?
>> Um usually you're you have to be in at
least two, right, to do the loot? Uh
some I play three in my list. Uh some
players have played three because of
decks like Diana, right? So if they try
to interrupt you, you still able to go
notably kind of almost forcing their own
hand by playing the forge of future
because you did play Rally of the
Troops. So playing the forge of the
future gives you that buff on that
recruit. So it makes a two might recruit
which you can kind of do more with than
just that one might recruit every turn.
>> Yeah, kind of checks the rain bloom or
at least will force out something from
Allen if they try and contest. But Allen
will hold for a third point. Has a unit
to conquer for a fourth. So, I would say
Allen was slightly slowed down. A lot of
that was forgotten monument and then the
sprite burst, but I don't think Allen's
like too far behind in speed here.
>> Not at all. This is You were able to now
even dig through the deck even more by
doing this tide turner move,
>> which is very useful here.
>> This is kind of
>> a slowish I would say start for Olivia.
So, it's very good news for Allens where
he's able to kind of get up to four
here.
>> I imagine Allens is digging for the
specific cards that work in this match
up. Hard bargains one of them.
Acceptable losses could be another. I
don't see one in hand.
>> Allen is passing with
>> Oh, there is a hard bargain, I believe.
Oh, there is one already. Okay, so
already has one of the uh the ways to
interact with the Lux combo.
>> And now we can repeat the hard bargain.
We've passed with a lot of runes up.
>> So, a progress day here, I think, does
get fully countered. Yeah, cuz we only
have three runes available after we
exhaust six. If we promising future, we
can pay for the repeated hard bargain.
however, so um not sure what cards are
in hand for Rivia.
>> Let's see what Rivia wants to go for.
Okay, going to go for a recycle.
Creating a power. Get our seal.
>> Into another seal.
>> Mhm.
>> There's the progress D. It's going to
get met with a hard bargain repeated. So
this a very good spot for for Allens.
Now
>> this would have been a draw five if we
didn't have that hard bargain. So one
rune short and notably if we left that
soaring scout on the battlefield last
turn with temporary.
>> Yeah.
>> It might have either for this Allen
might have either not pushed up
>> or
might have pushed up and if he did then
we'll have that ready rune to pay for
that bargain. it would have been
available at Rivia's start of turn. So
yeah, sometimes using those scouts, you
know,
as like a just a ramp tool and not a
body that you're trying to save cuz
yeah, it was going to go anyway.
>> But either way, uh, Rivia will still be
trying to dig through as much as
possible. Retreat goes in just to try
and channel another run. This will now
be 12 runes up for Rivia at the start of
their next turn, but Allen will hold to
six. Allen can win in one more turn.
Rivia has not dug through very much of
this deck. I do not think Rivia is going
to be very close to actually getting to
the full combo.
>> I did think I saw a time warp in Rivia's
hand.
>> Okay.
>> Uh we're going to be on 12 runes next
turn. So you can uh you know time warp,
use two seals if you need to, right? To
only Damp two uh draw cards, see what
you draw, float um you know, you have
two more runes to work with afterwards
as well. So you can maybe draw another
um rally the troops or something like
that. So draw a couple cards, then go to
another turn, keep allens off a turn,
right? So you can technically if you
have time warps to chain, you can start
digging, but I think it might be a
little too little too late for Rivia
here unless they can kind of pull off a
miracle. So there's a Fizz, Vex,
Apathetic, and Traveling Merchant. I
imagine it's Fizz. Probably go for
something like another stacked deck.
Just keep digging for those uh hard
bargains. That's really the best tool
Allen has in the main deck. And you'll
notice players like Allen will quickly
identify what is my out to my opponent's
strategy and how do I just get to it as
fast as possible. He has been, you know,
really speeding through his own deck
here with multiple stack decks, multiple
uh draw cards, using that Diana to great
effect as well. I don't think I see a
hard bargain. I do see another Moonfall
or Vex very similarly colored cards.
>> Uh we did pretty quickly take a card. So
curious to see the contents of Allen's
hand if we get another little hand
shuffle like he does.
>> But this is kind of the obviously now
the most important turn. Looks like we
have two Moonfalls, a student, a
stupify.
>> Aust and a way. It looks like uh is the
second to last card if I'm not mistaken.
>> Okay, pulling the Diana back. Makes
sense. Allen can then try and get its
ability on the next turn and just pass
with the tie turn remaining. So, Rivia
needs to do something here. You pretty
much need to win here. Yes, you have the
uh
>> uh time warps as an option.
>> Progress stays promising future. a lot
of ways to draw through, but with only
12 runes up, it's going to be difficult.
>> Two time warps, I think I see in hand.
>> Oh, that's actually very interesting.
That's going to draw essentially four
cards here for Rivia.
>> A double hard bargain would completely
shut this down. But we know Allen ZQ
does not have it. So suppose the
reactions you could be thinking about
would be like Gust potentially or
stupify.
>> Yeah. So one time warp used. I think
there was another one in hand if I saw
correctly. We're going to go to our next
turn. Again, back up to 12 runes. Those
seals really helping by mitigating the
power cost of that time warp since it is
a very, very steep cost. We do have
another time warp. I see it in the
window there.
>> Can't count the deck.
>> Yeah, now we got to figure out how many
cards we have left.
>> Sorry. Yes,
>> it's banished. Yeah, time warp does get
banished. Good looks on the judge there
to uh to pinpoint that, especially with
cards like Forge of the Future that we
can, you know, accidentally recycle it
if we were like, "Oh, maybe this time
we're bought, you know, hard bargain
previously and that's why it's in my
trash."
>> I just still don't think that Rivia is
going to be able to get there. You need
so many draws
cuz that that hard bargain was great and
Rivia didn't have the best three. Okay,
we're going to go echo sacrifice here,
which is going to allow us to generate
enough runes to progress day and time
warp.
>> Okay. Oh, true. Yeah, cuz you you uh
float all the energy and then ready
everything. So, technically here we have
what uh 17 at our disposal.
>> Is that fine?
>> Yes, that's fine.
>> Channel.
>> Yeah,
>> draw two.
Maybe 18 it looks like cuz they have
seven right there. So potentially
>> yeah they have enough to play time warp
for free or sorry excuse me progress day
for free because they have seven
floating in a power so they don't need
to use one of their last seal. There it
is. Six in a power is going to get used
for that progress day to draw five.
>> Uh unless Allen has something here. No
Allen's letting it happen.
>> And that is four draws.
>> We do have a ruination in hand notably.
>> Oh
>> so we could count on the game a lot.
Yeah.
>> However, if we have a Quay, which I
think Allen does have, and if there is a
ride the win in hand, he can kind of get
back into it. I don't know if he can win
in one turn unless he has also a tie
turner, right? So, we in tie turner it
back and then go to the other
battlefield.
>> Temporary draw, too.
>> And was
Yeah, I guess he's looking for an answer
here. He needs to try to find a hard
bargain. Uh otherwise,
>> we're going to sack. Yep.
>> Sack results the cost. Yes, this is a
really really good
>> four.
>> Yeah,
>> this is really good for sequencing.
>> So, the untap first.
>> He's very scared of
>> one power.
>> Yeah.
>> Five and a power.
>> Uh sack resolves.
>> Yeah.
>> Draw two.
>> Superify.
>> Super fire resolves.
Shadow call resolves. Draw two.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, like you were highlighting,
great sequencing right there. Making
sure that you're getting all of your
energy back. It's amazing how Rivia is
able to still dig and still have all
these runes up. You would think, oh, 12
energy spent in a turn. I think Rivia
spent more than 12 energy already and
still has all this back plus five more
floating
>> sacrifice on the bottom.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, we're setting up our
combo turn now.
>> I missed the deck count, but I mean with
ruination, you'll probably buy yourself
at least one more turn.
>> Five. No power.
>> Yeah. Echo.
>> Another echo. If we have another
sacrifice, this is really good.
>> Shadow's call sacrifice will go
absolutely crazy right now.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay, keep digging. Keep digging.
>> Yes, we have it.
>> Okay.
>> Sacrifice. That's good. Five.
>> And he's netting energy every time he
does. He's almost doing the combo
without having an empty deck. Obviously,
he can't do this deterministically
because there is still a bunch of cards
in deck, but I'm h I'm geeking out a
little bit. I love watching someone who
is much better than me play this deck.
>> It is shocking how quickly Rivia was
able to get to that point. I did not
think there was a world that Rivia would
be able to actually pull it off with
what was in hand. But multiple
sacrifices,
>> multiple uh cards,
>> promising futures.
So, 13 cards and we know the bottom is
echo sacrifice. sacrifice echo. We know
that is
>> uh or it's actually probably echo echo
sacrifice sacrifice echo is your bottom
>> two echoes first.
>> Yeah. Is your bottom five cards. So you
have to kind of draw through
>> I want to say seven or eight cards and
then you can start the combo.
>> It's seeming like that. The deck looks
like it's around like the 13 progress
day is huge here. Another one's coming
out. That'll draw four more cards
and then maybe like one more progress
day essentially would get you there.
>> Should be eight cards.
>> Yep.
>> And we know the bottom five. So, three
cards we need to dig through
>> two and a
>> Mhm.
>> Promising future.
>> There's the future.
>> Okay.
>> And we know that we don't have a our
third progress state in our hand. So,
we're going to see it off this five cuz
we know the bottom of our deck.
>> It's five. I don't think we're taking
the echo actually. Maybe not.
>> One of them uh hard bargain.
>> One was hard bargain. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> So, we're going for that echo
>> for free. We can ex I don't know if we
accelerate the echo here. The thing is
you're also giving Allen's a free card,
but
>> if it's a unit, you can just ruination
if you whiff on the combo a little bit.
>> Go for it.
>> Uh you're going to play yours first. I
don't know if they want to wait, but
>> yeah. So, very good by Allen here
looking for that hard bargain.
Desperately there's one left in the
deck. Does he find it?
>> Hold on a second.
>> It's so hard to see from this angle.
>> I can't hear him, so I don't know what
he's saying.
>> Yeah. Just give us one second.
>> You're good.
>> Play. Play.
>> Yes. So,
>> finaliz.
>> He's not supposed to know what this is.
>> These are all play.
>> That's what we were talking about.
>> Are Are you Are you sure?
>> Oh, he does know what it is.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Well, he knows what it is anyway.
[laughter]
He knows what I'm doing. This is
>> all in resolution. One sec. This is
pending, correct? But we go. This will
now resolve.
You sure? Okay, I trust you. I'm not
worried about it. I know Allan knows
what I'm doing.
>> Yeah, it's okay. Okay, so pay your power
right now to finalize this.
>> Yeah, the only part we were talking
about is if he does get to know
>> notably there is a Lux trigger as well
because his promise has resolved.
>> So I'll play the echo
>> and that should be on top of the stack
deck.
>> Yes.
>> Uh and then
>> uh draw from Lux.
>> There we go. Perfect.
>> Rivia showing a masterass of how to
pilot this Lux deck.
I don't know if Allan's found the So,
six cards. We're very close. We are in
lethal range for our Lux player now.
>> Okay. And going fast, too. The downside
of the Lux deck is that it takes a while
to do this. And even though he's
digging, he hasn't even started the
combo. Uh 43 minutes left on the clock.
I would say that this is somebody who
clearly knows what they're doing. And
once you get the combo, if you're fast
enough on it as well, you can get
through it really quickly. these dice
cuz they're bigger and it makes
>> you have to do a lot of but once you uh
show that you can do the the loop two
times you're allowed to just say how
many times you do it.
>> Yep. Correct.
>> Channel one draw two
>> eight floating energy
still looks like five cards left in
deck. Four I think five. We did just
recycle the echo. Allan's trying to see
what is in the trash as well. We have a
sacrifice in hand. I think I see the
forge. Are we going to play the forge
now? Maybe to start sculping the bottom
of our deck. Yep.
>> Or recruit.
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry. I They're real
recruits. Yeah. Yeah,
>> that's fine.
>> They're [laughter] real recruits.
>> Yeah, that looked like five when he
fanned it out. Now, does Rivia have a
thousand of those
>> power?
>> And does he want to play all of them to
the field?
>> That's the question.
>> We're going to do it
>> just for the sake of it. Makes it
easier.
>> Eko's back on the field now. sacrifice
>> four.
>> Oh, this is
>> I feel like
>> yeah, even if you had like a hard
bargain, you're not able to hit that
one.
>> I don't even know if there's been like a
good opportunity for all two hard
bargains.
>> And now there's so much resources in
play. Hard bargain doesn't stop this at
this point. Like hard bargain does
nothing.
>> Uh spend one.
>> Yeah. I don't even think like if off
that sack deck you find it would have
done anything.
>> Oh, double stupify is going to get him
into now. He can We are alive. We are
live now.
>> Yep. We're gonna see it. Everybody strap
in.
You've seen the YouTube shorts. You've
seen the explanations. I should say
YouTube longs. Probably
>> YouTube longs and 13minute explanation.
>> Your 13-minute explanation. Although I
think a lot of that was charmer trying
to follow along uh on what you were
talking about. Um but here we go. We're
going to see the loop. The Limitless Lux
in action.
A lot of uh air quote infinites will be
happening here. It just depends on how
many uh Olivia wants or Rivia wants to
um declare that they're going to do it
for.
>> Yeah.
>> What would you say if you got to pull it
off on feature match? What number would
you pick?
>> I do it 29 million times. Why 29? I
don't know.
>> Just felt right in the moment.
>> 420 million.
>> 420 million. Why did you pick that
number, Gretton?
>> Cuz Jyn has four. And then you said 29,
so 420.
Yes,
>> two to [laughter] draw one.
>> Blazing through the turn right now.
Rivia is going to try and show us what
the combo does
>> as that's one more draw. And now
everything will get the buff on it.
>> Will we even have enough buffs in the
building is the question. And uh yeah,
so you had highlighted how the combo
works in a video before going into this
match. Do you want to give everybody an
update just in case they're tuning in,
they didn't get to see that last one and
they are unsure what is about to happen
because essentially we will get to uh
whatever Olivia declares a number of
like recruits and number of energy uh in
play.
>> Yeah. So what's happening here is we're
going to essentially loop the echo
through cards like sacrifice to make
sure our deck is echo, forge of the
future, sacrifice, and shadow call.
Those are four cards. And then all every
time we loop, we can shadow call one of
our units. We can then sacrifice in
reaction to that shadow call and then
we're drawing four. So as long as we
have forges available like we do,
>> we can continue to do this and make as
much energy as we want. And then when
Rivia is ready and you know comfortable
with the amount of energy that that they
were able to create
>> 420 million 29 million whatever it is
whatever they choose then they will move
to the power loop which is a bit
different where we're going to be using
retreats to create power by playing
retreat and in reaction to the retreat
we're going to recycle one of our runes
to create as much as you want to to be
honest. So
>> uh how do you win? Just demonstrate the
win.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Demonstrate the win. Uh, so I'm going to
loop obviously as you know. I'm going to
kill everything on the board.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm going to take two extra turns and I
have sprite burst.
>> Mhm.
>> I'm going to put 10 billion sprites on
both battlefields. I'll go 246.
[laughter] I'm actually So yeah, it's
246.
>> Mhm.
>> Or 468.
>> Yeah, he's got two time warps here. Time
warp next turn. You do it again. That's
the six.
>> Play through. That's good.
>> All right, we're going game two. So we
saw the combo.
>> Wow. And what's crazy is Adams was on
six points. And I'm curious if any
knowers in the chat
>> can find out the first time Rolivia
counted his deck before he or after he
played that first time warp, how many
cards were left? Because a lot of Lux
players have a problem getting to this
point
>> because their opponents are already on
six. And if you have 15 or 20 cards left
in your deck, you have to churn through
16 at least of those to be able to go uh
and do this. Now, we're going to be
going to the paper tree, which is also
dangerous because, as we saw, the more
runes you give the Lux player to use,
the more difficult it is to stop them
when they're going uh and they're
comboing off.
>> But we saw the successful combo. Allen
was not able to shut it down.
Congratulations to Olivia for finding a
way to dig through the deck and show one
of the most unique ways to win in
Riftbound currently. Allen's back on the
play going first again. Let's see if
he's able to clutch it out this time.
His hand looks a little funky. I think I
saw was there a wages of pain in the
hand for for Livia. I'm not entirely
sure.
>> Interesting.
I guess the idea being you slow down
your opponent by clearing out their
units early game so they are not able to
get to that six points or I mean ideally
the eight points as well.
>> Yeah. And that gold helps you a lot uh
in not dramping. There's a lot of power
hungry cards. Echo cost of power,
progress day, promising future. So being
able to uh
>> you know create a gold would be very uh
generous there. and kind of helps you
not der. But I'm not sure. Maybe I'm
just seeing things. Now that we found
his hand again, I don't think I saw the
wages.
>> Oh, there is. I'm not crazy.
>> I mean, I think you throw this out if
you're Olivia.
>> Yeah,
>> there it is. Wages of pain comes down.
Does Allen have a response? There's one
stupify that
>> Stupify the tie turner.
>> Yep.
>> And it's now out of range because of the
abandoned hall.
>> Oh, there's already at the abandoned
hall. Yes, true.
>> The gold. Yeah, that's nice. And
[laughter] okay, we have the proper
gold.
Ride the wind is very good here. Y
>> Oh wow. Yes. Still enough because he
used the Diana scorn of the moon legend
ability to pay for the stupify. Still
had two energy up.
>> Gets another point and gets off the
paper tree. So you're not going to hold
there and give Rivia an extra uh energy.
>> And this is where you see the Lux Crown
Guard come out because we're very behind
now if we're if we're Lux and we need
that extra two resources every turn to
kind of climb back into this game.
However,
if we have a moonfall, it's going to be
really rough. What I do like is that
Allens has now sideboarded in his Baron.
>> So, allows him that once he gets to 10
points faster.
>> He could just score an extra point which
might be able to close out the game.
>> Allen will go and conquer two right
here. Should go up to four total. And
there it is at the top.
>> And passes with that. Still two up for
hard bargain
>> if that's in hand. I haven't gotten a
good look at Alenc's hand yet.
I think there's a time warp in Rivia's
hand.
>> Seal ruination.
>> That's what I've seen.
>> Uh, stupify
to draw into the deck.
Can now recycle that.
>> Sunk's map is nice here as well. It's
going to draw you four uh two cards at
least if you play it.
>> Uh, shadows call. Nice. I'm going to
play with this shadow.
>> Yes. Yeah, naturally.
>> Yep. You can uh exhaust the Lux Crown
Guard to give yourself two energy that
can be spent on spells this turn.
>> Oh, we have a retreat. So, we can
retreat the Lux. We have another Shadow
Call. So, we can retreat
>> uh the Lux
and set up for another Shadow Call next
turn if we want to.
>> That's good.
>> We're drawing some cards. So, we've
drawn four cards this turn, which again
is anytime you're drawing more than four
cards a turn of the Lux deck, it's good
until you're ready to really go, I call
it turbo, right? When you're ready.
Okay, I'm digging for the combo. Now, if
you can draw more than four a turn,
you're you're in a pretty good spot.
>> I think we're going to get more than
four this turn.
>> Retreat comes out. Now Allen has a
response.
>> August titer.
>> Okay,
>> Gusting Tide Turner.
>> This is really a heads up play because
now we're not triggering the paper tree
by holding.
>> True.
Slow down Rivia on the energy cuz the
more energy Deluxe has to play with, the
faster they can dig through that deck.
And Allen still needs two turns in order
to win. Yeah. However, oh, we're not on
10 runes, but
>> once we're on five points with a Baron
in hand,
>> we're in lethal range.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. But still need two turns. We're
going to go to six here most likely on
Allen's side. Sump works map is going to
trigger and draw us a card off the hold.
And then when we, you know, ultimately
conquer that paper tree, we'll be able
to draw another one from the Sump Works
map before it, you know, dies to the
temporary trigger on Rivia's uh
beginning step. And if you think about
it, that's essentially a six draw turn.
Um because there was the four off of the
double stupify and the shadows call and
then now two off of the map. So
>> very very efficient for Olivia. We saw
what they were able to do last time when
they didn't have an ideal setup. But
there's the acceptable losses that will
>> Oh,
>> only clears the gold gear, right? Yeah.
So Rivia gets to choose
>> conquer six score.
Yeah, give the opportunity for the uh
the misplay if Rivia just takes away the
map. They don't get the draw, but the
gold gear, I mean, also I guess feels
somewhat good for Allen's EQ here.
Slow down Rivia a little bit, but
Allen's right back to the same position
he was last game. And now Rivia's back
into essentially the same position. If
your opponent scores two points, you
lose. you have to find the combo either
now or find something like um heroine to
just kind of clear the board and give
yourself space to work with. So there is
a ruination right in hand that we can
play next turn if
we have oh no we're on seven runes for
Allen. So we're not going to get greeted
by a Baron if we ruination now where
otherwise if he was on you know eight
runes and he was able to then we might
get hit by a baron. And now has to
decide am I going for the combo? Am I
gonna try to turn through my deck or do
I need to buy myself some more time?
>> Yeah,
>> we are in time warp mana and it or
excuse me, time warp energy, but
>> that's nine. That's a ruination. Yeah,
I'm just trying to slow it down.
>> And showing that he's got the game right
there.
>> I believe there was a ride the wind in
the discard so he can fizz. Ride the
wind in. Tight turner. Swap with the
fizz. Move the fizz into the other one.
And that's eight points. Allan just
shows I got it. And now I [laughter] got
Now I got it. Yeah, now I got it. That
is a game three. And also trying to save
a lot of time there. I think it's
crucial in these matchups that you don't
want to go to time, especially if you're
in time against the Lux. Really really
scary because they basically get just
two turns to play
>> and like they're it doesn't matter if
like the whole win by two. They're
they're just going to do the full combo.
>> That turn doesn't all my other turns
>> if they have at least the ranada
version.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> I mean solitary at this point like you
don't [laughter] need to think.
>> There's like a little bit thinking
because there's a different amount of
cards in your deck every game and so you
have to like think of a little bit about
how to get there but
>> uh once you get there is yeah [laughter]
>> for Olivia explaining where the
difficulty in the deck is is getting
there. Once you're there it's just a
little bit of solitire of showing off
>> what the combo is and then getting the
combo off.
So, Aspirin's game, the tale is old as
time, mulliganing a time warp, and then
drawing a time warp off your mulligan.
>> Oh, is that what happened there? I guess
that that's great.
>> But, uh, a good start, right? Soaring
scout. We're on aspirin's game. We're
going first.
>> Uh, we can actually, you know, really
take advantage of this spot because we
are playing to nine. However, we know
that Allens has a Baron in there. So, he
can stay on even points to bluff the
extra turn and then close it out with a
Baron at the end.
>> And also,
>> very, very interesting. stand odd runes
ideally as well cuz you just kind of
wait it out until you ramp up to that
>> yeah that number. Now Diana can go in on
the next turn for Allen, but Rivia
already has the Sorian Scout with four
runes up so can try and score a point
here or actually just going to establish
Deluxe Lady of Luminosity not putting
the Soren Scout out which could get you
a point and then channel a rune. So
>> kind of curious to see like maybe talk
to Olivia later to figure out what why
are we not what is our scout for? Or is
it just for a Shadow's Call?
>> I would imagine Shadow's Call. Yeah, cuz
if one of your unit is dealt with, then
you want a second one to make sure that
you have the Shadows Call, but I would
argue that Diana's best ways to deal
with your units are to return them back
to your hand. So then you could still
play it anyway. I know it slows you
down, but it's curious thought.
>> Yeah, we do have a hard bargain in hand.
Uh so Rivia does have to fight through
at least one.
>> Sure.
>> Uh which we saw him do in game one. So
not an impossible
matchup for him to to close out. But
again, this early game is so important
for Allens to play perfectly or else, as
we saw, you can get the six and get
completely blown out.
>> Yep.
>> And only one point scored for Allen on
that turn. Was not able to get a second
one down. But I guess it is. Aspirin's
climb, so being on odd numbers doesn't
feel too bad. It's not like you're
really speeding it up very much by
having that second point right now.
>> Stupify.
>> Yeah,
>> Stupify comes out from Olivia.
Essentially, there's 1 2 3 four more
turns for Allen to win this game. So,
Rivia has four turns to find the way to
the combo.
>> Ooh, and a repeated uh downstage
dramatic, excuse me, with using Lux as
well. So, we're able to draw. Again,
this is our fourcard turn so far, right?
One for the turn, three extra.
So, not a terrible one. As you said,
there are, you know, about four turns
left u for Atlands before he can close
it out. But this is where Allan is going
to be able to, especially since he had
that Hay that he revealed with the
Diana, he's been able to draw a lot of
cards.
>> Yeah.
>> And if he finds his counters, it's going
to be tough.
>> I almost wonder if that's something that
you could have looked
>> I doubt it'll come up, but
>> Olivia gets a little information. He
says it himself. [laughter]
>> Doesn't change anything. Yeah.
>> Now, Grant, I know that this is exciting
for you cuz you were the one that said
Lux making top eight. That was your deck
to take the whole thing.
>> Whether you actually decided that or
production decided that for you and you
were just banking it either way,
[laughter]
>> okay, the flash is going to come out.
>> Go ahead.
>> Might as well use it if he knows about
it.
>> And then you can trigger the Diana
again. Uh, Lux is my pet deck. It's my
favorite deck. I do think that if it
does see a top eight, it has a real
chance of winning, but getting there is
very difficult as we see because not
only are you have to get to the combo
like Rivia said,
>> you'll get to the combo sitting across
Allens.
>> Yep.
>> Now the SA scout will be committed.
>> One,
>> one point for one trigger targon past
not have to.
>> Oh, that's actually nice. Being able to
trigger the Targons and then now have
three to play with gives you more
options for things like stupifies into
stupifies. And trying to see what else
is in hand there for Rivia. It's pretty
big hand already. Yeah,
I see a Fizz in hand for Allen's EQ.
See a couple of units. A hard bargain.
So, not not actually the worst uh setup
here. You can get in quickly
and try and uh dig for more of these
hard bargaines cards.
>> Oh.
getting rid of the Hay actually, which
is interesting.
>> Now, this is interesting as well. Vex
apathetic. I know that um ruination will
still clear it, but like in a pinch if
Rivia needs to try and accelerate an
Echo in that could slow it down. So,
maybe that comes up
>> ride the wind. Pretty good.
>> I wonder if this that would have changed
Allen's decision to
>> um to discard that Quay if he knew, you
know, he was going to see a ride the
wind
>> cuz it let you turn through the deck. Uh
the Targon's obviously being impactful
here, allowing the rally the troops to
get played since it is action speed or
as that Diana goes in. So giving you an
extra card that you wouldn't have
otherwise had on your opponent's turn is
always always good when you're looking
to draw your entire deck.
>> Yep.
Now Allen's up to three points. Still
needs three turns to close out the game.
And we saw what Rivia was able to get
done
>> in a much worse position. There's the
Vex
>> again. And really all it's shutting down
is the potential play of like an Echo
accelerating in and crashing, which in a
pinch can, you know, give you a little
extra energy to work with, but
>> it's not going to be nearly as
devastating as say the Rengar decks seen
that hit a field.
>> Okay,
>> just uh super fight here. That's good.
>> More draws. Nine energy to work with
now. Eight for Rivia. Let's go
four by six.
>> Progress day.
>> I would imagine progress day and four
>> and keeping exactly four up. Very nice.
>> Good.
>> And that's four plus one from the Lux
Crown Guard Legend or sorry, the lady of
luminosity legend.
>> So essentially five draws off of the
progress day. So
>> we've drawn six this turn plus our card
for turn through the stupify.
>> Pretty good.
>> Progress day. Not bad. And again, uh,
Allens will go to five here and at least
three more turns. Looks like five,
seven, nine. Even if we get that Baron
and go to eight doesn't really help on
an aspirin game.
>> Yeah, you hear a long sigh from Allen
there. I think realizing the situation
he's in. Rivia is very close to having
the full setup. Another shadow's call.
>> There's the hard bargain. Probably going
to come out here. I kind of like it
because
>> Allan is kind of thinking about it. I
would I would I like it, but I guess
Allen's Allen's not a fan. He's trying
to keep it to
>> thwart the combo itself.
>> Yeah, I think it seems like Rivia is
playing this very well. The only thing
I'm like processing that Allen could do
it better is maybe a second hard bargain
and then if you can double hard bargain
the the first sacrifice cuz they would
sacrifice you hard bargain, double, they
pay the cost, then you again when it
goes to the chain for the sacrifice, I
believe you'd be able to hard bargain it
again. And like maybe that's enough to
>> So you're saying you're hard bargaining
the shadows call or the sacrifice?
>> The sacrifice. But I guess the the cost
>> still you'll still kill the echo but
you'll prevent the channel and the draw
which can thwart throw them off. But
with that many cards in hand at that
point if you need to draw two more cards
you probably have you know a stupify or
something like that that can draw you
that card. Right. So
>> getting
>> it's really hard to stop the combo once
it's there.
>> So I always tell players if you can slow
it down before it gets there is probably
a better play. But obviously Allens is a
lot more uh knowledgeable about the game
uh in how to win specifically than I am.
So uh he has a game plan that he wants
to stick to and I'm curious to see how
it pans out.
>> Allens is up to five points now. Needs
two more turns
>> and just a pass there. Still has a hard
bargain in hand.
Relivia will uh trigger the death nail
from the temporary and get an extra rune
channeled exhausted draw for turn.
That's an echo. It's so hard to keep
track of anything in Olivia's hand at
this point, but you got to imagine
they're close.
>> So, we had 18 cards in deck last turn. I
know Allen's asked for account. Um we
just drew an echo, so 17 and now we can
echo sacrifice and start getting out of
range of this hard bargain again. Yeah.
>> Do we have the hand composition right
now to draw, you know, 16 cards, 15
cards? That I don't know. But with the
Lux in play,
>> yeah,
>> it's we have an extra energy, right? So,
we're technically at 13 runes right now
>> if we count Lux.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, one was Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Perfect.
>> And there's the progress day coming out.
>> See if Allen tries to hard bargain this
one.
This is the issue. Oh yeah.
>> 1 2 3 4 5 six. We have exactly enough to
echo. Um and if you again if you hard
bargain the sacrifice I'm still getting
all my runes back.
>> Yes. So if you hard bargain this one
instead then maybe they don't go for I
mean they're not going to be able to
draw before going for the echo play.
>> Looks like we're going to maybe take one
turn off for counting.
>> 12 cards.
>> 12 cards left. So almost there.
>> Okay.
double time warp in hand as well notably
which is very very scary especially when
you have uh Lux crown guard because you
can use her to pay for the time warp so
you can keep two extra runes open for
that hard bargain
>> and she'll keep readying if the time
warps go off and then keep looping into
more but maybe that's what Allens is
waiting for
>> is the time warp coming out say hard
bargain that one that's the biggest
threat because that is kind of your
entire turn I know if you're already at
12 you can lux uh pay for two of them
and still have four up
>> but it doesn't look like Rivia's going
to be going for a big push right now.
There's just a forge coming out for the
recruit. Although, as I say that, I
suppose the forge could start putting
things back into the deck if Relivia
wants to keep going. But you're not
going to get the echo into the sacrifice
this turn because we just spent two of
that energy for F forge of the future
now
>> in the tank right now with Rivia. Big
decisions.
>> Garbage grabber.
>> Whoa.
Just another way to dig into your deck.
You're able to
>> Wow.
>> I believe it's recycle three from your
trash.
>> Recycle three from your trash, pay uh an
energy, exhaust it to draw a card.
>> Interesting. It's another way to
recycle. So, if your Forge of the
Futures uh go away, this can also help
you get there. Obviously, it's only a
once uh per turn activation cuz you have
to exhaust it. But,
>> and map is great here.
>> In deck,
>> uh 11, I believe.
>> 3 6 9 11. Yeah,
>> 11 in deck. So you were at
>> one was just drawn there.
>> That's correct.
>> So the it was 12 then one drawn when
Allen holds. So now 11 left in deck.
There'll be another drawn.
>> If Allen goes in and conquers. Targon's
Peak. Yeah, I imagine Allen will have to
do that.
>> And here we are cycling now. We just
need We need stuff to interact. Stock
deck lets us dig more. Diana lets us dig
more.
>> Yeah.
>> Ah.
>> Oh no.
[laughter]
>> Don't do that. Don't do that. Diana has
a stack deck on her. That'd be crazy.
>> For [laughter] real. That would be
crazy.
>> Okay.
>> Ride the wind.
>> Yeah. Conquer.
>> And the Sumpworks maps triggering for
Rivia as well. So drawing two cards on
Allen's turn so far.
>> Stuck deck
>> at 10 cards left in deck for Rivia.
>> I imagine Allen is digging for another
hard bargain here
or something sided if he has a a
sideboard option uh to answer the Lux
build.
I'm not sure if Allan did, you know,
maybe swap a cartoon in his sideboard
for it. Maybe assuming that there's like
two players that he maybe thought were
proficient enough to really push it and
>> two players out of a 1600 player
tournament, 1,800 player tournament.
Maybe you don't check for it, but maybe
there's a one of that kind of hits
multiple matchups that you can uh you
can bring in.
>> I'm wondering if something like abandon
would have any additional use here just
cuz it kind of
>> Oh, this is nice. We're getting rid of
Lux.
>> Oh, that is very nice. very well looking
for that Moonfall. Find it and notably
this starts another showdown.
>> So we can look again with our Diana
Lunari.
>> Sure.
>> Getting some good value out of Moonfall
which we had highlighted before. Not
necessarily expected in this matchup.
Does get another spell drawn.
>> Smoke screen added to hand for Allen.
Lux is gone. That means two less energy
to spend on spells on Rivia's turn
>> in this match up for sure. [laughter]
Allan draws a smoke screen and you know
pretty pretty you know insignificant
card in a in a matchup that uh uh
actually it's pretty good if he if he's
going for the Ranata combo.
>> Would you have an ability Oh yeah cuz
Ranatada goes that you speed make it
minus four. No, cuz the buff will hit
and the buff is just entering
with a buff.
>> H and then Fiora will trigger because
the unit became mighty. So even if he
doesn't become mighty anymore, it's
still ready.
>> Yes. Because what what's notable here is
Ranata resolves without a window of
priority passing because it's a unit.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh but the Rally the troops is if we can
pull it up, I believe it is a triggered
ability. Feel
like you uh either have to have the
invert here to gamble or
>> Yeah,
>> it's probably cooked.
>> Relivia seeming confident.
>> Yeah, Rivia's ready to combo at this
point with 10 cards in deck. I see two
time warps in hand.
>> Okay.
>> Um we have enough
>> if we time warp here, then we might lose
the game. Uh, but I don't think Rivia
even needs to time warp.
>> At this point, it's just sequenced
correctly for Rivia.
>> Yeah, I think we start the echo loop to
generate enough energy to play through a
hard bargain. Then we time warp later.
And that's that looks like what's going
to happen here. Yeah,
>> if Rivia is going to lose from this
position, I imagine it comes down to
miss sequencing something.
>> Shadow's call used first.
>> You have temporary
>> sacrifice will still uh
>> not be hard bargainable. So, not
sacrificing a response.
>> Sack him.
>> Now we're sacking him.
>> So, I'm going to float four.
>> Floating four.
>> And then on the untap, I'll float a
fifth and a power.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. So, notably
>> what this is going to end up tapped.
Sorry,
>> Rivia's doing this because they have no
runes to channel.
>> So, we're going to float a power
>> to channel that rune that we're
recycling instantly.
>> It's five in a power. Yes. Thank you.
>> Six cards.
and getting an extra energy as well cuz
you know Ekko will ready all the runes
you'll recycle a ready rune thus
floating an energy and a power
>> it's funny how you can do that in that
sequence but optimizing it
>> and now comes down to putting stuff back
>> sacrifice
>> forge is going to put back one sacrifice
>> yeah with the garbage grabber out there
uh you can be a bit more selective with
how you're sculpting your deck cuz you
do have another way already in play to
recycle three cards if you need to from
your trash and that's exactly how much
you want to recycle when you're doing
the combo cuz Ekko will be your fourth.
>> Now, we're imagining Rivia has the
Ranatada at this point, correct? In the
in the deck from the side.
>> I would assume. Thank you. Sorry, I I
didn't notice that you put it face down.
I just wanted to make sure that that was
clear.
>> You're okay. So, five more after the
sacrifice. I'm going to do the same
thing. One and a power. This is going to
end up tapped.
>> Okay. And now we are well out of hard
bargain range.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
I'm not Six cards. Echosac Echo is the
bottom.
>> Echosac Echo is in fact the bottom. That
is correct.
>> Shatter's Call and then Echo I believe
at the bottom of the deck right now
in the order of Echo at the bottom and
then Shadow Call right above it.
>> I do.
>> And we're just going to keep doing it.
Rivia's ready to pop off and pull off
the combo. Again, the only question is
do they have the Ranatada in the main
deck? because Ranata would be the way to
win this turn. Otherwise, it's going to
come down to that infinite combo and
then you have to kind of show that
you're able to pull it out multiple
times. But even three time warps would
be enough. You know, one second time or
first time warp.
>> Actually, I guess three time warps would
be enough, wouldn't it?
>> You go to three,
>> make a seal,
>> you time war, you go to five.
>> They got the one point earlier from the
Soran scout. If they hadn't gotten that
point from the soren scout earlier in
the game, then actually they wouldn't be
able to. Now, three time warps could get
you there.
>> Yeah. So, you would go to three, right?
Then you would time warp to five. Then
you would time warp to seven. Then you
time warp time to nine. Yeah. So it's
exact skis.
>> Interesting. Exact skis. It's a great
Canadian term.
>> Is that a Canadian term?
>> Well, I we say it in Minnesota and most
things we say in Minnesota, we all are
Canadian. That's correct. Yeah.
>> Forge.
>> Mhm.
>> No cards in deck. So got to be careful.
>> This is it.
>> If we missed now and we draw from an
empty deck, uh Allens gets its eighth
point and we recycle our entire traction
to our deck, which would make us lose
the game. that that forge recycling
looks like.
What are we doing here? We're looking at
what is in our trash.
>> Mhm. That's good.
>> Uh,
>> and then the echoes.
>> We have echoes and sacrifices in hand.
>> We'll just do this just in case.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Now, we're going to take a peek. This is
why I love Ash, right?
>> What was in his hand the whole time?
>> Two rides. Yeah, I think you just take
the hard bargain here. It doesn't
necessarily matter matter, but I think
this game is all locked up.
>> Pending sequencing. Yes.
>> I'm going to take your whole hand first.
>> So, he's going to infinite into the Ash
taking away
>> everything from hand.
>> That goes to 2 4 6 eight.
>> Yeah. So, it it won't it won't win, but
I'm going to I'm going to stack my deck.
>> Oh, no. He's at one. Yeah, he's at one
point. I I guess maybe they forgot that
he had conquered with the sword and
scout.
I still can win.
>> You can still win.
>> Invert fist. Uh, invert fist for invert.
>> Yeah, I'm saying. But I can put my whole
deck back in the
>> Oh, there for forges.
>> I can I can forge as many times as I
want.
>> That's true.
>> I can literally just do this after I set
up. I I put 8 trillion recruits on both
boards.
>> No hands. You have no hands.
>> Yeah, it's a bigger number than both of
us.
>> Are you doing it back to your hand?
>> Sorry.
>> Sure. What? Are you doing ruination on
your hash to put into some trash and put
them back into your deck again?
>> No, I would I have retreat. I retreat
lit. Okay. It's the same It's the same
ret.
>> I mean, it plays at the base then I
>> Well, I move them I move them all in on
my extra turns.
>> Oh, yeah. Fair. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, like
>> Yeah, that's good.
>> And he gets it.
>> Allan conceds saying they just talked it
out at the end there saying basically it
wouldn't be enough. And I will say Rivia
did have that one point from the game,
so theoretically would have just won
anyway. Yeah, cuz three ongoing time
warp 1 to 5, time warp 2 to 7, time warp
3 to 9. You'd have to do it with like
the sprite burst way to to get the
sprites in and then create recruits out
at the the battlefields. But, you know,
hey, still a win's a win. He's able to
take it. Allan says, "I do not have the
answers." And Gren, you're right. Lux is
able to maintain a win streak here.
Stays X and one at the end of round 11
and has an opportunity to push for top
eight. Yeah, I had to change uh change
outfits a little bit.
>> Yeah. What happened to you? You're
wearing a a judge shirt.
>> Yeah, I I listen, it was a very complex
matchup. It was I was getting into
rulings. I had to get back into my
element a little bit.
>> It felt right, you know, having a judge
next to me to talk through all that one.
That was definitely one for the history
books here at Hartford. Uh the Lux is a
complex deck to pull off, but I think
we're seeing why it's so scary and why
you really need to play fast to get into
it. Allan was playing fast. I mean, I'm
specifically thinking that first game uh
he put him on like better sequence
perfectly and get through probably like
15 cards, 18 cards, something in uh in
the deck and pull it off. Yeah.
>> What's crazy is I I've played this deck
a lot, right? I've played this Lux deck
a lot. Admittedly, a different list now.
I'm kind of bought into the triple time
warp cuz like I just really like it.
>> Uh but I would have lost that 20 in like
25 minutes.
>> [laughter]
>> Um, so Rivia just I would call that
almost as perfect as a game that you can
play if we look at the game one and
three, right? Game two, Allen's got to
do his thing. Thwarted the strategy of
the Lux, but especially in game one,
making Lemonade out of Lemons, I think,
is a perfect example because we were
back against the wall. Allen's on six
points, has a uh has enough units to
score, and has a full grip of cards in
his hand. You have to win this turn.
>> Yeah, you have to. And when the pressure
is on like that, being able to stay cool
and actually get the combo, pretty
impressive. Game two, we saw the
weakness of like, you know, if if
Allen's able to just go first and just
get in and, you know, shut you down
completely. You don't see the right
sequence of cards. Um, that's also what
can happen. But then it comes down to
game three. Aspirin's Climb buys you a
lot of time, it would seem.
>> Yeah. But and again, the Aspirin's
Climb, most decks that play Aspirin's
Climb want to use Aspirin's Climb when
they're going second, right? To just
[clears throat] make the game longer.
Obviously, Lux loves to use it when
they're going first because it's almost
a guaranteed win at that point. We saw
Lux was a little uh sorry, excuse me. Um
Diana was a little far off of even being
able to strike lethal range if Rivia
gave him another turn. Yeah. Um so,
>> I don't know. I'm happy. I'm a huge
Allen ZQ fan. We're good friends, but
>> my my girl Lux, she pulled it off.
>> Tough that Allen ZQ is now going to be
waiting on a potential bubble if he's
looking for a top eight, but you don't
even know if an X2 is going to be able
to make it in. But with that being said,
we are standing by with the man himself
who made 10 trillion recruit tokens.
That's a lot
>> to close out that game. Let's hear from
him.
>> Incredible round 11 action here with
challenger TCG Rivia taking down a titan
of the game. And on a deck that a lot of
people are talking about, Lux, how does
it feel to take down Allen's EQ and move
closer to potentially a top eight?
>> Uh, it feels pretty great. Uh I've
played Allan once before. We played in
the top 64 of Houston. Uh the very first
regional. Uh he did get the best of me
in a close game uh three game set. We
were playing Kaisamir. Um so it feels
good to get that a little bit of a
revenge. He's a great opponent, great
guy as a good friend. So um yeah, it
felt good.
>> I mean building those sort of rivalries
is a lot right now in the community cuz
you're very aware of it and your team is
very aware of it.
>> The people that put the hours in this
game are the ones that are continuously
having success. So speaking of success,
we got to talk about Lux. Yeah,
>> I heard through the grape vine that you
didn't even think
appearance and I'm just saying with, you
know, two more rounds for you to play
with only one loss, it's looking pretty
strong. What do you actually feel about
the Lux deck, especially if it were to
make a sort of top eight appearance?
>> Sure. Yeah. Um I did say that. Um I said
it was probably unlikely when I was
talking to Grenton. He said he picked
Lux to win the tournament. I told him I
don't even know if it's going to make
top eight and and I'm playing it. So,
um, but the reason why I say that is
because when your opponents, as you get
deeper into the tournament, your
opponents get better and better and more
difficult, and if they have reps on
against the Lux deck, your percentage
points go down a lot. Um, it does really
benefit the opponent who knows what
you're doing and they know what to
sabotage, what to defy. Um, but at the
same time, Lux also has very polarizing
matchups. So, I have a few match ups
that are very favored for me, although
Diana is a close one, um, as the the
match you saw. Um, but one more win uh
next round and I should be able to draw
into top eight. So, I'll guess I'll eat
my words.
>> You know, I I would also agree with you,
but I watched one of your teammates last
week also say the same thing. So, I'm
not going to I'm not going to make any
promises there, but you talked about a
close match and I actually specifically
want to talk about game one. Game one,
if you ever go back and watch it, even
the casters didn't think you could pull
it off. There was a ton of cards left in
your deck. when you when you picked up
your deck, you're like, I got to count
because, you know, and then, you know,
the first echo hits the table. We know
that the sacrifice, you know, uh with
the you know, the blood. Yes. It's going
to you're going to draw a bunch of cards
here. You have to get through that
entirety of the deck.
>> Yeah. I think I had like 18 cards when I
counted, which is like on the upper end
of what's possible to go in one turn,
and you kind of need a little bit of
luck to get there. So,
>> so then like what is your mindset when
it is in that situation? because I mean
we're very aware obviously game two was
very quick and then even game three was
like in me less tension building than
that game one because that game one is
so important
>> right
>> so what what are you feeling in that
moment before you even play a single
card there trying to get to that 18
cards if you're the lux player or you
are striving to be one at home
>> how do you even navigate that turn
>> yeah so first obviously I start my turn
I know I need to win that turn because
he's going to win so I count my deck I
see 18 cards I know it's going to be
really tough I need to um navigate a
very specific um order. Um, the order
typically involves you need to draw all
your echoes and sacrifices. They need to
not be stuck on the bottom. You need to
be able to forge in between. That's one
thing that I think is really important
is knowing when to forge one even one
sacrifice. I did a forge for one
sacrifice just to wedge that sacrifice
in between those echoes so that when you
get back down there, you don't get
stuck. Um, so that it's tough. I I've
bricked many times trying to go for an
18 card uh deck loop. Fortunately, it
came through that game and it's really
important to win game one. This deck is
very important to win game one because
you lead with Forbidden Monument and you
have Aspirin's Climb. So, what typically
if I can win game one, I just paper tree
when they're going first and I sack that
game. And if I win, great. But most of
the time, I just lose game two. I just
give it up cuz that way I guarantee
Aspirin's Climb going first on game
three, which is a very favorable game
because I get six turns almost
guaranteed depending on your opponent.
>> And that will uh that that tends to to
work out. I think most of my close
matches, a lot of my wins this weekend,
uh, are 2-1.
>> Yeah.
>> And makes a lot of sense.
>> And that's a great strategy. And so my
last question for you, because I know
you have a pretty important round coming
up here, um,
>> when you're playing this deck
necessarily, is there less players that
you want to go against in matchups like
you talked about earlier? Or would you
say the amount of time it takes to
master this deck is more important? And
if so, how many hours did you put in
before you brought it here? Uh, I
definitely think the mastery is the most
important because most of your matchups
you're solitarying. There'll be a few
interactions, defies or hard bargain,
stuff that they can do while you're
solitarying basically, but you need to
know every interaction, every loop. You
also need to know more importantly than
even the loop because anyone can
memorize a loop is how to get to the
bottom of those cards. Counting your
deck, knowing exactly what you need to
do to get to zero cards in your deck.
And that's kind of the easy part once
you get to zero cards in your deck is
just doing the loop. That's all
memorization. So the the thinking on the
fly is part of the getting to zero. Um I
would say that I have spent an ungodly
amount of hours doing this. Uh the just
a quick backstory is I was planning on
playing control lux. I wanted to play
control lux before this deck kind of got
popular and before people knew about it.
I was going to play control lux. I just
love lux. I wanted to go for the best
stuff for utre inton here. Uh, and then
5 days before my flights, this deck
became popular. Everyone's talking about
it. I immediately realized, well, if I
want to win this best of, I got to learn
this deck. So, I sat down at my kitchen
table and I solitireed for 12 hours and
then I got with my team and we jammed a
bunch of games and I practiced winning
through double defy. We would
intentionally give them defies and just
try to practice all the lines. Figure
out how to get to the bottom of your
deck. Takes a lot of time. I think
that's way more important than uh the
matchups. I think there are only really
two matchups that are horribly favored
and that's Rengar. It's almost
unwinable. Um that's just because Thrill
of the Hunt scores a point on your turn
at reaction speed.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh Lilia is pretty tricky. The sig
spell from Lilia. If they if they pull
that off and you don't ash first,
>> you're done.
>> It's great to hear that insight with
someone who potentially might be on
their way to a top cut appearance here.
So congratulations on a very tough
round. You have more tournament to play
of course and I'm looking forward to see
your journey. But we're going to go
ahead and send it back.
That was a fantastic interview with our
winner and we're of course going to
recap that important moment in game one
because I agree I think this entire
series was based around this action in
game one from Rivia because we're at a
moment where as he had pointed out there
are 18 cards left in the deck when he
does this counting and he is trying to
figure out can I get all of the cards
out of my deck because we know that this
Lux loop, this Limitless Lux requires
your deck to be empty in order for you
to get things to pop off. So, we're
going to go ahead and kick things off
here. Again, he's counting through the
cards in his deck at this moment. What
you're thinking in this moment, excuse
me, [clears throat] is that you're
likely going to need to not just draw
the deck, but continue to untap your
runes or un uh ready or
Hello everybody. [laughter]
the the Lux Loop has actually fried my
brain. That's what's happening. So,
here's the deal. You need to ready the
runes and you need to somehow draw cards
in between. So, you know that you need
the echoes. You know that you need the
sacrifices, right? And as he said in the
interview, you have to have them not
clumped up. You don't want them on the
bottom, but you also don't want to hit
too many all at once so that you can get
this combo going. So, if we let this
roll, we're going to watch this play out
once again, trying to get all the way to
the bottom of this deck because
otherwise the loop does not work.
And
I think we are starting at uh the wrong
location, but that's okay. We're just
going to talk through it as if it was in
the right location. We are looking for
[laughter]
uh the the moment. There we go. So, the
moment in game one where Alen is
knocking on the door, counting the cards
now is Rivia. We are on the right track.
And again, 18 cards. That's a lot to get
through. When you're looking at what the
deck is capable of, Lux can draw six
cards off of a uh Promising Future into
a progress day. So, that is one of the
things you want to keep an eye out for.
You can also draw five cards off of any
progress day. Uh the progress day
costing six means that you're going to
then save your other six runes for an
echo and a sacrifice. When you're trying
to pull that off, you are trying to get
to the point where you can loop. And
then, as we can see here, as they're
wrapping things up, we have all of the
things that are being explained to Alen
that are going to occur. This is the
loop that's occurring. And then after
that, you see cards shown like
ruination. You see cards shown like time
warp because Rivia was already at two.
Three time warps when you have units on
the battlefields means you go from two
to four, four to six, six to eight. So
all three time warps do result in a one
turn win uh from that point. So getting
to two early on was really important for
Rivia and uh again so much of this
series depends on game one. And the
reason for that, as outlined by Rivia in
the interview, is when you get to game
three, when you can go first and you
have aspirants climb, you guarantee that
you have a number of turns that you're
going to draw your deck before your
opponent can finish you off. Unless they
are a player that's playing Rengar, for
example, and you can use Thrill of the
Hunt to score on your opponent's turn
while maintaining holds at both
battlefields. You can't speed up the
clock. So, by going first, you get first
opportunity to play draw spells. By
making the opponent have to go a minimum
one more turn because of aspirin's
climb. You can buy all of that extra
time to burn through your deck because
again, the combo requires you to draw
all of your cards. Now, Lux is a very
efficient deck at doing this. This is
why, if you're wondering, the combo is
played in Lux and not in legends like
Ranatada because the passive ability of
Lux allows you to draw additional cards
off of Progress Day, draw additional
cards off of Promising Future, uh even
some of your other spells, you're
getting that incidental draw, but all of
that adds up when the goal is to empty
your deck and make it available for you
to combo off. You have to be able to go
through the entire thing. And that's
exactly what we saw happen with Rivia in
game one. Uh even if it took us a little
bit for me to get there, we got there,
gang. And with that, we're also going to
get back to the desk. So stick with us.
I'm throwing it back.
>> Expertly demonstrated there from
Charmer. The Lux combo. It fried all of
our brains a little bit. I think
>> I'm good. I'm fired up.
>> Yeah. You're ready to go. Actually,
you're the fan of the Lux.
>> I'm a Lux enjoyer. Even if self
admitted, you said you would have lost
if you were in that same.
>> Me specifically, I lose that. Rivia, I
will vicariously live through him.
>> Okay, cool. And uh you again uh riding
high now, you said that you thought Lux
could make it. I was not a Lux believer.
I said, "No way." And then we saw Allen
against the Lux deck and you were like,
"Okay, maybe it's not going to happen."
[laughter] I got isn't going to get
there.
>> I got nervous. But Lux being 10-1 right
now, one more win and like Rolia said,
can just ID, assuming they don't get
down paired into top eight. So this next
round very important for Olivia. Curious
to see if they can dodge. I'm assuming
they could probably dodge, you know, the
Rengars of the field and stuff like
that. There's not many left, if any, I
have to guess.
>> That was the interesting part was the
their explanation of what the decks uh
that they're, you know, not the best
matchups into. It was decks that uh
Lilia's um counter spell has the ability
to prevent your opponent from playing
spells for the rest of the turn.
completely shuts down the deck. And the
Rengar thrill of the hunt, being able to
have reaction speed score on their turn,
speeds up the clock. Not the decks I
expected. I was thinking things like the
Rexai, like the rushdown decks, like
those ones being the hard ones. Or when
they mentioned Lily, it's like, oh,
because of the sprites, but it's not
because of the score two every turn. We
saw scoring two every turn does not get
you the win necessarily against Lux. And
we can take a look, we actually uh had a
Rexai in round five that Rivia did
manage to beat. And again in round 10,
something must work, which I believe is,
if I'm not mistaken, are best of Rexi.
Could be wrong, so don't quote me on
that. But a lot of these matchups, I
mean, the two MF matchups are super
favored for Lux, right? Those are most
likely Aurora deck lists, and Lux
>> dominates that match up.
>> Chews that up. It's got to be an insane
win rate. Yeah.
>> Yeah. There's nothing you can do. But
again, I'm curious to see what our round
12 opponent for Rivia is going to be.
I'm going to obviously be keeping a
close tab on that one since that is my
prediction to win it all. And I think
Rivia is one of the few, if not the
last, Lux that is still live for top
eight.
>> And you said it yourself, if Lux gets
into the top eight, if you remove the
time clock, it becomes so much easier
for the Lux to pull it off. But we're
going to take a look at some of our best
of right now. Here's our best of Rexai
the Void Brewer. Yeah, four eight and
twos right there. So, shout out to
Something Must Work as Poke. Uh, Poke or
Pokey? What do you think? Poke. Poke.
I'm going to
>> I like Poke. I like Poke Poke. Big K or
Reno as well.
>> Big Crankco.
>> Big Cranko as well.
>> Yeah. So, four A and twos. Uh so
obviously uh don't guess if you're on
the desk.
>> Ask production to help. [laughter]
>> True. True. As as production is true.
Yeah. Don't don't do that. [laughter]
>> Uh [clears throat] but it's cool to see
uh some of the best of start to trickle
in over the day. I mean, yeah,
approaching round 12 now. Uh we only
have what uh a few more rounds, I
believe. Two more rounds left before top
eight here in the Swiss stage. So, we're
getting close.
>> Listen, I don't want to loop the
conversation back to Lux.
>> Okay.
>> But
>> I feel like we're stuck in stuck in the
loop right now. Yeah.
>> But you never saw it actually do the
thing yet. You saw me explain it a bunch
of times.
>> Yes.
>> So, what was your now opinion on that
deck after seeing that series?
>> Well, I think we need to get a top down
view and just demonstrate it for
everybody.
>> I think I think if we just did it one
more time.
>> I have my deck list. you have it on. I I
feel like chat would come and, you know,
burn this entire studio down. So, I
don't think we [laughter] should do
that. Maybe not. I feel like maybe let's
avoid that one. Uh, but I hear that we
have another list that we want to take a
look at here. Um, here is the card
presence list. So, this is going to be
uh what cards are most represented on
the floor here in Hartford. Uh, and
immediately I'm not surprising Scuttle
Crab is number one. Column is a really
strong domain and Scuttle Crab is just
the best two energy unit that Colm can
play.
>> Yeah, that was we were asked at the
beginning of the weekend, you know, what
our favorite cards of uh of Unleashed
were. Scuttle Crab was one of mine, so
I'm happy to see my little guy up there.
Obviously, Vex Apathetic to no one's
surprised. Every chaos deck that isn't
Aurora is running a Vex Apathetic in it.
Tide Turner as well, the Diana's of the
world, the Aurelius of the World. Love
that card. Thousand Tail Watch are
actually fourth currently as our um
>> as our most played unit. Uh the Leblons
do play it. I'm assuming it's also in
some of these Victor lists, maybe in
these Rumble lists. So, I'm actually
kind of impressed that that is above Vi
specifically.
>> Yeah, specifically cuz there's so many
order decks out there right now. Pretty
much every order deck is is on two VI
peacekeepers in the main deck as it
trickles down more. Uh one other
surprising one for me is Knox's Hopeful.
This is an origin staple that has just
kind of stuck with us through Unleashed.
I remember back in Spirit Forge not
being super impressed, but that's cuz
I'm biased. I'm a Jinx player. It's
decent to Jinx, but you don't always
want it in the deck. Um cuz it doesn't
really do much on its own. But like
we've seen in Annie's in the old Draven
list really any fury list um that has
like any two energy to play or like a
spell to play especially the chaos build
with like a stack that can knock like it
still has staying power in the format
and enough to be top 10 most represented
cards.
>> Yeah, it's obviously awesome. The
Thousand Tale Watcher like I mentioned
72 I believe is what we were just told
Blonde decks are playing Thousand Tale
Watcher.
>> 72. Wow, it's a lot. Plus, uh, not to
mention things like, you know, Ari decks
and, uh, such. Uh, production just tried
to tell me something, but I was talking,
so I did not hear it because I listened
to my own. 1,200 scuttle crabs.
>> Wow.
>> What?
>> Almost as many scuttle crabs as players
in the tournament.
>> And now I'm going to assume that's a lot
of three of,
>> of course. Yeah. I feel like if you're
running the scuttle crab, you're running
three.
>> You're running the play set. But that is
a lot of crabs. We are having a crab
rave over here. That's units. Let's take
a look at spells here. um as it I
believe that's what do you remember what
skeletal crab was offh hand what
percentage representation I believe it
was below defy here 20ome I think
interesting so defy significantly higher
I suppose decks like vex decks like Ari
that maybe don't get as much value out
of the skele crab will still be running
the defies um and it so this is a fun
fact that I had I actually uh had a
little free time the other day and I
looked up every spell in the game defy
actually counters 79% of spells in the
game right Now, very high percentage.
Now, the ones it does not stop typically
tend to be pretty good spells.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> But it can stop a lot of ones in the
field.
>> Yeah. And uh you know, the voices in our
head just told us 2,000 copies of Defy
>> have seen play this weekend. So, a very
very popular card. I'm not going to do
math on stream because that is never a
good thing to do if you're cast.
>> I like it. I think it's
>> 38% to 39%. How much less than 2,000 do
you think that is in terms of
disciplines? Oh, disciplines. Well, I'm
imagining you're still on play sets, but
that's crazy that because defy I don't
see that as like a three of in every
list. Sometimes it's only a two of,
whereas discipline I imagine would be
more towards that three of. That's
actually interesting. Very surprising.
Um I don't know.
>> I did the math.
>> You You did the math.
>> It was in production telling me, but I
did the math. 1,800 disciplines.
>> Oo, that's a lot of disciplines. Also
notably, three Origins cards in the top
three most used spells. Man, Origins
continues to be a very strong set. Even
Charm as number four there, another
Origins card. But Starcross creeping in
to the top five there. Uh was that your
other uh card from Unleash?
>> That was my preview card.
>> That was your pre Oh, that was your
preview card, right? Yeah,
>> Starcross. Yeah,
>> really
>> near and dear to my heart.
>> Yeah, I think it's one of the ones that
a lot of people uh build their deck
specifically to account for. Diana is so
popular. Even Ezreal's still out there.
Just chaos as a uh domain is really
really strong. So, uh, having an answer
to the starcross or a plan for the star
cross, I think it's on everyone's
radars, but it's still a very
represented card.
>> Absolutely. And you were talking about
your Jinx deck earlier.
>> Mhm.
>> We played a little game backstage.
>> Are you going to bring it up? You going
to
>> We're going to bring it up.
>> You going to call me out on this?
>> Yeah. So, for those of you uh who were
watching yesterday, Kangas was talking
some big game that he was going to beat
me uh in
>> and I am
>> in a in a match. And uh unfortunately
for Kangas, uh no, no, no. He lost uh to
my Leblon deck. LeBlanc without a C.
>> Game one. Yeah.
>> And then game two, I was in a good
position. I had to go work.
>> I had to go do an interview. Barrett
steps in. He beats you.
>> Yeah. So,
>> that's my deck. That counts. I set him
up. I I gave him the tools. Well, we got
a game three ahead of us. We got
>> You're 0 and one into Grenton right now.
>> 0 and one, but I'll win the series after
this once we get back there. Uh but I
hear that we're ready to uh move on with
the show to take a look at another match
here. Um, I believe it was uh the the
backup feature match if I heard that
correctly.
>> Vote for round. Actually, we're ready
for the next round. There we go. We're
not wasting any more time. We got Factor
versus CTCG Awesome Rosom and then Dr.
Snuffles versus Cactus X King. Hop in
chat, vote A or B to let us know which
one you want to watch. So, Pike Awesome
Rossom on a Pike control list, notably
uh Dr. Snuffles most likely on that
Aurora list, but Cactus King are maybe
tied for best dressed player.
>> Yes. Yeah. Full suit. We already saw him
on a backup match. Uh and he's notable
for beating Dewali in his the second
round of the event. Dewali had the buy
immediately loses into an Azir uh and is
still doing uh decent. But I actually
caught Cactus King earlier um at the
venue. And uh yeah, he was in good
spirits. He was like, "Yeah, I'm feeling
good. I'm feeling ready. Like I feel
like I'm I'm prepared for this event.
It's awesome to see he's still making a
very deep run on Azir that just took
Utre last week.
>> Yeah, and it looks like Do uh excuse me,
Factor and Awesome Rossome, we're going
to be watching a Pike versus Master Yi.
I don't think we've seen a ton of Master
Yi on stream this weekend.
>> I don't I have not casted one this
weekend. Um, and I don't know if the uh
the other caster pair has yet, but the
uh the Pike has also been a pretty much
fan favorite. A lot of people get uh
tilted when they watch it because they
go back to their locals and losing their
entire hand and not being able to play
the game. But then you see the top
players, especially now going here into
round 12. Like these are really, really
strong players and how they're going to
adapt to it. very curious what this
matchup is going to look like because
Master E is the type of deck that
oftentimes will have just like one unit
out and then a bunch of cards in hand
and Pike kind of likes that because
they're like, "Okay, I'm just going to
keep looping and then uh get rid of your
entire hand."
>> Yeah. And we've seen the list do a lot
of work too in the
>> the list. You just made the list
>> in Pike's list.
>> In Pike's list.
>> Uh and technically that turns off Ye's
passive if
>> you think about right. It kind of
negates it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So it kind of gives uh makes Ye a
fair combat deck. So, we're going to
jump into the deck list here so we can
take a look at what these players are
actually running and factor.
>> This looks like a pretty, you know,
standard
>> wow
>> uh standard list, the one of primal
strength, which was popularized by
houses are big uh when he had his good
run uh with the deck as well. Uh and
obviously a ton of combat tricks.
>> Triple punch first. Interesting to see.
And then also still on Fiora. I want to
talk about Fiora for a bit here because
this was something that was all over the
place in Spirit Forged format and then I
wasn't sure if it would have the stayain
power into unleash. I thought things
like Rengar would kind of take its spot
because if you're going to be playing
this on the three ramp then you won't be
able to play the Rengar next up. Um
Fiora is still a house of a card though.
When you combo this with things like
charm, you're able to pull enemy units
into you. Um uh if we could highlight
the Fiora, I just want to highlight that
one for a moment here in case anybody
hasn't seen it in a while. when it uh
attacks one-on-one or battles one-on-one
attacking or defending uh you double its
might. This will combo with the Master
Yi Wu Bladesman. So that will give you
plus two might. Then you go to 10 might
uh when you're defending. Um so if
you're charming something in then you
can even like challenge with the 10
might into something else that's you
know at a different location gets kind
of out of hand. What's scary with this
as well uh is that when Fiora checks for
her trigger it just happens when she
attacks her defend. Mhm.
>> Whatever happens after that doesn't
matter.
>> So there's cards like Rengar Trophy
Hunter that have ambush.
>> Oh yes.
>> Yeah. So you see you're picking up what
I'm putting down a little bit, right?
You can do a pretty much stepping in.
>> Yeah. You can let the yeasa put her up
to five, right? Double her might to 10.
>> Then we'll play the Rengar, which will
reduce her might a little bit, but now
we've added Rengar's might to the mix.
So it's kind of difficult to figure out
the math when you're playing against a
Master Yi. And we're going to take a
look at its run so far. only dropping
one game to Sam D. Sherman himself
>> on the Rengar, but three Master Y mirror
matches in a row to get to this point.
Really running the gauntlet of people in
contention for best of Ye. That that's
got to feel pretty good if you're able
to make it to best of Ye and you're
like, "Yeah, I took out a bunch of the
other on the way. I did that. I earned
that. I
>> Yeah, I I stepped on the Ye to get to
where I climbed the ladder of
>> E. [laughter]
A nice break from the mirror mash, but
again into a Pike who has been very much
focused on this deck for a long time.
Awesome. Rossom.
>> Mhm.
>> And we can take a look at their run as
well. Only losing to a Ye, but beating
another one later on in the Swiss
bracket. So, currently 50/50.
>> Wow. Really varied spread of what
they've matched up against here. Two Ye,
two Ezreals.
>> Three Ezreals. Yeah.
>> Uh, well, one of these. Oh, yes. Three
Ezreals. Ah, interesting. But still a
lot of uh diverse matchups here. I think
that's a mark of a really really uh
prepared player when they're able to
take down this many different legends on
their way.
>> All right. Well, let's take a look at
Awesome Arasum's deck list themselves
cuz Pike uh we see that often do the
very similar things depending on the
player, but pack of wonders is one of
the best tools for it plus the list.
This is kind of the combo that Ezreals
have even started running, but Pikes
have been doing it for a while. Um
because of course you're able to bounce
things back. The list you're happy to
just use as a minus two and you can loop
it with a pack of wonders. Pack of
wonders can also loop all of your other
nice uh units like the bewitching spirit
and the fizz and your pike doside
butcher as well. Your chosen champion,
right? You can bring it back to your
hand, pay the additional cost and
accelerate him in. But how about we
accelerate into the game itself
>> and jump into round number 12. Both
these players are 10 and one. So if they
win this again, barring them getting
down paired, they can kind of uh
intentionally draw into that top eight
if they so choose, if they want to just
guarantee themselves one. But this is
going to be a grueling best of three. Uh
and we [music] have the aspir's climb
from Awesome Ros to start it off and not
opening Emperor's Das on the side of E.
So, I've noticed uh as we're hopping in
to game one of our round 12 of Swiss
that Awesome Roses also only had two two
uh energy units or sorry, one two energy
unit with uh three copies and that's the
traveling merchant. So, this is seeming
to be more of like a slow scaling pike
deck. There's the stack deck. This can
get you into things like Nox's Hopeful,
which he was on uh or that traveling
merchant. So, now it opens up options.
But the aspirants climb going first. So,
I wonder if you just opt to go second,
even if you win the die roll, if you
just say, "I'm just going to go second
and have the three ramp." Uh, cuz I saw
more three drops than two drops.
>> I'm curious.
>> Oh, yeah. Let's
>> um I might have already messed it up.
>> Oh, yeah. So, we lifted up the deck, but
there's still one card beneath it. And
then let's as always, what I tell
players, when you make an oopsie, let
the judge fix it.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Don't try and fix it yourself. Let them
do it. Not the uh best start for a fast
play, but still it gets you onto the
board here. Pack of wonders has now hit
the field for awesome rosom. You can
exhaust it to return another friendly
gear unit or hidden card to its owner's
hand. And uh now factor just going to
establish the master temper. Did not
have a turn one play, but now the will
uh have a little field presence.
>> Yeah, we have to be a little careful
here. Uh he does draw a void seeker,
which is a great answer to
>> Y. However, I think debating if we want
to just take another turn off to set up
that void because it's expensive and it
looks like that's not going to be it.
We're going to fizz stack deck again,
which I like. We need to kind of get
that card economy. It's an aspirin game.
>> There's no one no one on the board yet.
It's going to last a little bit longer
than um most players are used to.
>> Interesting decision here. So, going for
the starcross, there was a Noxis hopeful
as well. So, if you wanted to get just
more uh development, you can go Noxis
hopeful. But going for the uh starcross
means that you can now loop this phase.
And also there just wasn't an oxal in
hand anyway.
>> Yeah,
>> but the starcross can help you with the
fizz. It's a classic combo. You bounce a
fizz back and something on your
opponent's field and then later you play
the fizz to do it again. So a natural
combo there for those two cards.
>> Master E temper now going to choose
which battlefield to go into. Going to
go into aspirin's climb. No surprise.
Seed of power not going to get you much
conquering that one first.
>> Do you want to give me a tracker for
that so stream can see it?
>> Yeah. So triggering the hunt now for the
XP. notably runer in the hand currently
for uh for factor. It's a very very good
card into purple decks because you
cannot choose it and notably even if you
name it with the list, you can actually
use the list's ability to choose it uh
because it chooses, right? So, it's it's
a very resilient unit in this match up
and I think there's actually two of them
in the hand for factor. So, we're just
probably going to develop the first one
here
>> of course
>> would make a lot of sense and there we
go. So, factor dropping it out. I will
say awesome. Awesome. It did have things
like cleave in the deck. So, there are
options to still punch through the
camel, but um the traditional outs that
chaos has access to with like starcross
not going to be uh available.
>> Yeah, we do see a card getting hidden
there for factor. I think the only one
in his list is zonas.
>> So, pretty again standard for for master
Y. So, we have to kind of play around
that zonas as well. We want to kind of
keep that Y alive as as much as
possible. But we want Awesome Rosesome
to use as much resources to get rid of
it so that our rune runner is even more
safe.
>> Yeah,
Factor has opted to just completely
exhaust all of the runes two turns in a
row here. So, Awesome Awesome's going to
have another turn now with really no
response other than that one hidden
card. Let's see what he decides to do
with this bit of tempo play.
Theoretically, we'll go to two points
here if you can clear that Y. And we
know that there is the Starcross in
hand. So that should be enough if he
wants to force the guarantee.
The list coming down.
>> I'll name Ionia.
>> Yep.
>> Naming Ionia.
>> Okay. That notably Master Yeet Tempered
has the Ionia tag.
>> So minus two now on the Master Yi chosen
champion, the tempered.
Five energy still up. Let's see how
Awesome Rosome wants to approach this
one. Pack of wonders can bounce the list
back and that is the move right now.
That would put the master E down to zero
might and then plus two from the Wu
bladesman legend. So it' be a two
defending the Fizz or the Nox is hopeful
could get over it.
>> Yep. And this way you make sure you
retain both your units which is very
important especially if we're trying to
conquer twice. Uh there is the ZAS.
We're going to save this Y perhaps.
>> Uh, yep. Good one.
>> And there it is. So, ye will get saved.
So, very good heads up play by factor to
hide that zonas there before passing the
turn.
>> Yeah.
>> And it does keep the minus four notably
because uh it's not damage.
>> Yep.
>> So, zonas does heal the unit, but this
is just a might modification that is uh
put onto the unit until the end of the
turn.
>> Good. Now the pike legend ability from
Blood Harbor Ripper will return back the
fizz to hand
>> creating a gold gear token. So now that
Fizz is available to play later on, but
awesome awesome not actually going to
send the Nox's hopeful out to conquer a
point and I believe should be at one
point right now. But there's a void
seeker
>> into
maybe
>> could be a discipline, could be a few
things.
>> Could be an on guard, could be a lot of
things. Yep. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Could be half the cards in use
deck. Let me tell you, as somebody who
plays a lot of fury decks, oh, calm is a
rough matchup.
>> It is defy.
>> Yeah, this denies the draw as well. You
could do something like a discipline and
get the uh stats pumped up so that it
doesn't die, but then your opponent
still draws. And if you're just trying
to deny them the card advantage, uh defy
feels pretty good.
>> And especially in a full control list,
the more cards you give them, you it's
going to be very rough to try to get
back into this game. Now, we're in a
really good spot here for E. We've
established one unit on two
battlefields, which is your best case
scenario. So you have E passive online
when a combat showdown does start. We
have uh six runes available currently in
and uh for our master Y player. So we
can we could take a turn to develop or
we could do the Y classic conquer
conquer. I'm all I'm already pass.
>> Yeah. You can just pass from this
position. You're absolutely right. I see
two on guardsuards in hand. A lonely
porro in hand. So even just the lonely
porro back to the base would be the
worst. Runner first mate punch first
double on guard. Sabotage double on
guard.
>> Sabotage.
>> And we're going to go for the sabotage.
list, starcross, fizz, and void seeker.
Number two,
>> I will take
>> I feel like even the void seeker might
be the most valuable right now. Although
the list already has Ionia,
>> the list in play has Ionia. So
>> then you play another one. You can also
pack a wonders at back and just do it
twice. So
>> I'll take Voyeker.
>> Yep. Okay. Void Seeker does just cleanly
answer the E and also gets you another
draw. So that's why I was immediately
thinking that one made sense. Starcross
doesn't really threaten the camel at
all. And you have another one in hand.
So
yeah,
>> I love call it the camel, by the way.
>> Yeah,
>> my uh my locals call it not ruin runner,
but they call it fun ruiner.
>> Fun. [laughter]
>> They probably play a lot of fury decks,
don't they?
>> They sure do. A lot of chaos and a lot
of fury.
>> Fury and chaos. Yeah. Ruin Runner though
is one of the stronger uh you know
mid-range cards coming out of Spirit
Forge. Of course, not being able to be
targeted by effects that your opponent
has. Cannot be chosen by enemy spells
and abilities
>> and gear do uh do be abilities.
>> Yeah. So, debating where we're going to
play this first mate. If we're going to
play this first mate and maybe bring
someone home, maybe the master y
>> ready in the master
doesn't have to move it home. still
leave it there and just have the first m
be a unit. Although at that point, I
think you'd play the first mate out to
the battlefield and then move the
message back. But this is the call
factor is going to have two units back
in base with one ruin runner at the seat
of power.
>> And yeah, completely negating the effect
of the list, right? The only thing on a
battlefield right now that we can
interact with much is that Ruin Runner.
We know there's a punch first and we
know there's an ong guard. We have two
runes up. We have a potential seven
might swing on top of the baster
passive. So he can potentially go up to
14 might on that role hunter which is
massive and we didn't really see a way
to deal with that in the hand for
awesome rosesome. I think he did draw a
falling star. So could potentially deal
with that backline. Use the list to
bring E down to two falling star and hit
both of them.
>> See what happens with the on guard. Pack
the list back. Name the other thing and
bring it back down.
>> Trying to think of what awesome
Awesome's outs are to just a 14 might
ruin Runner. I mean I [sighs]
they have three cleaves. I guess let's
just get a bunch of cleaves and just
punch really hard or actually bewitching
spirits. If we can get to the bewitching
spirits, then awesome Awesome can start
looping those and get rid of all of
those on guards and all those punch
first in the hand.
>> Oo, I think this is
>> I think this is Yeah, I think that is an
error if we do that because we can just
pack that list back, play it down, name
Buildwater,
>> and then because there's damage marked
on that uh first mate, we just use it
and we kill it anyways. So, good heads
up play here by Factor realizing that we
could just list again and just saying
I'm not going to use this on guard. He
did unfortunately give that information
to Awesome Awesome that he has one in
hand, but I mean at this point if you're
playing against a you just always assume
they have it anyway.
>> Yeah,
>> fantastic uh spell for Awesome Awesome
to draw there. Clearing out Factor's
next turn cuz you'll hold for a point,
but Factor doesn't have much in hand
that's going to get things rolling here.
>> There's another rune runner. Two on
guards. punch first.
>> And I thought I'd seen a lonely porro in
there, but now I'm not entirely sure.
Okay.
>> So, we're going to bounce the uh Noxis
Hopeful. Replay it for two. Doing what
Pike does.
>> Yep.
>> Never staying on a battlefield.
>> Not using the uh legend ability for the
bounce though, so you don't spend the
energy cost. Starcross is now live.
You have a scuttle crab.
>> Oh, that's a pretty good draw. You could
just play the other Ruin Runner, though.
You know, Starross isn't live,
>> huh?
>> Starcross isn't live cuz we have a Ruin
Runner.
>> Well, if if factor were to play
something else,
>> Correct. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> We do need two legal targets to put that
card on the chain. One of ours and one
of yours.
>> Yeah.
>> I remember when it was first uh revealed
and people were like, "Do you have to
target one of yours? Can you just bounce
one of your opponents?
>> For those of you at home, I didn't push
up my glasses this time.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Your uh hypothetical glasses,
>> correct?
>> Yes.
>> Um actually,
>> yeah,
>> we're going to bring the Ruin Runner
home. Develop another Ruin Runner. Yep.
I like this. We're on even points. Uh
it's an aspir game, so we need an extra
turn to win now because we're not on odd
points. So, I don't hate kind of
bringing it back and forcing a
development turn obviously from Awesome
Roses and getting more information of
what they're trying to do.
>> Yeah.
It's just giving two opportunities to
conquer and then return back to hand.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's also giving awesome rosin the
ability to catch up in points a little
bit here. But we'll see if it works out
for factor as uh treasure trove will
come down. Pack of wonders to return it
back to hand which will draw a card and
channel rune exhausted. It's a little
ramp for awesome rosom. There's a
scrier's bloom as well. Falling star
think in hand which is pretty dead right
now with two rune runners out. Uh but
there's a couple options you can do
here, right? can uh bring the Noxis
Hopeful in kind of use it as a
sacrificial lamb if you really want to
go to three uh and then play your pike
from your champion zone to go to four
but again you're on an aspirin's game so
staying on even points three or four is
the same
>> right so uh I think just a hopeful would
probably be a little bit better here
unless we're just trying to develop more
of a backline
>> there's the Fizz coming out see what it
copies stack deck awesome awesome is
digging and I'm noticing this deck with
the pack of wonders treasure trove
scrier's bloom kind of engine here.
Almost seems more like how the
Auroralists build things. Obviously,
you're fury with Pike, but uh it's going
to be going a little wider. You know,
you're just drawing a bunch of stuff,
getting a bunch of runes ramped, and
then you go really wide. Not going to
score to a third point here. So,
Awesome. Awesome accepting this game is
going to go on a little longer.
>> Yeah. Interesting. Obviously, we played
the Fizz to look for more cards. So, if
we do bring that Nox is hopeful and we
do bring it back to hand with the Blood
Harper Ripper,
>> we can't replay it.
>> Yeah.
And also it would just immediately die
to one of the rune runners. So you're
just sacking it for a point at that
point. So I suppose Awesome Ros saying,
"No, let's save the resources. Let's go
real wide with this deck." Now scuttle
crab comes out for factor. That'll draw
a card. Um
>> when it dies, it would also get XP.
Almost getting to six. On our way.
Pair rookie is going to buff one of the
ruin runners, the one at the aspirin's
climb.
And now we're we're a big development
turn here for E. Obviously, we need two
more turns to win cuz we're on aspirins,
but this is like best case scenario if
you're Master E.
>> Yeah,
>> you have five runes up, double camel.
>> Yep.
>> And uh Awesome Rosom has not been able
to find the Bewitching Spirit. Like if
there were Bewitching Spirit loops
happening, I think this game's very
different. Awesome Rosom not seeing that
early in the game at all. Not even
Midame at all, despite digging so deep
into the deck. Let's see if the Scriers
Bloom can get one.
>> Make an XP.
We drew a spirit or we're looking at a
spirit.
>> Okay. I imagine that's the keep. Oh,
it's not the keep.
>> Not the spirit.
>> Interesting call. I wonder another stack
deck. What is Awesome Raw Awesome
digging for? He is digging so deep into
his deck and I'm wondering like what the
one thing he's looking for is.
>> I guess maybe it would just be the the
the cleaves.
>> Cleaves mind. Well, there's one on Mind
Slitter, but I don't really know that
that helps you a ton here. It gives you
that information.
>> Yeah, I that I imagined it was the
bewitching spirit. So, you can just
clear the hand and then, you know,
understand exactly what might the ruin
runners are going to be at when he's
trying to hit in.
>> Oh, he had one. Have one. Okay, cool.
>> I like this play.
>> Discards an ong guard from factor side.
And there's another bewitching spirit
from the pack of wonders. Returning it
back to the hand.
>> Another on guard's gone.
Again,
we have one more turn here if we're
awesome. We're awesome. Right. So, we're
not facing lethal just yet. I don't
believe Yi is uh I mean, we know there's
no Trinity Force in the list for Y and
it would be too late to put it anyways,
but we're just going to pass the turn
here and we're going to have to break
both battlefields next turn to win with
two camels that we cannot target.
>> That being said though, if you're able
to chain more Bewitching Spirits, get
rid of the hand and then attack him with
some cleaves could be possible. But like
you said, it's got to be both. That is
seven might and then eight might without
anything in hand, let alone the punch
first.
Factor seems to be in a really solid
position here. And awesome, but with
only two points, he's going to have to
claw his way back into this game.
Yeah, this is a big turn here for
Factor. The thing with these pike lists
is they're so
>> similar, but also different. There's,
you know, probably like five or 10 cards
that change throughout the every pike
list.
So factors needs to kind of figure out
>> how do I set up myself for success. The
charm is obviously a huge pickup here on
the draw to get rid of that bewitching
spirit. So we don't have to get rid of
the rest of our cards in our hand. So
going to send it to its death on that
aspirin climb.
>> Very very nice from factor. And now
because we saw that one was cycled from
the Scrier's Bloom, we know at least
one's at at the bottom or towards the
bottom of Awesome Awesome's deck, which
would assume uh there's one more left
somewhere else in the deck. He's going
to have to dig again for that now.
>> Or I guess you just hope and pray that
there's no punch first, no discipline,
no on guard, and you just start hitting.
>> But we know a little better. We know
factor at least has one of those in
hand.
You always got to assume they have it.
>> Yeah. Well, unless you're going to lose
regardless.
>> Regardless, you got to make them happen.
You got to hope, you know.
>> You just [laughter] got to make them
have it at that point.
>> Yeah. But I do agree. Oftentimes, my
decision-m starts with, okay, worst case
scenario, can I win through worst case
scenario? If yes, do that line. If not,
then you go down the list of like, okay,
what percentage chances are they gonna
have? Are they going to have three punch
first? Like, is that a statistical
probability? Probably not.
>> If they got it, they got it.
>> They got it. Yeah. You know, good for
them. But um I think awesome roses still
pretty far away from that thinking right
now as he's just thinking like how do I
stop myself from losing right now?
>> Okay, we saw a void seeker and I didn't
catch much else with that hand. Void
Seeker is not going to do anything.
>> Yeah, this is a really tough spot for
awesome roses.
>> Flo power and energy. Pick this up.
Yeah,
>> floating one so that we can still get
the rune channel on awesome rosom side.
>> This would be a magic trick if he
manages to break both of these. I'm
>> It truly would be. Okay, there is
another bewitching spirit in hand. So,
awesome. Ross is able to start
>> chunking the hand.
>> Reaction discipline.
>> Love that. It'll get you uh more might
and then you draw a card anyway and then
you can just discard that. The
discipline is worth much more.
>> Yes, we have a punch first and a
>> Is that a Rengar?
>> Rengar. It might be a Rengar, I think.
So,
>> really solid hand actually. Wow, that's
>> You got it. Yeah,
>> we're going to [laughter]
play the the stone off the top. I was
like, I'll push my back. He has no way
to kill my Y. And you like drew the
stone and I was like, oh, my ongo sucks.
[laughter]
Uh, love to hear the players having fun
up there on stage.
>> The list doing uh what the list does.
>> List do what it do. Now, Emperor's Deis
for game two for factor here. So, going
second, you presume. Um,
>> you uh you made a pretty fun uh social
post about this one and the uh
interactions and we've already seen some
of that on stream. You don't have to pay
the full cost. you can just basically
use it as a way to mini Pike ability and
just bounce your own unit back to hand
um for free,
>> but Pike can also do that and Pike
doesn't mind doing that himself. So,
you're kind of giving Awesome Rosesome
on the tempo play the ability to do it.
But we also noted that Awesome Rosom
doesn't have a lot of uh two energy
units and not going to have one to start
off this turn. Instead, it's going to be
a stack deck.
>> Yeah, I mean turn one, draw an extra
card. It's not, you know, the worst
thing to do when you're playing a
control deck, but
>> it's a very conscious decision to play
so little two drops.
>> So, I think you're it's like those
Leblon lists that are running hook that
run, you know,
>> six two drops instead of, you know, the
eight two drops or nine two drops and
they're very comfortable with Yeah, I
missed the two drop. It's okay.
>> Yeah, you're playing a long game with
this pike list, it would appear, trying
to get to more uh runes so that you can
actually start looping your bewitching
spirits or your fizzes. Lonely Porro for
Factor. The beautiful alt art there.
>> I love that art so much.
>> So good. All of them are so good. But I
love that we get to see this one on
stream a bunch cuz pretty much every Y
deck anybody in who's willing to ball
out for it at least we'll have.
>> Have you collected all six yet?
>> No, I don't have a single one. Do you
have any for me?
>> I have three for myself.
>> Very helpful.
>> I need three more.
>> Okay. All right. Scrier's Bloom used.
Awesome. Awesome. a three energy up
could play in a pinch just the uh pike
doside butcher that chosen legend or
chosen champion. Otherwise, you can
ideally like a bewitching spirit here
would feel really good. Yeah, I also
believe I see a is Oh, maybe not. I
thought I saw a void in hand. I was
maybe he's debating what to uh to do
here with the scriers's bloom.
>> Oh, yeah. He's still deciding which to
add. He's
>> thinking if he wants to put both on the
bottom, one on the top.
>> I heard him say gross. Was it gross or
close?
>> Oh, okay.
>> I'll get uh Thank you. Could be both.
>> Could be both.
>> All right. Puts them both at the bottom.
Draws one card off the top. And I did
Oh, I thought I saw a bewitching spirit
in there. I imagine this is going to be
a um uh void.
>> Oh, there's a void. Yeah. Okay. Yeah,
there was a bewitching spirit, too. So,
not going to play the bewitching spirit.
Saving the runes for the void seeker.
Deny points.
>> Ooh, this is really good.
>> Go to dice.
>> This gets it out of range with the
discipline. Yeah,
>> because of that buff. Thank you. Thank
you.
>> Three might and then discipline will add
two more might. That is now five. Voer
will not kill but will get the draw.
>> Yeah.
>> Thinking on conquer to one. Thinking on
trigger.
>> Yeah, you could choose to return this
back. I don't know.
>> Activate make a sand.
>> You're going to do it. Okay. I guess
when you have the energy up, you can
actually create the sand soldier though.
The fun thing is you can use the full
battlefield effect rather than the full
cost.
>> Well, he that that's what he likes,
right? Cuz that sand soldier is now four
on defense and it's a free unit, right?
And you can bring something back to your
hand, develop it back to your base. Uh
not obviously the fact of Emperor Dies
is that the payment happens during its
effect. So, it's not necessarily a cost
and uh unless you have runes floating in
your rune pool, you could just elect not
to do it. But if you don't do both, you
don't make the sand soldier. So, you got
to you can't have your kick and eat it
too. You got to pick a struggle.
>> That's why I imagine you just leave the
lonely poor out there with the buff on
it. It's a three might five defending
and even if it dies you draw the card
but it does mean that more resources in
factor's hand as the scriers bloom will
hit the field for awesome roses.
>> Yeah, very very slow start here for
Awesome Rosesome now. Maybe debating if
we're going to bring out that Spirit and
it looks like we might.
>> Um
this is obviously very vulnerable to a
charm play.
>> Yep.
>> U and are we going to discard this
lonely porro? Looks like something we're
deciding cuz we do have it looks like a
Sabo, Discipline, Rune Runner, and I
don't know.
>> Could be a Zonas. Yeah, that does look
>> kind of like a Zas to me. Yeah. Okay.
And there there we go. So, the only four
is a discard. [laughter]
>> We got value out of the four. Bounce
back to hand.
>> There it is.
>> He didn't die, so didn't get a draw, but
necessarily protected the rest of your
hand. So, you can kind of count it as a
draw
>> in a way. Yeah, it kind of accomplished
its same mission as the hold will come
through. Second point for Factor. Has
the pit rookie to score for a third at
the Frozen Fortress,
but also full runes up right now for
Factor. Has seven energy to play with.
Let's see what he decides to do.
Sabotage wouldn't be too bad here. Get a
look at your opponent's hand cuz you're
probably expecting that they want to
start looping this Bewitching Spirit. If
you can hit like a pack of wonders
first, then you deny that option. And
there's a pack of wonders.
>> Only legal options.
>> Only legal options. There is another
bewitching spear, but at least you've
denied the ability to like do them
multiple times in one turn.
>> That's a huge hit for factor here.
>> And now, if we do push that pit rookie
up, we know that there's not really
anything in hand that's going to be able
to uh get over that uh battlefield, even
though it's frozen fortress, right?
>> We'll be at one might uh excuse me, one
damage marked, two might, and then when
we enter combat, it'll be four might,
one damage marked. So, even with the two
from the bewitching spirit, only going
to deal three total. Uh, so we're pretty
insulated there and that keeps it uh
keeps awesome rosom from being able to
use the blood harbor ripper to bounce
that spirit back to hand if he can't get
onto a battlefield.
>> Three,
>> the factory is going to go for the third
point. It wasn't necessary. You could
have chosen to leave the pit rookie
back, but if you allow a open
battlefield for the bewitching spirit to
conquer, then suddenly the pike uh blood
harbor ripper can return it back to hand
and then those loops start coming
through. So I think factor it makes a
lot of sense. We want to hold these,
deny awesome rosin the points, but also
more importantly the ability to loop
these bewitching spirits. Yeah, we're
going to play our master tempered it
looks like to the base. Just get the
development going. We do have a a rune
runner in hand
>> and now awesome gets to cook a little
bit acknowledging the trigger.
>> Yep.
>> One damage marked on that pit rookie. So
only need to deal one to it somehow or
the list would get uh that kill there by
Yep. by putting it down
>> actually just uh on its own cuz you're
not in combat so it's not getting the
plus two might from the Wuju Bladesman
legend ability.
>> Uh I I thought it was stack deck. I
looked at I just looked at this.
>> Oh,
>> that's unfortunate.
>> So we have looked at extra cards.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Luckily, this is a
>> the bottom two. Bottom five. Bottom five
are known from this five. Yes. And then
you two bottom seven.
>> Yep. So, this is a really easy fix
because we didn't mix the uh extra card
that we looked at into the set of cards
we were supposed to look at.
>> If we did,
>> the fix would be different, but this
this is a really easy one. Awesome. Ross
is going to get a warning most likely
for obviously looking at extra cards.
We're going to randomize uh the that
extra card into the random portion of
the deck, and then we're going to
proceed with play. if you had mixed it
in, it's a little bit more wonky where
now we're revealing those three cards to
our opponent. They choose one to
randomize back in. So,
>> always call judge on yourself when you
make an oopsie. Obviously, awesome. Ross
got himself right away. Yeah. Um,
>> but also important to keep track of
that. And I do believe that the other
squires bloom put two back. But, you
know, at the end of the day,
>> one top, one bottom.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> The one he said gross or close was one
top.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Now, now I remember.
Yeah, cuz we were talking about what he
said. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Well, here we go. Back to state of
play for Awesome. Rossom.
>> Exhausting two runes to play treasure
trove. Three more runes, I would
imagine, for another spirit. Yeah.
>> And maybe we're killing our trove to
>> make you discard
>> draw.
So, what are we discarding? Za's
defy.
Obviously, not camel. That is not a card
we're discarding ever.
>> I feel like Zona's in my mind that's the
one that's going to get the least value
against this matchup. Defy is pretty
nice into stopping like the um the void
seekers or such. But no, it is going to
be the Defy.
>> Hold defy.
>> Yeah.
>> Holds to five points factor back on the
turn
>> each.
>> Yeah. So it still gets pinged every
every beginning step.
>> Yep. That pit rookie is never going to
be full fully healthy. It's always get a
little cold.
>> It is sitting in a frozen fortress. So
>> true. I think that's pretty topical
actually. But we can now kind of swap if
we want to um that pit rookie with the
master uter to make it a little bit more
difficult. Uh, but I think if I'm
factor, I probably want to lock down the
Emperor's Das more so than the Frozen
Fortress because if Awesome Ross does
conquer that Emperor's Dies with a
booing spirit, it's a free bounce.
>> Yeah,
>> but it looks like uh we're going to be
playing that Ruin Runner to the
Fortress.
>> So, yeah, I Yeah, I still would have
liked it away from the Frozen Fortress
cuz now it's going to take one damage
and obviously you can't target it with
things like the list, but still it just
makes it a little easier to punch into.
Yeah, we do have a zonas though and
that's I think what we're trying to do
is say, "Hey, you need to deal with
this. I'm at five. You're at zero.
>> So, you have to deal with this rune
runner at one point." Uh, and then when
you do, I'll just save it.
>> And then you have to deal with it again.
>> Yeah.
>> I think we just drew a death from below.
>> Okay. Pretty solitter.
Oh, no. Down. Well, this is a great card
here.
>> Yeah. I mean, that'll deal with it. It
also triggers the treasure trove, so
you're able to draw an extra card and
channel run exhausted. doesn't have the
ability to play additional cards. When
we've seen downwells in past uh lists,
you know, in formats past, you'd see
things like, oh, play a Rosa for free
afterwards. No, this is a more honest
downwell. It's just going to reset the
the state of the field.
>> It's a downwell,
>> but also treasure trove let you draw a
card in. So, like semifair. Yeah,
>> semif fair. But it does mean the factory
gets to redevelop first. So, he's still
ahead on tempo, not only just on points,
but now also on board presence.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and that rune runner is
probably going to be the first unit
we're going to see come down. Um, or at
least one of the units. Oh, we drew a
scull. Okay, so we we want to get some
more information before we commit to a
six rune play. Uh, but naturally that
rune runner will hit the board. And now
it is up to Austin Ross to figure out
again what to do.
>> Yep.
>> You know what's funnier than one
downwell?
>> Two down wells.
>> No way.
>> No, he only has one in the sideboard.
>> No. Okay. early uh to play that. He
could have actually waited a turn before
going for it, but wanted the
Beaywitching Spirits for this turn's
play here.
>> Playing double bewitching spirit that
will get two cards out of hand. First is
a pit rookie. Second, I imagine is this
lonely porro.
>> There's a charm in hand. There's a
zona's
>> master y tempered is in hand and looks
like a discipline. Maybe
>> I think it's a discipline. Deciding
between the charm and the porro. I guess
when there's two bewitching spirits in
hand, the charm isn't as valuable. Yep.
>> Oh wow.
>> Big development turn from Awesome
Rosesome.
>> That is a lot of might that just got put
into play. We're looking at 12 might on
the side of Awesome Rosesome with that
uh Docside Butcher in the champion zone
that can come in ready itself with that
trigger with the additional cost.
>> So that' be an additional four might
putting the total to 16.
>> We do have a back off it looks like. Is
that a backoff maybe? No, that's not a
back off. That's a charm currently
closest to us. Oh, it's a rake. Rake is
the top card.
>> Ah, yes.
>> Seven.
>> Yep.
>> I'll dice.
>> Take a sand soldier.
>> Yep.
>> We get to draw another card with the
scuttle crab now.
>> Yep.
>> Bouncing the crabs around.
Love this interaction for Master Y decks
in particular. It's one of the strongest
things that the deck can do and just
efficiency.
>> Yep. get multiple draws out the scuttle
crab and then uh now you're defending
with even more from that sand soldier.
And now we're debating if we charm here.
Obviously we can charm it into the
frozen fortress. Uh that is a seven
might to a four might noises hopeful
and that's exactly what's going to
happen. Ross is fully exhausted on his
side. So yep, nothing he can really do.
Nice efficient way to clear out one of
the threats cuz Awesome Rosom's only
move next turn is just punch punch punch
punch punch. You got to get through this
ruin runner. You can maybe deal with the
sand soldier with something like a
starcross, but the ruin runner is pretty
simple in this matchup. You got to use
your cleaves. You got to use your units.
Have you noticed a cleave in hand for
awesome rosesome yet?
>> I don't think he's seen a cleave in both
these games.
>> I haven't noticed one. Yeah.
>> All right.
>> The hidden zonas. And now we're going to
probably develop another camo. Okay.
Yeah, this is
>> this is rough for awesome rosesome.
There's not much you can do,
>> but it does communicate. It's not going
to be multiple punch first or punch
first with on guards. We got a stop from
the judges.
>> Yep.
>> Factor very perplexed as to why we're we
stop play.
>> Yep.
>> All set.
>> Good.
>> Okay, looks like they're good.
>> Happy to see that we're not going to
have a long delay there. Just a brief
judge call, but we're back into the
action. Awesome. Awesome on the play.
Full ramp runes. All 12 available.
Currently showing eight might on the
field. The Pike Blood Harbor Ripper or
rather dark side Butcher uh could come
in as an extra four might putting up to
12 total might threatening.
>> This is kind of where
>> three cards, right?
>> I like a Baron.
>> Yeah. Right. Like I'm like, "Oh, what
what would help here if I'm awesome or
awesome?" I'm like, you know, slam a
Baron. got our first point. Now we have
four might spirits and six might
hopefuls and we still have two runes to
do stuff with.
>> Yeah, you got to clear factor off of
both of these though because if factor
holds either then they they win.
>> I don't know if you'd be able to do
clear both with a Baron play
>> but conceptually I like the Baron into
these types of matchups for sure.
>> Looks like we're going to stack. Oh no,
we do have a cleave. We found the
cleave.
>> Nice. It's going to be very helpful.
Now, four might with three assault puts
it to seven when it attacks.
>> Plus three. Sure.
>> Yeah.
>> Doing it now before attacking. So that
way it's not defied and you're
>> kind of It's technically not plus three
yet. Enter a combat showdown. Then it uh
we'll get that passive effect from the
assault.
>> Uh so just keeping it close by so you
know we don't forget.
>> Again, Awesome. Ross has to clear both
battlefields.
one rune up on factor side can be so
annoying to actually add a factor in.
Again, you're thinking worst case
scenario. Worst case scenario is punch
first. You basically have to plan
playing around a punch first here.
>> Oo,
>> that's pretty slick.
>> I like the cleave. Not usually a target
for Fizz. So,
>> assault six now on that Nox is hopeful
and we're going to send it into the rune
runner. So, we're looking at 12 might
>> on the attack to the seven might on
defense. Notably one damage marked as
well.
>> Yep. And notably, if punch first was in
hand, this would all still trade anyway.
So the zonas will come up.
>> The rune runner will trade with just the
bewitching spirit cuz Nox's hopeful is
way too big.
>> That's good.
>> And then rune runner will go back to the
base.
>> This is kind of where I'm sure the
factory
>> uh zonas. So we put the rune runner in
the trash. Yeah, there we go. We got it.
We got it. Yep. Okay.
I'm curious like an acceptable losses or
something would have been really really
cheeky there. That would have been nice.
Uh not in the list obviously, but
something that oh there is sorry one
acceptable losses in the main deck for
awesome roses. So that would have been a
really good way to get around that zonas
>> when you get focus back. We're just
going to get rid of the sand soldier and
the crab.
>> Pretty clean removal option there. Now,
Awesome Ros's next game plan is uh, you
know, score obviously here
and then I'll get to see a hand,
>> but then also prevent Factor from
conquering both battlefields on factors
next turn. Yes, I'm trying to figure
out, excuse me, how you do this. Uh,
there is a world where you can
conquer with the sprite, bounce it with
the Das. Mhm. hold and try to rip some
cards out of your opponent's hand cuz
there's 10 might.
>> You can
>> and then you can play it back to the But
the thing is you're on the frozen
fortress which the more units you play
there
>> the worse it gets cuz they're each going
to get hit for one damage.
>> I mean you can return it and make the
sand soldier and then replay the spirit
to the deis but even then it's only four
might defend.
>> Oh yeah you you could conquer the deis
with the spirit pay pay for it. Make a
sand soldier. Play the spirit there.
Bounce the hopeful with pike. Play that
also there if you wanted to.
>> You would have enough energy for that.
Yeah.
>> And then it would be eight might
defending at the Emperor's Deis. Nothing
defending at Frozen Fortress. So Factor
would at least have one battlefield to
go into uncontested if that's the line
Osar wants to go down. Let's see what
they actually choose to do here. We're
in the conquer window.
So really tough spot here for Awesome.
Rossom.
>> Really tough matchup I imagine for Pike.
You don't have a lot of clean outs to
the Ruin Runner.
>> Ruin Runner is a fantastic card.
>> Seeing four Ruin Runners in two games.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Good luck.
>> Good luck indeed.
>> Looks like this time. Like the the
looped cleave is one of the best ways to
answer it. Um but the Zonas are just
coming in clutch for factor.
All right. So, the Emperor's Deas has
been triggered. Sand soldiers out. The
bewishing spirits back in hand. And I
think that you were right on the money.
>> One short. He's one short.
>> Oh, he is one short, isn't he? Yeah, cuz
you'd have to pay an energy cost to
trigger the Pike Legend.
>> This card
>> still going down this line.
>> You have the
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, I wonder what it was.
>> Yeah. Right.
So that is still representing the eight
might defending up there. But let's see
if factor can do it.
>> Yeah.
>> Go here.
>> Conquer draw.
>> And we have a defy for insulation which
we don't really need.
>> You're going to be at eight.
>> And discipline doesn't get over
actually.
>> Yeah, discipline would go to seven. You
could discipline early and draw a card.
Just see what you get.
>> And that's exactly what we're going to
do. Play to our routes. We found some.
Oh, we found a charm.
>> Charm. That's enough.
>> GG.
>> Yeah. Yeah. GG's.
>> Yeah, something back. Attack in. That's
enough might to take it back. GG's
>> wins the series 20 and advances to 11
and one. One more match ahead of him to
qualify for a top eight in Hartford.
>> So,
>> I think he broke his stream losing
streak.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I think he was saying he was been 05 on
stream. Oh, and he just won his
>> unless he gets down paired winning in
for top eight. So, congratulations to
Factor. Very well played against a very
proficient Pike player as well. Uh so,
super happy. I love when players show
emotion on on the stream.
>> Yeah, and I love it when you get to see
uh the natural matchups of certain decks
cuz that was a a topic that I've heard a
lot of players talking about. We talked
about it a little bit ourselves on the
broadcast is some matchups are really
rough percentage-wise and I imagine Pike
is so good against certain things. I I
would guess it's a low win rate versus
Master E specifically for all the
reasons we saw. Even if it wasn't Ruin
Runner, still going to be a little hard
to deal with these big might units. The
Starcross would put in a lot more work
if it wasn't specifically Ruen Runner.
So like that's kind of the bigger out
that they have. But because Ruin Runner
exists in the matchup, hard to take
down. Yeah. And the the issue with that
star cross is the units you want to
bounce. One, you can't, right? You can't
bounce the unit run. Another one is
Rengar. You want to kind of get it off
the battlefield. You're just putting it
back into the hand to do it again.
>> Or a scuttle crab or a rookie. It's
like, h, I've just given him another
activation.
>> Almost every unit in this deck, except
for the Fiora Peerless, is something
that you give the master more value when
you bounce it back to hand. So, I
really, really like this list. We didn't
really see the one of primal strength
kind of play any role in it or the
Fiora. Yeah, I'm happy you even
mentioned I forgot few our pier list was
in the list. We didn't see that at all.
I imagine I was probably sided out at a
certain point because like against Pike,
I don't think you really need it. Um but
uh yeah, maybe we can hear from that uh
from the player themselves cuz I'm
hearing that we have the interview ready
with Factor.
>> Round 12 is in the books and not only
has Factor taken the win here, but he is
the Ye factor as well. Congratulations
on an excellent win. How do you feel now
>> basically being locked in for top eight
almost?
>> I feel really good, you know. Um I know
that I mean Billionaire was 11 and
missed it, but I I hopefully I can just
get the ID next round and get in top
eight. I um I've played a couple events
now. This is my third time playing a
winning top eight and I lost the other
two on stream. So I'm really happy I was
finally able to get one. I have never
won a game on stream either. I the
stream curse has been broken for me. So
I'm really excited. That's a great curse
to break here. So, congratulations once
again and I kind of want to pick your
brain a little bit. Um, Pike, we had
Pike on earlier today already. It would
had a great performance. There's another
one running around here in the Top Cuts
potential area. What is your kind of
thought on that deck? Because it could
be like another sort of Annie stylistic
fury chaos deck to compete against
what's going on in the format. What are
your thoughts on it?
>> Um, I really love that deck. I actually
played that deck to Vancouver and went
eight and five. Um, battling for the
best of with Blossom and somebody else
in day two. Um, so I have a lot of
knowledge about the deck which I think
helped me a lot in the matchup. Um, I
think the deck is incredibly good. Um,
it's definitely the hardest deck I've
ever played in any TCG in my life and I
was like, uh, I'll just take Ye. I feel
really confident. I played Y in set one
to Houston way back when, so I felt
really confident with the deck.
>> That's awesome and great to hear. Now,
of course, we got to talk about the
allstar or I guess the all camel of the
match, Ruin Runner twice in both games
really helping to deal with what that
pike deck is using in that sort of
matchup. A lot of their removal is
targeting, of course. Can't do that with
the camel and then of course they want
to win combat, but with Master Yi to
help you out, it feels pretty good. So,
do you think that's been a winner for
you in the tournament as a whole? Do you
think Ruin Runner is maybe something
that more people should play more copies
of? Um, awkwardly enough, Rune Runner
has been very bad for me the entire rest
of the event. It has been the worst card
in my deck. I've hit a lot of like
yellow decks in the mirror. I haven't
hit any Diana, no decks that are doing
spells, no red decks. And so, it's been
really bad for me. And so, I'm happy it
showed up when I needed it. And my
thought process like going into
Morgans's everything was just like find
the rune runner. And like game two, I
had the run in an hourglassing hand. I
was like, this is exactly what I want. I
just need this thing not to die. Like,
yep. That's got to feel incredible. And
it's so incredible here now to be X and
one with only one round left to go in
the tournament. Factor, congratulations
once again. An incredible performance
with Master Yi and I hope to see a
Master Yi in Top Cuts. But we'll go
ahead and send it back.
>> Fantastic interview there. Master Yi and
Pike. Master Yi the most represented
deck coming into this tournament and
factor showing us why it is so good.
We're going to talk a little bit about
this match. Now, the first thing I want
to look at is actually on awesome
rosesome side. We've seen some pike list
this weekend and we've seen the list.
So, we're going to go ahead and play
this here. The list is something that we
have been seeing in these pike decks and
paired with pack of wonders. They're
able to give a unit minus two might and
then the pack of wonders bouncing it
back into hand. Then they replay it,
name the tag they want and give it
another minus two. So, we see the list.
It's going to give minus two to Master
Yi. we can then bring out this falling
star. It sets up the play to clear out
this backline. So, love to see the list
pack of wonders combo that we've been
seeing in these pike decks this weekend.
And again, paired with the falling star
is a great way for this to take out the
backline. But unfortunately, we're going
to go ahead and fast forward to our next
segment here and we are going to take a
look at the the Ruin Runner. The Ruin
Runner just absolutely crushing Awesome
Rossom and Pike here in this matchup
because Awesome Rossom is running a deck
list that doesn't have a lot of might.
We saw some earlier Pike in the day off
of Mirror and he was running a deck that
could get that higher might total. But
here, this is tough to get through the
Ruin Runner. We can go ahead and play
this through. Ruin Runner can't be
chosen by enemy spells and abilities.
So, catch me if you can says factor. And
we can see in the backline here for
Awesome Rosom, he's got a problem. We're
at eight points on an aspirin climb
game. If we hold one battlefield, it is
all over. And again, Awesome Rossom,
this is more of a controloriented pike
deck. And unfortunately, he just doesn't
have the might needed to break through
these Ruin Runners. The Ruin Runners are
so good with Master Yi because they get
that additional two might and you can't
target them. And unfortunately, we can
go ahead and run it through here and
it's just not going to do the trick. You
need the extra might to get over these
camels. And for this particular pike
list, it is just not enough. So, the
ruin runner is really the nail in the
coffin in game one. And that is going to
be the key to success for factor in the
match. Now, let's go ahead and skip to
the next segment here. And now, we're
going to take a look at this segment. We
can go ahead and roll it.
And now this is another situation where
factor has gotten very far ahead once
again. And we've got the ruin runner set
up yet again. We can see the point
total. Awesome. Rossom's behind. We need
a desperation play. And downwell is that
desperation play. He's able to clear the
board, but the problem is we can go
ahead and jump to the next segment.
Guess what? Factor has found two ruined
runners yet again, and they are going to
come back. bounce them back to the hand,
but now they're going to come back. And
we look here at this bottom battlefield
and Awesome Raw Awesome has to once
again break the Ruin Runners. Now, we're
going to go ahead and play this here.
And we're going to see that we've got a
hidden card. We've got a Ruin Runner set
in the back ready to come in on the next
turn and try and double conquer. And
that Zona's Hourglass after the the the
cleave here buffs the uh might up here
on the Nox's hopeful comes through. The
Zona's hourglass is going to save the
ruin runner. It's going to come back and
it's we're going to fast forward to the
next segment and that is going to set up
this double ruin runner once again. This
is just too much for Pike to overcome
with so many spells that are going to
try and remove via targeting. So now
let's go ahead and run this through. We
see the discipline going to buff up that
ruin runner and then as awesome rosom
has to hold here. The charm is going to
pull that unit down to the southern
battlefield where that ruin runner is
and there is the handshake. So
unfortunately in this more
controloriented build for Pike. He just
was unable to get through the ruin
runners and that was the key to success
for factor. So, Master Yi doing it and
we are going to see Master Yi in the top
cut here in Hartford. But we are going
to cut to a short break, but don't go
anywhere because we have got the final
round of Swiss coming up next.
What's up everybody? Kangas here with
three members of the team the secret
sauce. They made it to day two. We're
going to get to know them and the team a
little bit. Introduce yourself and what
champion you're playing.
>> Hey. Yeah, what's going on? I'm uh
Houses are big. I am playing Master Yi
at the creator of the best deck in the
format. And um that is uh me today. Not
doing too hot, but uh we're we're still
running. We're still running. Doing our
best.
>> Not the deck's fault. Maybe user error.
>> 50% win rate. Uh mirror match. It's
okay. Someone's got to lose. [laughter]
>> All right. How about over here?
>> Uh I'm Nightingale. I I've been playing
Vex for this whole set. Um
>> yeah, I I just been building my own
path, doing a very control oriented
deck. Yeah.
>> Um but it's like very slim margins. You
have no room for error. And [laughter]
and today and just this tournament I
haven't been on the
>> We've been We've been tired. We've been
tired.
>> We've been traveling like day two. It's
different than day one. Right.
>> And we've been going RQ to RQ. So it's
been
>> You guys been in a bunch of them, right?
Back to back to back.
>> Us three have been to Sydney, Vancouver.
Oh,
>> Atlanta. [laughter] Atlanta, Sydney,
Vancouver.
>> Atlanta, Sydney, and Vancouver. No back
to back to back. That's awesome to see.
All right. How about down here at the
other line? Um, playing Civer, not doing
too hot today. Uh, [laughter]
I mean, it's just the nature of the
game. You know, you go to so many
events, you're not going to do well at
some of them.
>> Uh, and when you're playing a game like
Riftbound, the meta is so wide. You play
into whatever. A lot of the game is kind
of matchup lottery. Um, and there is a
something to be said about how well you
play and, you know, making sure that you
win all of your winnable games. And I
think that we just didn't do that today.
So, it's something that we wanted to
prove down in the future. Yeah.
>> So, team the secret sauce didn't have
the secret sauce for this event.
>> Not today. We ran out. We ran out. We
used sauce. You got to go back to the
store.
>> We went to two playoffs. Two playoffs
and we go some more. Make some more.
Make some more.
>> Well, talk to me a little bit about the
team though and how it came to be and if
anybody wants to get involved.
>> It's a really a great story. So, a lot
of people are familiar with the
Riftbound community server. It was
started uh by like Willow and Gailwinds
and we kind of all met at the beginning
of the game playing with in that server
and we eventually was like hey we're all
like getting pretty good. We're all
going to the events. We're all testing
together and then eventually we're just
like let's just make this like an
official thing like we are the secret
sauce. Yeah. So shout out to Togg who uh
>> father
I think he has invited literally
everybody onto the server.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Friend of ours great player.
Um he uh he's like he's the one to uh
give credit to for any success that we
have. So
>> cool. Shout out to Todd Father. Shout
out the team secret sauce. What was the
TP?
>> TSS. TSS. There we go. The secret sauce.
>> The secret sauce. Shout out a proper
noun, by the way.
>> Do you guys have shirts? We're working.
You're working on it. It's in progress.
>> All right. We'll get uh jerseys for the
next one. Thanks so much, guys. That was
awesome. Best of luck the rest of your
weekend.
>> Thank you.
>> Do you want to try the hard?
>> Yeah, let's do it.
>> You want to try the hard? All right.
Perfect. You will have
>> there's a lot
>> as well 12 runes.
>> Okay, you can't give me 13.
>> Unfortunately, I can't break the
mechanics of the game. You will have
three dragon soul sages in play. So, you
have 15
>> energy. There you go. I gave you your
13.
>> But they're also units.
>> They're also units.
>> You will have in your hand
>> three Herald of scales.
>> Oh, is this one of those volar
>> three gentle grim dragons?
>> Oh, it is.
>> And one confront.
>> Okay. The card that you will draw off
confront is guaranteed to be an elder
dragon.
>> Okay, that's my deck.
>> Here's your Vol legend.
>> Okay, I might need that.
>> Here's the battlefields.
>> Okay,
>> and here is what your opponent has on
the battlefield.
>> That's a lot of drag.
>> So, you start at six points and your
goal is to win this turn.
>> Start. And this isn't active. This is
not
>> This is not active. Y that's important.
>> 11 players, if you hear your name, we do
not have your match.
>> 11 units on the battlefield.
>> Please report.
>> This doesn't need to get played
immediately because
>> this can kill every single unit on the
battlefield unless they they don't have
any abilities or anything. No,
>> no abilities.
>> So, it's just
optimizing everything.
>> Can I end up Okay, so the question is,
can I end up with 14 energy in order to
play both of these?
>> So, if I do all of these first, I'll
have three left.
>> This will cost two and give me back two.
So, you'll have three. This will cost
two and give me back four.
>> So, then I'll have five.
>> Yep.
>> This will give me backio
>> plus four.
>> So, then I'll only have five.
Aaron Miller. We have Sam Rosie.
>> I love this one cuz it's a bunch of
cards that nobody uses.
>> Wait, someone I think got best of with
this
>> with uh Gem Dragons. Yes. But the
Herald's not as much.
>> I thought they had the Herald, too. They
were some kind of infinite combo. Uh
>> a Rengar player was a Rengar doing.
Okay. Not even a super fun. Interesting.
>> You can play it in any uh red orange
combo.
two and get back two.
>> Oh, it's all a bait.
>> Is it?
>> Hold on. I [laughter] can just confront
this out
and then send it in and ping one and
then send the last S dragon. Oh, wait.
No, then I'm off by one. Hold on.
>> Not quite.
>> It's almost You can almost do that, but
not quite. If you had one more energy,
>> one more energy, one more unit.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, that ends up only spending.
>> So, for anybody at home who's maybe not
too familiar with these cards, the
heralds make all your dragons cost two
less and the gem dragons ready two runes
anytime you play itself or another
dragon. So, the sequencing of this
puzzle is you have to spend all your
energy, but the goal is to get a bunch
of it back
and then somehow clear the entire
battlefield.
>> Oh, wait. When I end up with nine, this
is reduced by six.
>> It is.
>> Did I have enough anyway? What are you?
>> You'd cost six.
So then, oh, nine was just enough. Okay.
So, I do play all of these.
>> Okay. So, so let's let's put these back
in your hand. So, what's the first moves
that you're making?
>> All right. I'm playing all three heralds
of scales.
>> All three Herald of scales.
And then this costs two.
>> Yep.
>> And ready is two runes.
>> Yes.
>> Am I going to end up off by a unit
again?
>> Ah, but I can afford to confront first.
I see. Okay. So then I'll pay another
two for another gem dragon. Okay.
>> This will ready four runes.
>> Yes.
>> Then I'll play the confront.
>> Yep.
>> Draw the elder dragon. Everything is
readied. Then I'll play the gem dragon.
Ready? Yep. Ready. Six runes. With the
six runes, I'll play the elder dragon.
It'll come into play. Shoot anything.
>> Sure.
>> And then this should be
>> There are 10 units, so that will crash.
Everything
>> and then I've got two units left.
>> GG's. Okay,
>> you got it. That was the sequence. Well
done.
>> Just had to realize this was cost
reduced.
>> And that's the real bait is that you
have to use one of these, right? You
know, you have three. You kind of want
to use them. You have to use one.
>> You have to keep one
>> to score. So, congratulations. You
solved my puzzles.
>> How hard were they? Honestly,
>> I This one tricked me a little bit.
>> Okay. A little.
>> A little bit.
>> Made it pause.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. I'll take that as a win.
>> I found the line and then second guessed
myself and then was like, "Wait a
second. What if I just do this?"
>> Yeah.
>> But it's not quite.
>> All right. Well, thank you for playing
for Met. That was awesome.
>> Best of luck in the rest of your uh
weekend. You going to win it.
>> I got you as my guy.
>> I've got to catch up to the Allen and
Squirtle. Like, this is ridiculous.
>> I know. It's crazy. You got to add
another Annie to the
>> Yeah, that's definitely a big part of
the plan. We'll see you about winning.
Winning's a lot harder.
>> Best of luck, dude.
>> Thank you.
>> Hello everybody and a big welcome coming
from the regional qualifier here in
Hartford, Connecticut. My name is
Charmer and I am here to talk to you
about something that is near and dear to
my heart, which is the overall metag
game for Riftbound as we head into this
event. The Hartford qualifier will of
course be the last one as far as the
unleashed meta goes and it is still wide
open which is pretty rare when you
factor in that we are so far into the
lifespan of this set. So with that in
mind let's take a quick look at how Utre
the most recent regional qualifier
finished. It finished with eight
different legends in the top eight. Yes,
that's right. Eight different legends.
We've got an Azir, an Annie, a Master
Yi, a Set, a Rexi, a Victor, a Darius,
and a Diana. So, eight unique legends.
And that is phenomenal this late into a
set because very often in card games, we
find scenarios where people kind of lock
in on whatever the best deck in a format
is. And surprisingly, for many, it is
Master Yi coming into this event. This
is a list that despite not winning in
Utrect was phenomenal during the Swiss
rounds. It had winning matchups against
uh most of the majorly played decks uh
with a poor matchup into Auroraists. And
I will be talking about the dazzling
Auroraists in just a moment because uh
you may notice they're not here as well.
But the big question is going to be
whether or not Master Yi can convert
after getting to the top eight and
whether or not the success that was seen
at the last event translates into more
market share as far as the decks brought
that deck representation here in
Hartford. Uh another thing to consider
is the rise of order. So order as a
domain, this yellow color you're seeing
here on your screen is something that
had not been as popular in the past.
However, it had a fantastic showing in
Utrect with several legends bringing it.
And that's because of the power of cards
like Call of the Week as well as being
able to generate early pressure into
some of the other matchups. And again,
these are order lists that are not named
Leblanc. Instead, we see uh legends like
Set. Set is a list that can generate a
lot of might, but also can keep the
units alive. It's a very sticky legend
to pilot. Uh on the other side, we've
got uh aggressive lists like Rexi and or
Darius. Whether they're the hook
variants or the not, these serve as a
might check for much of the field.
They're kind of saying, "Hey, I'm going
to just play a lot of might every turn.
I'm going to use that might to get onto
a battlefield, make you contest it, and
I'm going to rinse and repeat." So,
you've got to have some sort of level of
uh interaction into these lists. You
have to have a way to defeat the might
that is going on the board. And one of
the ways that people are doing that and
have historically been doing that
throughout the unleashed history thus
far is through decks like Diana. So
Diana has been a very popular deck from
top level players like Dewali, like
Alen's EQ. And that's because Diana is
also capable of generating might, but
has a lot of interactive tools. Cards
like Gust to slow the opponent down.
cards like the Diana signature spell,
Moonfall, for example, will deal with a
large number of units at a battlefield
because of the might reduction and you
can also force combat as well. So, as we
are looking at these order decks, what
are people going to be doing to counter
it besides necessarily Diana? Well, uh,
we might have to look at some previous
tournament results in order to figure
that out because again, notably eight
unique legends. However, there are some
people whose faces are kind of on the
milk carton of the meta. So, if we go
back to what what the top eight for
Vancouver was, what we're going to see
is Ireelia is present, was missing in
Utrect. We're going to see uh, Civer is
present. So again, Dazzling Aurora, uh,
most popular on Civer, but obviously can
be played in Misfortune, can be played
on Poppy, etc. This is another deck that
many people thought was incredibly
powerful. And then, of course, there's
the legendary run that Sam D. Sherman
went on with Rengar as well. Rengar more
of a a mid-range attacking list, but uh
again, something that can either meet
the might check of some of these red
yellow lists, these order lists, uh like
the Victor list as well. that was
generating a bunch of tokens or if you
can't meet the might check like the
Rengar does then again you have to have
some way to deal with it. So, uh, we've
got the Ireelia list, which Ireelia the
legend is phenomenal at generating, uh,
additional uses from your units, moving
them around, specifically the champion
unit of Ireelia, getting a bunch of
might on it, providing it ganking with
cards like Boots of Swiftness, moving it
around, but also has access to
Starcross. the starcross plus fizz
combination is one of the ways that you
uh see people try to slow down the might
development of these opposing decks. And
so really again for me the story here is
in Hartford we have a wide open meta.
Normally at the end of a set, everyone
kind of figures out what decks are the
most powerful. But here, we just had an
event where we had eight unique legends,
not even featuring some of what many
people consider to be the best decks in
Ireelia or problematic decks in Aurora.
We also had Rengar back then. On top of
that, there are some contenders that
people continue to talk about. It did
not crack the top eight in Utrect, but
the Lux decks, the Limitless Lux, the
Infinite Lux, whatever you want to name
it, it has also been on people's radar.
On top of that list for this event, I'm
hearing a lot of rumblings in the room
about Kha'Zix and how that is another
list that like Sam D. Sherman on Rengar
can sneak up and surprise people. It's
got a lot of very adaptable mid-range
game plans. It can move units around. uh
it can get a lot of value through ambush
effects. So, Kha'Zix is also a potential
contender. And so, when you factor that
in, we are literally looking at double
digits worth of legends that could crack
the top eight here in Hartford. I do not
expect this to be like some previous
events where we might see like four
copies of a legend in the top eight.
Things are really wide open. So, what
does that do to the meta? Well, it does
mean that many of these decks are going
to need a little bit of luck on their
side. We call it matchup roulette. So
when you have your pairings, you're
hoping that you get paired into some of
the decks in the room that you have good
matchups into. So again, when you look
at the the matrix of how your decks
perform, Master Yi had a very good
matrix in Utrect. And I have heard some
people picking it up saying, "Okay, this
is just mathematically the best thing I
can be doing in the Swift round or Swiss
rounds, excuse me." But the problem is
is that once you get out of the Swiss
rounds, then to win an event, you still
got to beat the other decks as well.
What do I expect to to take it all at
the end? Well, uh, people are kind of
forgetting a little bit about Aurora.
So, I've got my eye on that as well as
some of these other decks that are kind
of sneaking their way into contention
like the Lux, like the Kha'Zix, uh, or
decks that were perhaps uh, forgot about
after Utrect, like the Ireelia. It's
really hard to nail down any just one
list here with how wide open things are.
Uh if you are a card game player, this
is the best time to be playing
Riftbound. If you are a fan of whatever
your pet legend is, it's the best time
to play it again because uh we're kind
of proving that a lot of lists are
viable and people can find success on
whatever their favorite champion from
League of Legends is in Riftbound with
the meta the way that it is. So, uh it's
going to be an exciting weekend. I'm
really looking forward to seeing how
things play out. looking forward to the
feature matches so that we can see what
these decks can do when they're on the
broadcast. And this is going to be it.
This is the last big event in the
unleashed meta with Vendetta right
around the corner. So, uh, enjoy it
while you can because the next shakeup
is right around the corner.
Welcome back to Hartford. As we prepare
for our final round of Swiss, it all
comes down to this charmer. One more
round to see who our final players are
going to be in the top cut.
>> Yes, we talk a lot about how you make
the top eight, it becomes single
elimination. But for a lot of players
still competing, this is where their
single elimination bracket begins.
Because if you don't win here, you do
not even have a shot at the top eight.
I'm seeing a lot of X2s in the
standings. They're likely going to have
to play it out and see if their
tiebreers will make them make that top
cut.
>> Yeah. Now, if you didn't tune in for the
last round, we just saw Master Yi take
down Pike. So, we know that we're going
to see Master Yi in the Top Cut, the
most represented deck in the field this
weekend. Charmer, could this be the
weekend that Master Yi ends up on top?
>> Listen, there's something to be said
about having a number of opportunities,
right? The window is open. If you make
the top cut, anything is possible. You
just have to win three games at that
point. You're crowned a champion. You
could be the first ever Master Yi
Bladesman to win a regional qualifier.
That being said, I am still of the
belief personally that Master Yi is best
in the Swiss rounds. And when people
know what they're playing against and
have unlimited time in these untimed
rounds to kind of navigate the matchup,
it becomes significantly harder because
there's not a ton of surprises in Ye. It
really is just valueoriented
and it's a pretty on the table solvable
problem. Now we take a look at day 2
meta game. Master Ye, of course, still
most represented. Had 18% of our day 2
meta. Diana and Leblanc rounding out the
top three and then it was Aurelia and
Azir. So decks that most players are
considering to be top of the meta. The
one that I guess kind of stands out is
Leblanc is still struggling to get back
to the top eight. Yeah, Leblanc
struggling a little bit. Uh, of course,
just in sheer numbers representation,
Civer here is also low, only 11 people
in day two. We also have Kha'Zix with
eight players in day two. Kai'Sa, if I'm
being entirely honest, having nine
players making day two surprises me. As
good as Kai'Sa was in the early parts of
Riftbound, she has kind of fallen by the
wayside as of late. So, kind of happy to
see that the people who are sticking
with Kai'Sa are being rewarded. Yeah, we
talked about Civer there and we also see
Kha'Zix over there with eight in day
two. Civer was your pick. Kha'Zix was my
pick. Unfortunately, I think Kha'Zix is
out of the running, but we're gonna take
a look here at our standings going into
the final round. We have one player that
is still yet to lose, and that is
Bradykin on that Ezreal deck that we
actually had the chance to watch on
stream earlier today. That's right,
Brady Kin currently 110 and one. And of
course, that one draw did happen on the
broadcast earlier against a great
player, but the rest of these X1s are
really looking to solidify their spot in
the top eight. Depending on pairings,
uh, and if you feel good about your
tiebreers, they might try to take an
intentional draw. Where it starts to
really get spicy for me is at that 10
spot or lower. And especially at all of
these 10 and two records. These are the
people that are likely going to have to
play it out if they want to secure a
spot in the top cut.
>> Absolutely could be a situation where we
see someone at X2 get on or get in on
those tiebreers as we continue. So many
great names here in that X and [music]
two bracket. We see Allan ZQ and Dewali
there at 10 and two. So they're going to
have to win and hope that Breakers would
be enough. Yeah, even going a little bit
further down that list, I also noticed
Bloody, who is a very [music] well-known
card game player as well, uh, piloting
Civer. So, still holding out hope that
my pick has a shot to make the, uh, top
cut here. But, uh, with that in mind, I
believe we're going to be going to a
vote. That's right, a vote from you, the
viewers. You get to impact the
broadcast. So, in chat, you can vote for
whether you want to see B Switz versus
Dr. Snuffles. This would be Diana taking
on Misfortune or whether you want to see
Prismaticism against Cactus King.
Reminder for folks, Cactus King is in
full regalia, a full suit while playing
today. Cactus King right now the frontr
runner of the Azir decks looking to have
Azir be a back-to- back champion over
the past two weekends in Prismaticism
trying to get to yet another top cut and
just trying to lock up that sixth best
of any. And this is looking like Chad is
favoring seeing the prismaticism taking
on Cactus King. I like that this is
almost a full circle moment for Cactus
King because when they were on the
broadcast earlier, they talked about how
their experience was this is their first
regional qualifier. They show up uh they
did not have an opponent in their first
round and then they had to play against
Dewali right out of the gate and they
did beat Dewali. Said that was a kind of
key confidence booster and they've been
riding that for the rest of the event.
[music] So they started against a
regional qualifier winner in Dvali and
now to potentially get into [music] the
top cut, they have to beat another
regional qualifier winner in
Prismaticism. I think if this [music]
ends up going the way of Cactus King,
nobody can doubt that they've earned the
spot at that point.
>> No, not at all. I mean, that would be an
absolutely incredible feat. And it's
very likely that is a win and match. So,
so much at stake and it looks like you
at home you chose you want Annie versus
Azir. Prismaticism versus Cactus King
going to be a fireworks show charmer.
Oh, absolutely. This is a matchup where
you cannot afford to blink. Both of
these players are going to be playing
units getting onto battlefields
incredibly quickly scoring those points.
I have to say I'm also excited to
[music] see what the interaction is
going to be like in this matchup because
on the one side obviously Annie wants to
use the legend ability and giving those
two free [music] energy runes back to
play spells like flash to play spells uh
excuse me not a spell swords play swords
like long sword I'm so used to spells in
Annie but they have upgraded to the
three long swords lately on the other
side there is cards like defy and we
know that defy is an incredibly powerful
card in the meta and we've seen
prismatic says literally win a regional
qualifier in the past on the back of
cards like long sword and Rengar that
can't be defied. Yeah, that's absolutely
right. Now, taking a look at the
percentages, it looks like we're
favoring Annie here, 54% to 46%. So,
Prismaticism maybe with the edge coming
into this match. I think that long sword
that you talked about, we mentioned it
earlier in the stream. I think it could
be a very important piece to the puzzle
for Prismaticism here in this particular
match. Let's take a look at the run that
Prismaticism has been on to get to this
point. That only loss coming in the
final round of day one going down to
Rexi. Yeah, that was something must work
who has been in contention. The last
time we actually checked in on the best
of for [music] Rexi was in the lead with
Rexi. So, Prismaticism dropping one
there. Did also have a draw against an
Ireelia, but otherwise a lot of
victories, which we've come to expect
from Prismaticism. [music]
However, I said at the top of the
broadcast, day one is where legends are
played. Day two is where legends are
made. This could be the coming out party
for Cactus King with a win here. Did
lose one game to a Diana. Just lost to
that Dr. Snuffles, who is competing for
that top cut spot on Misfortune, but
still very much in it and could walk
away with their first ever top eight
appearance.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely right. Took down
an Annie earlier today. We'll see if
Cactus King can repeat that success
against the previous regional qualifier
champion. Here is the deck list for
Prismaticism. We talked about those long
swords, three copies of the long sword.
Is there anything else that's really
standing out to you for this particular
match charmer?
>> So, one thing to [music] note here, and
I actually like it, is you will notice
hard bargain and abandon are in the
list. Uh hard bargain being an answer to
an opposing defy because obviously
that's going to be Azir's premier way to
stop some of your plays like the cleave,
the stack deck, and the flash. Uh even
that's even though it's just a one-off,
having it on hand to make sure that
whatever you're trying to have go
through is forced through can be a
pretty big deal. Uh the other thing that
I want to point out is of course uh the
Vex Apathetic two copies in the main
deck. And the reason I'm pointing that
out is because that shuts down Arise.
And we know that Arise is usually very
key for Azir to close out games.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely right. also can
close down that Azir, the chosen
champion, from accelerating out and
bringing those tokens right away. But
this Annie deck wants to be aggressive,
wants to get into the battlefield, score
points aggressively, and again, those
two runes that you get back every turn
off the Annie legend leaves you the
flexibility to still have the
interaction. And we've seen Prismaticism
pilot this deck so many times. He won in
Atlanta and he's looking to repeat that
here in Hartford. Let's take a look at
the Azir deck list followed by Cactus
King. And here, this is pretty cookie
cutter, but that is not a knock on this
list whatsoever. It is doing all the
things you want to do in Azir. If
anything jumps out to me, sometimes you
see Azir just run one copy of the VI
peacekeeper. This is on two copies,
which I adore. The ambush units from
Unleashed have been allstars in this
meta. So including a couple of them here
makes sense. The one edge perhaps that
prismaticism has is the red Rengar, the
Pouncing Rengar [music] is a little bit
cheaper and still also attacks for five.
So there might be a bit of an econ
economical advantage. But on the other
hand, another card that jumps out to me
is the three copies of Back Off. uh that
could end up being very clutch in this
matchup because of all of the ambush
options. Being able to respond with
this, whether it's from hidden or from
hand if you need the card draw is a
pretty big deal. And a card that we've
seen a lot in these Azer decks because
it's just so good is death grip. I love
this pump in this deck because it allows
you to be aggressive and then you can
use that death grip to kill one of your
units, buff up another one, and it's
importantly dropping off that equipment
so that you can then reattach and
potentially go back into a battlefield
and conquer yet again. And of course,
death grip with the most metal of all
flavor text in the game. Death is my
kindness, says Morichiser.
It's growing on me. I still say that the
best flavor text in the game is of
course on back off and that's just EU.
But what is not you is our matchup and
we're going to be going to the table and
seeing who can walk away with a victory
and [music]
hopefully secure their spot in the top
eight.
A huge moment for both of these players.
A lot of work and [music] preparation
has gone into getting ready for moments
like this.
>> Yeah, I like it as my hydration
>> on the biggest stage in Riftbound.
>> Stay hydrated.
>> It tastes like blue raspberry
>> trying to secure a spot in the top cut.
>> Okay,
>> as they have an eye on a trophy
and Chris already [music] touching the
hair, trying to get the vibes going at
the same time.
>> Feeling it. Here we have
>> good luck.
>> The brute of prismaticism versus [music]
the suit of cactus king [laughter]
which will prevail.
>> All right, game one.
The final round of Swiss is underway. A
prismaticism starting things out with
the traveling merchant
>> and it's equipped
>> and cactus king
>> coming back getting that equipment out
right away
>> and the legend ability creating that
sand soldier taking advantage of the
weapon master.
>> Good
>> getting it attached right away.
Sometimes when you play brutalizer, you
don't always want to immediately attach
it with the weapon master, but in this
case, because it's your opening turn
play being on the rune, it's safe to do
it. It makes this sand soldier
immediately three might on the following
turn. forgoing obviously the equip
bonus, but three might still greater
than two on the merchant. And that might
either force prismaticism to save some
sort of reaction if they want to save
the merchant or perhaps not move the
merchant at all, which would be a big
victory for Cactus King. That being
said, I have to assume that Prismaticism
has some sort of trickery to be able to
answer whatever Cactus King throws,
whether that's a long sword in reaction
or a flash to bring it back. not only
save the merchant, but flash is key
because it triggers that move trigger
once again.
Prismaticism tanking a little bit here
on this early stacked deck.
>> Yeah, it's not often that you see
prismaticism take that much time. So,
that must have been a very difficult
decision.
>> And now a second stack deck. Maybe this
one will be a much faster decision
and that is the case. So that first one
a little bit of a deliberation but
prismaticism seems to like the contents
of the second one much more.
>> Knox is hopeful coming down for just two
energy passing back over
>> and I had mentioned that cactus king
might actually be happy if that merchant
does not swing and that was the case.
So, prismaticism perhaps some of that
deliberation had to do with the fact
that there were not those interactive
options and as a result, Cactus King
kept prismaticism off of a battlefield.
But on the other end, because of the
development of the hopeful, Cactus King
also deferred going into a battlefield,
not wanting to lose it there. So,
patient play, patient openers from both
players.
>> Rockard.
>> Yeah, both players just developing
early. But now, Prismaticism
going to strike first here. Conquering
both battlefields, getting that extra
card off of the seat of power
and going to reinforce at the Hall of
Legends with the Ferris 4Runner putting
10 might there at that southern
battlefield. As we go back over to
Cactus King, two sand soldiers. We have
the brutalizer on one of them, the BF
sword on the other.
It's a total of eight might between the
two units currently.
And I think prismaticism has to be
pretty happy with this opener thus far
simply because
>> he has said in the past, specifically
when he won in Atlanta, that Ferris
4Runner is kind of the key of the deck.
In fact, he said he was playing Annie
because he felt it was just the best
Ferris 4runner deck
>> here was able to reinforce on curve like
you want. And then because of Annie's
ability again, still has energy left
over, plays this long sword and trying
to make sure that they can take out the
VI. But this,
>> look at the back and forth though
reaction with discipline.
>> What a heads up play here by both
players. The long sword coming out and
then the discipline just to save that
vi. Very important for Cactus King and
he is going to end up conquering
>> three to two. Very important early
showdown there for Cactus King. And now
he's going to conquer up to two.
>> And not only does he conquer to two, but
>> because of the might that's left over on
both battlefields, Prismaticism is only
in a position to trade and get rid of
the units. Cactus King will not have any
energy available going into the
following turn,
>> but Prismaticism at best could likely
get rid of these.
uh unless there's something like a
starcrust. That is one of the things
that's worth mentioning is starcross in
this matchup against the sand soldiers
does turn it into just straight removal.
Obviously, sand soldiers cannot go back
to your hand being token units. So
perhaps we will see that at some point.
However, given that your only units on
your own side right now are the mech
tokens now that poses the issue of
that's going to destroy your own mech
tokens as well.
So now Cactus King looking to
potentially hold one of these
battlefields, but he has fully exhausted
all of his runes. So no interaction
coming from Cactus King here on
Prismat's turn.
>> And Prismat taking a moment to think and
drink.
>> This is of course just a math problem
because you have face up might and no
energy available. The biggest issue for
prismaticism is I don't think that
there's an easy way to solve it. The
follow-up equip sword means that there
is six might on one side, five on the
other. You have your two mech tokens and
a long sword. Even if you were trying to
cascade the long sword, the fact that
the one side has six might means that
yes, you could get rid of the VI,
>> but you have to have some other sort of
answer. And in this case, it's going to
be Inferno with the ambush triggering
the assault does mean that you go over
the VI, clear it, and score this conquer
>> with plenty of runes still up on the
other side. And a cleave as well.
>> That cleave is going to be a big deal
here. And that is an eight might mech
moving into the seed of power. And once
again, Prismaticism able to double
conquer, get that extra card off of the
seed of power
>> as the equipment fall back to base for
Cactus King.
>> Overzeealous fan
>> and Prismat going to reinforce with that
overzealous fan.
And regaining the tempo is Prismat here
in game one
on a game where Cactus King has the Hall
of Legends and would love to be able to
take advantage of it to
>> create more and more tokens, but we are
going to see a rise here with three
equipment in play after the door and
shield comes down. So, this is three
sand soldier tokens to be created and
two of them will be ready.
>> Let's see where the equipment attaches
>> as we wait on the equipment attachments.
Though, I do suspect it'll be brutalizer
and BF sword. Yeah, nothing.
>> We're about to potentially see the
actual power of overzealous fan in this
matchup because traditionally you might
try to cascade weapons to clear both of
these battlefields, but the first one
that goes in will likely just trigger
and we do see that be the case.
>> So, it goes away and now that sand
soldier stays alive. So there's no way
to balance uh the gear across other
options. And this other sand soldier is
just going to go try to take the seed of
power and at least get one win. But this
is a
>> another long sword.
>> Double long sword on the mech. And it's
enough to hold there for Prismaticism.
>> Wow.
>> Huge point there for Prismaticism. He's
going to hold both battlefields up to
six. and he has full control of this
game one charmer.
>> Yeah, that was the classic epic fantasy
battle of one person with a sword and
board, the other person dual wielding
long swords. That mech being just a
little bit better than the sand soldier
token. Uh prismaticism showing exactly
why they have moved to three long swords
in this list. It's so good in the
current environment. It not only dodges
defy, not that that was relevant because
of the exhausted runes, but the might
sticks around even when this mech is
gone.
>> Being able to play it at reaction speed,
this is so clutch.
>> And on Prismaticism's turn, I would not
be surprised
if we see a retreat and just trying to
set up for a double conquer. The only
reason that you might consider leaving
the mech up there is because the long
swords can be re-equipped on whatever
else you're developing anyway and you
want to make it difficult for them to
land on that spot because you don't want
them to draw from the seat of power.
Yeah. So, in in reading that we're going
to retreat the inferna and then you're
going to see the reinforce and that's
just exactly what I was talking about.
You don't want the draw from the seat of
power if you can help it.
That is a massive amount of might there
at the northern battlefield.
A total of 13 might there for
Prismaticism.
Cactus King
and a bit of trouble here in game one.
Two sand soldiers still in the backline.
And with the equipment
has an additional five might.
The brutalizer currently attached to
that one sand soldier.
>> So not getting the additional plus two.
>> Couldn't get a good look at Cactus
King's hand here, but another Arise
would certainly be beneficial.
>> I'll float one.
>> That would give you four units readied
>> and an attempt at again cascading some
of these weapons through. But the fact
that this BF sword is going on now
>> signals that you might not have the
arise. though the energy was floated. So
still technically six energy available
uh plus the additional one from the
float.
>> Can I just see those confirm?
>> Okay,
>> second copy of Ferris 4Runner dealt
with. But the 4Runner just showing its
value here replacing itself with another
six might.
>> That unit has been a staple ever since
Spirit Forged.
>> All flash
>> as we now see the sand soldier moving
in. And now it's the flash for
prismaticism.
>> One card in hand after that.
>> Looking to flash back that mech token.
>> Now this is a pretty big deal because
>> if Cactus King does not have the define,
I suspect that's what we're going to see
here.
>> What prismaticism would have denied is
uh again potentially this draw from the
seat of power.
>> Yes. You're floating for a brutalizer.
>> Countering that flash
>> and uh
>> another brutalizer.
>> Sand soldier equipping Dorn shield.
>> Okay.
>> And a sand soldier being created by
Azir.
This
>> is going to be five six after this.
>> Prismaticism.
>> Can he double conquer on this next turn?
Cactus King has to try and hold at one
of these battlefields. Going to hide a
card there at seed of power.
>> You have two runes off. And again,
having seen the list, this card could be
a back off. It could be a hidden blade.
Prismaticism is in their planning likely
just going to count it as any sort of
single target answer.
The token there at that seat of power,
six might currently.
And between the three units in base for
prismaticism representing 369
might on offense. Plus, you've got the
two long sword as well.
>> Yeah, I think the real trick here is
that for prismaticism to win, they
>> need a double conquer. So, at least one
of these units needs to be committed.
>> And we see that now.
>> Oh, here's the star cross.
>> You got it.
>> Okay. after going into the southern
battlefield and conquering the star
cross is going to remove the token
>> at the northern battlefield and Cactus
King can't stop it and we are going to
go to game two. Prismaticism the early
lead here in the final round. Okay,
>> that was such a massive play there to
get the unit on the other battlefield,
get that conquer point, then utilize it
for the star cross, force Cactus King to
have a second defy. You baited one the
turn before
>> and then put them in a position where
they essentially had to have it
>> Cactus King now down one game,
>> but still smiling.
>> You love to see it. Cactus King has been
having a great time. You could tell it
in the interview that he had yesterday.
Really enjoying his time here at the
regional qualifier at Hartford.
Said he wanted to dress the part
suiting up this weekend.
Had a couple players at least in suits.
Allen this morning.
>> That's right.
>> Walking around in that suit as well.
[laughter]
looking quite dapper if I do say so
myself.
>> Yeah.
>> So, now we get ready for game two as the
players think through some sideboarding
options.
Yeah, the interesting thing here is that
I'm not sure there are a ton of cards
that you consider bringing into the
sideboard if you're cactus king.
However, prismaticism
uh being in fury, being in chaos, likely
has access to uh maybe a thermmo beam,
for example, uh example, excuse me. Um
could also consider just running
acceptable losses like many of the Diana
players have run because you'd be able
to always have the energy for it and
then play it at action speed. There is
uh of course still rebuke available.
While it's fallen out of favor in the
meta, the fact that it costs exactly two
is still relevant. So a lot of times
these annual lists will have some number
of them in the sideboard. We'll have to
wait and see what comes in.
>> Well, we saw how relevant it was
bouncing that token in the first game.
So rebuke certainly could be a viable
option for game two.
It will be Prismaticism on Zan Warren
and Cactus King on Grove of the God
Willow
trying to generate some extra cards off
of Grove. And
as Warren will allow these players to
cycle,
you know, Grove of the Godwillow is a
really interesting inclusion as far as a
battlefield for Azir.
You tend to think of Azir as an
attacking style deck. You want to play
your equipment and then you want to get
the units into combat. Sometimes you
want your units to perish so that you
can re-equip onto other tokens onto
other units. But Grover the Godwillow is
instead rewarding you for holding, which
does signal that perhaps sometimes
Cactus King likes to put the equipment
on, you know, one big unit or maybe a
couple of units and then try to park
them there and say, "Hey, I'm going to
make you deal with my units for me and
then I'll cascade the equipment. Then
I'll re-equip." So, we'll see if this
alters the play pattern at all in game
two.
>> Should be a lot of fun here.
What could we be bringing out of the
sideboard for Cactus King to improve the
chances here in game two?
>> It's interesting because
when you think about order and you think
about calm, uh, order does have options
in salvage and ash for matchups like
Dazzling Aurora. You typically have some
number of them. perhaps you consider
bringing in salvage because you just
lost to two long swords, right? That
might be something where you say, "Okay,
well maybe I I want some sort of answer
to that." Um, outside of that, again,
you're you're playing calm and also
because we know Cactus King is on this
Grove of the Godwillow. Uh, we could see
cards like Charm where again, you're
trying to camp with these big units that
are all wearing the equipment and then
you use the Charm as a cheap removal
option to deal with some of these
backline threats. And in this matchup,
if charm is in the list, I would think
Cactus King would consider bringing it
in because it's a great way to force
back into combat units that have been
flashed away.
>> I'll go first.
>> Yeah, that's an excellent point.
>> Good luck.
>> We know that flash is
>> That's a new one.
>> The card used very heavily in this Annie
deck.
>> It's worked out pretty good so far.
>> Here we go. Players are set.
>> We're ready for game two.
And Cactus King should be going first
this time around. Was going second in
game one. Started with that brutalizer
and then created
>> a token. We are going to see a twocard
mulligan.
>> So either
>> did not like the hand or is in search of
one of those one energy costed equipment
pieces. I do believe I see a soul sword
there. So the option is available. Here
we go. Game two is underway. It's Dor
and Shield on turn one. Finding one of
the one cost equipment
>> for Cactus King developing the sand
soldier. Quickly equipping that shield
as it's overzealous fan developed first
for Prismaticism.
>> And now
Prismaticism has an early unit and three
energy available.
zero.
>> There's the soul sword that I had spied
earlier. So, that's going to be played
create another token. We could see a
situation where Cactus King passes and
that is the case. Just kind of playing
conservative, waiting until you feel
confident enough that you can protect
these units when they do get on the
battlefield. but with only two energy up
and if you don't have something like a
discipline or defy backing you up. You
don't want to throw these units away for
nothing. Uh on the other side we again
see the patient play from prismaticism.
No card to pair to reduce the cost of
the Noxus. So you simply play it for
four and then it ends up costing two
anyway as if you paid the Legion because
of Annie's legend ability.
>> Ability players playing a little bit
conservatively. We saw this in game one
as well
>> over the first couple turns. Now the BF
sword comes down
>> and here is Rengar
>> thinking about
>> being played
>> as a reaction
>> I to base.
>> I had the pleasure of interviewing
Gonkra earlier today and they were
saying that one of the beautiful things
about this Rengar unit is its reaction.
It is not ambush. this Rengar, Pouncing
Rengar in particular, when your opponent
plays something, you can react and
develop it on your own turn. So, it
allows for these kind of double
development plays where you play
something like the hopeful pass and then
also play the Rengar essentially getting
seven energies worth of units out
despite the fact that you were not at
seven runes going into that.
>> And the Rengar has stopped the
aggression once again from Cactus King.
He decides once again, I'm not pushing
in.
>> Prismaticism now going to develop that
Kai'Sa as well.
>> Battlefield, huh?
>> And he's just going to pass now. So,
[laughter] both players just going back
and forth here developing on the
backline. Who will
>> push the limits first? Charmer. Yeah. If
you would have told me that in an Azir
versus Annie match, we would be in turn
four and nobody would have a point or
have even been to a battlefield,
I would have thought something dire had
went wrong. But honestly, this has been
a very tit fortat opening where uh it's
an arms race and the first person to
either miss a development or honestly
just make a mistake and blink means the
other person will be able to capitalize.
So again, they're feeling each other
out. They're trying to figure out what
the appropriate moment is. Uh, this is a
great play from Cactus King to get some
of that critical information from
Prismaticism by developing the Ash. And
I was just about to say one of the
things you're going to see when this
reveal occurs is likely a lack of ferris
forrunners. If their forrunner was there
the previous turn, prismaticism loves to
get on a battlefield and force a
reinforced forerunner there and then
ready the runes and say, "Okay, break
this wall." So, not only were we seeing
no
>> 4Runner, but we also saw the thermo
beam. So, now we know why prismaticism
was being patient. This might have been
just a bait for Cactus King to play all
this equipment.
>> Now, the thermo beam banished, but
>> this king can get it back as soon as he
holds as Kaisa moves up. And for the
first time here in game two, we're going
to see some action at a battlefield.
This open showdown
is successful for prismaticism
conquering up to one
>> discarding far enough.
>> Mhm.
>> We have the on Warren trigger discarding
and then drawing and then Kaisa trigger
so
>> and a grove.
>> Yep.
>> Two cards coming to Prismat's hand.
>> Flash both my units
>> going in scoring that second point and
just going to use flash.
>> Two cards in or three.
>> Two cards.
>> Looking to bounce these units right back
out.
>> Flash is good. All right. All right,
>> resolved.
>> Flash is successful
and
does look like prismaticism is going to
continue to develop and does play a Vex
apathetic which can be super relevant in
this matchup.
>> Quite the backline for both of these
players, but Prismaticism able to strike
first here in game two.
Cactus King with four loaded up sand
soldiers
and the Ash.
>> I did see a bit of Cactus King's hand
just briefly there and I
>> thought I saw it defy. So, as we go into
these future turns, we're going to have
to keep that in mind.
>> Does Cactus King finally push forward
here?
try and make a claim at one of these
battlefields.
>> 36 minutes.
>> Yeah, at some point, not only do you
need to keep up on points, but also
>> after seeing prismaticism do it, you
have to consider going to zon just to
potentially hand fix if you don't like
your hand. Getting this trigger can be
>> I would like to
>> relevant. We are seeing cactus king go
in. The conqueror is successful.
Actually discards the defy that I had
spied. Little bit surprising there.
>> The Defy is discarded. Maybe
>> it's telegraphing another Defy in hand
as
>> Come in here. Move trigger.
>> Yep.
>> Cactus King is going to conquer both of
these battlefields. And now reinforcing.
>> Uh I believe that's actually the Eye of
the Herald trigger.
>> Yeah, reinforcing at that northern
battlefield with the sand soldier
getting the move trigger for another
recruit.
Just adding an additional might to the Z
warren.
>> That's seven on the
>> correct
>> players have a lot of units,
a lot of runes.
I think the suspension
of uh
the the treaty is upon us. I think that
we are going to see far more combat.
>> Right. They've both finally scored
points. They've been patient.
>> The suspense has been built and now it
is time for the battle to begin.
And keep in mind this game too is a
mustwin for Cactus King if he wants any
hope.
>> And continuing forward in this
tournament, here is the long sword on
Rengar. It will move forward. This is a
total of seven might. But here comes the
back off from Cactus King to stun Rengar
if this resolves
>> and it would allow Cactus King to draw a
card as well since it's played from
hand. And we do have a star cross in
response.
>> And this soldier
>> and it's going to be the Rengar and the
soldier at the southern battlefield.
There is another defy in hand. Starcross
is countered.
>> Oh, Grim Apothecary pick up the ringer.
>> And so it'll be the Grim Apothecary
looking to bounce back. Rengar
>> still draws a card.
>> Chrisbaticism not wanting to lose Rengar
in combat.
No, that Rengar is so important to your
game plan. Being able to get it back and
then replay it, move it around.
Guarantee you get that five boost.
>> Yep, that's good.
>> It's relevant.
>> Yeah, the discipline here is actually
>> forcing
>> this grim apothecary to only trade with
the recruit. Only three might. Ash was
at four. The other sand soldier goes up
to four after the discipline. And so
after all is said and done,
Prismaticism's first attack on this turn
results in just clearing a recruit after
a lot of energy was spent.
Likely not happy with that outcome.
However, there is still plenty of units
that you can send in and try to win some
of these battlefields.
And we see a lot going to the grove.
This might signal prismaticism wants to
get on this battlefield and attempt a
hold. But I think that instead of
allowing any opportunity for that Vex to
be lost, you want to send in all of your
other units. Make sure you get the
conquer and then move Vex in pass the
turn with four energy and and hope that
you Yeah. get this uh hold point and the
draw. So that's exactly what we see.
>> Up to three points goes Prismaticism
and will attempt to hold at the southern
battlefield. Overzealous fan Vex and
Kai'Sa there. Kaisa six might with the
long sword
>> as we send it back over to Cactus King.
He holds to three.
>> First successful hold
>> of game number two here in the final
round of Swiss of our Hartford regional
qualifier.
Must win for Cactus King.
>> Well, first before we talk about
winning, Cactus King almost has to break
this hold. If this hold goes through,
it's not even about the card draw. It's
not even about the points. It's the fact
that Thermo Beam will go back into
Prismatic's hand.
>> And that could be devastating given the
number of equipment on the field for
Cactus King.
>> So, if you have the tools to get through
this wall built at the Grove of the
Godwillow, you almost are forced into
doing it. Like you are priced into the
interaction to try to get rid of the
specs.
>> Here we go. That sand soldier loaded up.
It's a total of six might. And the
overzealous fan will be killed with that
defend trigger pushing back the sand
soldier to Cactus King's base.
>> And the issue now is that you don't have
enough to get rid of the Vex. And the
reason the Vex was so important was if
you had something like Arise in your
hand,
>> you needed the Vex to be gone first so
that Arise or even just guards could
continue the chain here. But that that
first repel from the overzealous fan was
a pretty big deal. And now instead,
we're just going to see three more
equipment drop to the table.
>> And again, this is Cactus King going
essentially all in needing to break this
because
>> the number of equipment before was
already high.
>> If somehow Prismaticism gets the thermo
beam off now,
>> I think Cactus King loses on the spot.
So this is a big gamble. This is Cactus
King essentially pushing all the chips
in, going all in, saying, "If I don't
win here, I don't win at all." And this
is a huge answer from Prismaticism.
>> Yeah, Rengar coming down to the
battlefield. We are going to see the
back off though to stun one of these
units.
>> Another card for Cactus King.
>> 10 might to 15. We are going to see
Kaisa and Vex go down.
>> But importantly, Prismaticism holding on
to the go the excuse me, the Grove of
the God Willow.
>> Correct.
>> My Soldier and these are all on him
still.
>> And this is why Prismaticism spent so
many resources saving this Rengar
earlier. Being able to deploy might from
your hand
>> at reaction speed is critical for some
of these holds. This is literally how he
won the regional qualifier in Atlanta
with that Rengar. And once again, a
reaction speed Rengar
>> holding for prismaticism might just win
him yet another game because now thermmo
beam is back in the hand. And there are
so many pieces of equipment on the side
of Cactus King.
>> This would be a a not a thermo beam,
this would be a thermo bomb in any other
situation.
>> Oh, absolutely.
>> There is a total
of seven pieces of equipment over there
for Cactus King. And here is the thermo
beam to wipe out them all.
>> Massive play.
>> Oh no. All right.
>> And Cactus King and all of the
development, the resources spent to
develop all of those equipment.
>> Merchant,
>> it's all gone now as a traveling
merchant
>> joins Rengar in the backline for
prismaticism.
>> Four to three is what I have for the
score.
>> This is correct. Cactus King did pull
all units back to his base. So, he has
the units here. He's got three sand
soldiers, the one recruit, and the Ash,
so not quite out of this game just yet.
>> Seven equipment gone. We know that
traditionally Azirists run nine one cost
>> equipment. I like to come here.
>> Three BF swords. That takes you up to
12. If they're on the three of
brutalizer, like many are, that's 15.
So, almost half of the entire deck's
equipment gone to one beam. But the good
news is for Cactus King,
>> the game's not over. There are still
cards available in the hand. We've
already found one piece of equipment.
>> They're not out of it yet.
>> It's just going to be a very big uphill
battle.
>> Master on them.
>> Okay.
see one of those other pieces of
equipment. The door and shield coming
down, allowing Cactus King to put yet
another sand soldier token into play off
of Azir
>> as Ash is going to move into Grove of
the Godwillow, scoring up to five for
Cactus King.
>> And now Ash is going to find herself
with five might and tank as the shield
is equipped. All of these ready sand
soldiers moving into Grove of the
Godwillow Cactus King
>> trying to claim the ground there at the
Grove.
>> And I like the strategy from Cactus King
because you essentially already did your
all-in play. As I said before, it was
akin to pushing your chips at the center
of the table. Right now, with only one
card in hand
>> to get back into this game, you need to
refill your hand. You do that through
Grove of the God Willow. So giving Ash
the tank and then just jamming all of
your remaining sand soldier tokens here.
You're hoping that prismaticism doesn't
have enough might to go over the top and
you not only score a point and that gets
you within striking distance of winning
but also gets you a card which is ever
so important at this stage of the game.
Yes, Cactus King has the points lead but
they are technically behind in terms of
overall board tempo because of that big
thermmo beam.
>> Uh 11 total. With those two units that
Prismaticism has in base, it's a total
of seven might on offense. Rengar moves
in against the odds for Prismaticism.
That is going [laughter] to be plus
eight might plus two for each enemy unit
there. That is massive.
>> The discipline onto Ash.
>> Ash will go up to a total of seven
might.
>> Okay.
>> But Rengar is massive charmer. Yeah, we
were talking about cards that could
potentially come in from sideboards. We
know against the odds is not in the main
deck, but it is a masterful inclusion
and bringin from Prismaticism in a
matchup like this. Uh you've got so many
tokens on the side of Cactus King. This
becomes essentially using your Annie's
legend ability.
>> Sword. That's it. The handshake and
Prismaticism takes it. He moves to 111
and one. Annie with prismaticism will
find another spot in the top cut.
Unreal.
>> Draw a card.
>> Chuck it. Draw a new card.
>> So wellnavigated by prismaticism.
>> And that's what you've come to expect
from him.
>> However, I need to give credit where
credit is due. We've seen Cactus King a
couple of times on the broadcast. I do
not think Cactus King lost this because
of their play. In fact, in game two, I
would like to praise the patience that
was shown, kind of matching prismaticism
in that arms race until something had to
give it properly identifying that you
needed to try to break that groove of
the god to prevent the thermmo beam from
coming back. Unfortunately, prismaticism
had just the number of tools to stop
that from happening. And then again
here, even though the beam went off, I
identified the only way I get back into
this is by drawing the card from the
grove. So I have to go all in again. And
unfortunately for Cactus King,
Prismaticism is the true king of
answers.
That was the perfect card out of the
sideboard that against the odds because
we know how well Azir can flood the
board and put multiple units, multiple
tokens just flooded all in the board.
and against the odds is perfect in that
particular matchup and in that spot. It
helps prismaticism
get to his sixth top cut charmer. That
is absolutely insane. 1 2 3 4 5 six. We
have to count on two hands now for
prismaticism. And that also keeps him
alive for the best of Annie cuz there
was a lot of competition at this event.
Uh in some events he was very clearly
ahead of the pack. This time it has not
come easy, but perhaps we will see an
expansion of that necklace when all is
said and done.
>> Six top cut appearances could be six
best of Annies. That was an exciting
match.
>> But Prismaticism takes it. What a run
though for Cactus King.
>> Dressed up in the suit. Played so well
on stream yesterday and giving it
everything he had in that final round
against Prismat. You couldn't ask for
anything else. a fantastic competitor.
>> And uh again, during the interview, we
heard him once say, "This is my first
regional. This is why I dressed up. I
wanted to look the part." Well, you did
really well for your first regional
qualifier. I would love to see Cactus
King run this back at future events.
Would love to see them perhaps in LA,
maybe trying to crack that top eight
officially. Uh again, the performance
was very, very good.
I hope we call this name many many times
in the future.
>> Absolutely was a pleasure to watch and
who knows he could potentially still be
in the running for the best of. I'm not
sure where the best of Azir race was
going in to this round. But certainly
still a shot if none of them make it
into the top eight because we know 10
and three will not be good enough to get
Cactus King there here today. Charmer,
this has been such a fun weekend. The
energy in the room has been excellent.
And here it is. We're actually going to
look at the best of Azir right now.
Thank you so much. Production Cactus
King coming in was tied with four
players or three other players. Four
including himself at 10 and two. So
Cactus [snorts] King needs some help if
he's going to retain that lead.
>> Yeah, you are correct. Did have the
better tiebreers going in. So if the
other three lose will likely be fine. It
is also worth noting though that below
the 10 and twos there are also four more
nine and threes. And so if Koopastar for
example who's at the top of that list
does get a win and Cactus King drops on
tiebreers then Koopasar might be able to
jump up and steal it. But I will say the
one thing helping Cactus King is you
just lost against Prismaticism. That
means that your tiebreers as far as your
your record of uh opponents if have got
to be pretty good. Again, it's really
going to come down to whether or not
Strog, Talion, or Waro win their game
and advance to 11 wins and then that
would of course User Cactus King's top
spot.
>> Yeah, that is absolutely right. We could
see
very interesting finish there for Azir.
Now we take a look at best of Annie and
it looks like prismaticism has
officially locked up a six best of
Annie. That's just ridiculous. Yeah, the
the necklace is growing. I I need to ask
him after the event is over whether or
not his neck has hurt all day just from
the weight. Again, these are metal
cards, right? The best of are those
beautiful metal variants and that that
feels like a lot of weight to be
carrying [music] for 13 rounds of Swiss
around your neck.
Absolutely. Now we are going to take a
look at Beast Whites here and the run
that he has had through Swiss. This was
our backup feature match for this round
and in contention here coming into this
round with just one loss and a draw
against Dr. Snuffles and another
potential win and match.
>> That's right. Dr. Snuffles on Misfortune
did drop a game early on against a
Victor on day one. Again, Victor can be
a very problematic matchup for decks
focused on Dazzling Aurora. You have to
assume that that is exactly what Dr.
Snuffles is doing on Misfortune, but
otherwise has been a very clean path to
a potential victory, including a victory
last round against Cactus King. So,
Cactus King, unfortunately, kind of
hitting the wall at the very end of the
event, but uh we [music] are going to be
taking a look at Dr. Snuffles taking on
BS Whites here in just a bit. I believe
we're actually going to be jumping into
it in uh in motion. So, I believe we'll
be joining them right when game two is
starting, but we do have some stuff for
you in the wings. So, it's not quite
game time yet.
>> Yeah, I believe in the very near future.
We're just preparing to get that
interview and hear from Prismat after
that big win and we can talk about a
sixth best of Annie. That is absolutely
crazy. But let's talk again a little bit
about the best ofs. And again, I know
that the community loves the best ofs.
And it's really the talk about Riftbound
because this prizing is just so unique.
And it seems to be something that drives
players to [music] compete at a very
high level. And it also helps bring
great diversity because you have players
competing for best of on legends that
aren't top tier meta decks. and you love
to see players doing that and bring us
that diverse feel.
>> Yeah, it does those things. But if I'm
being honest, part of the reason that I
love the best of prizing as well is that
it brings in the feeling from League of
Legends where you have that
identification with your favorite
champion from League. So you'll main
something and say, I want to be the best
in the world at Scarnner, for example.
And you can do that in Riftbound.
>> Yeah, you absolutely can. Well, we are
not going to keep you waiting any
longer. Six best of Annie's
prismaticism. Let's hear from him.
I always have to be so humbled every
time I get to stand next to one of the
greatest in Riftbound so far,
Prismaticism. Another lock in top eight.
Your sixth best of Annie. How does it
feel right now? because I think I
remember last week in Azir being what
stopped you getting a higher placement
and now it seems like you've conquered
your sand soldier demon. So
>> yeah, I mean that guy's not Squirtle.
Squirtle's an actual actual demon. But
it does feel good to win that match up
especially game two. That was like a
very hopeless looking position when he
Ash and took my thermo beam. It's like
that was my plan. I was going to sit
here and do nothing and then press
thermo beam at some point and then he he
said no. And then I was like, "Okay, I
guess at some point I'm gonna farm with
Kai'Sa and Flash as long as I can. And
at some point I'm g have to try to hold.
Probably ideally a 4Runner shows up and
that'll make it easier to hold. But then
he I think he overextended a bit and
then probably on the turn that I was
holding with the Vex and the fan and the
Kai'Sa I think he probably had an easier
way to clear with his Azir accelerating
to me. Um, but he missed that and then
that just swung the game completely. And
I and I think that's like it's always
playing like even when things look
bleak, playing to your outs, playing to
your win condition because that's that's
where I've stolen a lot of games.
>> I guess you could say it was maybe
against all odds as well. That was a
pretty good card.
>> I love it when that card comes out cuz
almost nobody's playing it, but the fact
that it just like when it comes into
that moment and like does that like
hyper punish of the sort of game plan of
what they're trying to do to come back
into the game. Huge shout out to Cactus
King though. First ever regional
qualifier ever. Um
>> Oh yeah. doing a phenomenal job and you
know taking even insight from Squirtle.
But I I want to focus on you right now
because there's a bigger story line here
to be had which is you are the only
returning regional qualifier champion
going into this top eight against seven
other very hungry competitors.
Do you feel that pressure? Because
there's also, you know, a Lux running
around that did also beat Allen during
the game.
>> I do need to kill that Lux, but there is
um I've been saying like when me,
Dewali, and I think Squirtle were top
eight in Utra where it's like we need to
keep these keep it closed number of
regional winners. Keep it within us. And
now it's up to me. I'm the only one left
that can stop them. I'm going to be
bottom seed, too. So, it's going to be
an uphill climb.
>> And that's okay. You know, I feel like
I've seen it, you know, even back in
Atlanta where it seems everything's
down, your hair is as fluffed as it can
be at a given point. But, you know,
sometimes the Rengars are really helping
you out right now. And I'm still a big
fan of the changes you've made with the
long swords and how every time I see you
play one and then another one hits the
board and I go, man, the fact that
you've increased this number, it just it
it warms my heart cuz I think that card
is so good in your deck. But that being
said, you've had a long Swiss run so
far. You can relax for a moment, but
you've got more tournament to play and
I'm going to give you a break. But
congratulations once again. Best of
Annie. Top eight contention. But we'll
send it back. We've got more action.
Fantastic interview. Wow. Prismaticism.
The last regional qualifier champion
still standing. So, he's going to have
his work cut out for him. We could have
another repeat champion, but we're going
to have seven other hungry players. But
we've got another match for you. We
talked about it a little bit. We've got
the potential Aurora versus Diana here
and another win and situation.
Beastwites and Dr. Snuffles going into
game two. Diana on Abandon Hall and
Misfortune
bringing forgotten monument.
And I think this says a little bit about
how game one went because forgotten
monument is uh something where you're
playing it, you want to slow it down,
but also specifically saving aspirin's
climb for when you're going first
>> Dr. Snuffles
>> bloom and pass
>> is going to start with a scrier's bloom
here and no mobilize
>> perhaps has a catalyst but we will have
to keep an eye on that because the
strategy is of course to get to Aurora
as fast as possible.
>> Chosen champion for bees coming out
>> on the beginning
>> Diana
>> draw
>> Diana Lulari
>> brings so much card advantage for this
Diana deck
they move back over to Dr.
Bloom.
>> Can you predict a couple off the bloom?
>> And so far
>> in hand.
>> Yeah, I was going to say so far no ramp.
>> Uh do see this treasure trove could pick
that up. But the problem with that is
there is also no chaos runes that have
been channeled yet for Dr. Snuffles.
>> I don't want to cut them, but you should
randomize.
>> That is an excellent point. And if he
does not find any ramp,
still three more turns until he could
play the dazzling Aurora.
>> Draw one.
>> All right.
>> Oh, there it is. [laughter]
Can't play the catalyst this turn, but
he does have some ramp in hand.
>> Scrier's blue.
>> Mhm.
>> Another Scrier's Bloom.
>> Yeah, and perhaps even most importantly
in this situation, there was the
presence of a gust as well. So, uh,
Beast Whites is likely going to try to
get this Diana on a battlefield. We'll
have to wait and see if they have either
an answer for the gust or a way to
increase the might. Now is going into
abandoned hall perhaps trying to play
around the gust.
>> Thinking
>> there is the Gus looking to get rid of
that Diana Lunari.
>> Hard
>> and hard bargain is going to shut it
down. Hard bargain resolves.
>> Yep.
>> Gust is countered.
>> Plus one. I'll resolve my Diana trigger.
>> Yep.
>> One.
>> That is a huge hard bargain by the way.
>> Yeah. Creates so much early tempo here
from Bites.
>> Able to get on the board.
>> Conquer to one.
>> Yep.
>> Also finding the spell off the top.
shutting down some of this digging as
well with acceptable losses. Scrier's
Bloom killed here.
>> I think I love this from Beast Whites.
>> If you're watching at home and you're
saying, "Hey, why would you ever play a
losses this early, you know, you're
playing against Aurora, you want to save
it for that." Uh the answer is you just
saw your opponent not play any ramp the
previous turns.
>> So if you think that they're still
trying to find it, you're shutting down
that option. But the other reason is
when the acceptable losses goes into
your trash, you can just get it back
later with Fizz anyway.
>> And with Dr. Snuffles having a slower
start, I do like just kind of shipping
it there and seeing if you can make it,
you know, that much more difficult. Of
course, we now know Dr. Snuffles had the
ramp to follow it up, but I I still am a
fan of what Beast was trying to do
there.
Beastwise holding up to two points and
now does have that option to score at
the forgotten monument.
>> Conquer
>> and will score up to three. Discarding
the stupify drawing another card off
that move trigger
>> treat
cards hand
>> five currently.
And so now the question becomes, how do
you save your units? Oh, I love this.
I'm pretty sure that was a hidden tide
turner. So if you think Dr. Snuffles is
going to slam Aurora and find an Elder
Dragon on this turn, what Tide Turner
does is when the dragon targets it at
locations, you just swap them to
different locations and the damage is
not done. That will allow you to keep
the pressure going if you're
beastwipites.
Yeah, seeing that ramp last turn from
Dr. Snuffles. Beastwise certainly has to
expect the dazzling Aurora. Here it
comes.
>> Aurora.
>> Mhm.
>> We'll leave two runes ready for Dr.
Snuffles.
>> Now, we did not get to see deck lists
going into this, so this will be a big
question answered. Is this is Baron?
Well, I see the flurries. So, this tells
me that this is uh definitely elder
dragon based. No. Oh, we found a baron.
Nasher
>> made me a liar. Finds a baron. Anyway,
>> Baron pit battlefield token entering the
board.
>> Pass the turn. You mean Baron on to the
baron pit.
>> Showdown. Yep.
>> Right. There's a showdown.
[clears throat]
>> Um,
>> player comes there giving [snorts] me a
little chuckle. Dr. Snuffles passed and
Beast White said on the turn.
>> Oh, another acceptable losses.
Sorry, I can I I'd like to look through
this if you don't mind.
>> And that would take out that Aurora
right away.
>> Oh, but uh if you're
>> if you're beast whites, you're kind of
unhappy about what was revealed with
that first Aurora because there was no
second or third Aurora in that pile.
>> That means either you have Dr.
on multiples in hand or they're just
more likely to show up in the deck
because
>> that was a good chunk of cards that was
recycled as part of that reveal.
>> Beast whites able to hold here once
again up to four.
It'll be interesting to see how Bites
navigates the Baron Nasher.
>> You der,
>> you know, you you pose a real question
just because it's not something that can
be targeted,
right? You cannot choose it with your
spells or abilities. So cards like
Moonfall, even trying to drag it out of
the way there. I mean, you could say
that there's situations where if you
hold on one battlefield, you drag the
Baron away and then you move into the
pit, but that's not an option. So unless
you have a way to just go over the top
with might or you have something that
does not specifically choose, you don't
have a good way to get it off the board.
Yeah, lots of spells that target in
these Diana lists.
As the game goes on, one thing to
consider as well, a lot of Dionists will
run at least one Baron in the sideboard.
You could see a situation where you just
play your Baron to get rid of the
opposing Baron and call it a wash.
Fair trade, I would say.
Beast White's up to five points after
conquering that abandoned hall with
Diana.
Yeah, unfortunately for beast weights
the hand, it does not currently have any
options for dealing with this baron.
So the question becomes, what do you
develop to set yourself up for the
future?
And it looks like it just might be
another tide turner in the base. Uh this
could still swap with the merchant when
played from the base if that was the
choice just to do the discard draw, but
actually be whites
>> said I'm just going to pass actually. Uh
beginning old
>> pass it over Baron Nasher holding up to
two for Dr. Snuffles
>> channel.
>> We'll see if he has another dazzling
Aurora
>> three.
>> I was going to say I didn't see one in
hand but
>> Last Rights is a great development
>> for Dr. Snuffles.
>> I did also see another mobilize
So, going to recycle a Dazzling Aurora
and a Scrier's Bloom.
Whenever you equip the last rights as
part of the equip cost, you do recycle
two cards from your trash. So, it's a
great way to
get whatever you need from the trash
back into your deck.
>> Yeah, I was going to say at some point
the shovel will make it up there. Don't
worry. ganking on Baron.
>> Baron is now got ganking due to
misfortune, which does explain perhaps
why Dr. Snuffles is on this Baron
version. Uh, obviously in the
>> event, we have seen several people
transition to Baronss in the main deck
and then going with the Elder Dragon
Blade Flurry package in the sideboard.
But when you're on Misfortune, the Baron
is uh significantly better because of
your ability to give it ganking and let
it leave the Baron pit and roam to the
other battlefields.
>> Yeah, it's just so nasty with a 12 might
unit that cannot be chosen by enemy
spells and abilities. It's now a 14
might unit. So paired up with
Misfortune's ability,
>> quite the combination.
>> Conquer.
>> Yeah, you conquer three.
>> Up to three points goes Dr. Snuffles.
The tide turner did swap locations,
bringing Diana Lunari down to that
southern battlefield,
>> protecting the chosen champion.
>> Now, in terms of overall strategy for
this game,
>> uh the pressure is currently on Beast to
find an answer for the Baron Nasher
because right now
>> you have no problem. play. Misfortune
coming out. Moving back,
>> readying up the Baron Nasher
>> the Forgotten Monument
>> and we'll gank down to the monument.
>> What does Beast Whites have here? Dr.
Snuffles looking to wipe Beast Whites's
board.
>> Yeah, unless there's a flash or
something, I think this is going to be
successful. trigger.
>> There is also, we know, I think a star
crossed in hand that could save your
Diana if you just also want to return
the misfortune to their hand and allow
you to replay your Diana so you don't
lose both units.
>> Trigger.
>> Okay,
>> just stupify. Okay,
>> another Diana Lunari trigger getting
behind yet another card. So, I I had
started to talk through before the
overall strategy for beast white here is
you have to answer this baron at some
point
>> because scoring points is going to be
easy when you have three battlefields to
get to. This game will likely be decided
from somebody getting to seven and
holding and right now that Baron is the
easiest path to holding for either
player. So, if you cannot get it off the
board, I do not see a way that Beast
Whites ends up getting a victory.
Dr. Snuffles able to clear that board
going up to four points.
>> No, 10. Oh,
>> can I see your
>> good swinging turn there for Dr.
Snuffles.
>> Love the combination
with Misfortune and Baron Nasher.
Now, it's not really relevant at the
moment because there are no other units
in the trash. But last rights does
trigger on conquer or hold. So, if in
the future there is an answer for the
misfortune, Baron would be able to get
her back. And I think identifying that
Beast Whites is going to use this turn
to dust on the last rights.
Uh that's one
>> hard bargain coming down forcing a
couple extra energy to be spent from
bewites just to have the turn to dust go
through.
>> Go ahead.
>> Developing the tide turner and Raven
Bloom student and the
>> temporary trigger will fire off. Last
right's gone.
>> Beginning the last right dies. I hold
for one more point up to five.
>> So both players will be at five points.
channel my two
>> drop return
>> and Dr. Snuffles still has to feel
uh in control here with that Baron has
not found another large unit or another
dazzling Aurora but in the current game
state does not need to
>> start off
>> Misfortune can still provide ganking to
the Baron
>> so the ability to actually go to seven
this turn from Dr. Snuffles
>> two purple.
>> Yeah, this misfortune chosen champion
paired up with Baron Nasher is
absolutely ridiculous.
>> That ganking keyword absolutely crucial.
Here is a mindspplitter.
>> Okay,
>> game three. Yep.
>> And we are going to game three. Dr.
Snuffles with this spicy Baron Nasher
Misfortune Aurora Deck sending us the
distance.
Yeah, that was a great call from Beast
Whites at that point to just call and go
to game three so that you have the most
amount of time possible to make sure
that it finishes. The game may drag on
and you know that your opponent is
saving Aspirin's climb for the game
three, so you're going to have to go
that much further to get there. Uh
overall, I liked what Beast Whites was
doing early on with the losses to slow
things down and then the second losses
to answer the Aurora. Uh unfortunately
for Beast Whites, it was Baron that
landed and seeing that there is
mindslitters in the list. You have to
wonder if that game goes the same way if
Snuffles only got a mindspplitter as
opposed to specifically Baron Nasher in
that point.
>> Yeah, the game changed on a dime when
Baron Nasher hit the board.
Early traveling merchant start for Beast
Whites. Moving into Aspirants Climb.
Here's a Gust.
>> And that is going to stop this early
tempo for Beast Whites. Gust bouncing it
back to hand.
>> Yeah, Beastwise just has to still
resolve that move trigger. Dr. Snuffles
kind of preemptively gusted, but
theoretically the move trigger happens
before that showdown progresses.
as we see the losses go away and a
development of two more units.
>> No beginning channel draw.
>> Bewise knows that they need to score
points quickly and efficiently because
this is a game going to nine thanks to
Aspirin's climb.
And in the hands of Dr. Snuffles. I
think I see not only a Dazzling Aurora,
but a Baron Nasher.
No ramp that I could spy though. I think
it's a Sabotage, a bullet time, and a
mind spplitter. So, a lot of top end,
and then answers. No ramp. This could be
a very slow start for Dr. Snuffles. Is
going to need every inch of that Aspirin
climb's help.
>> Yeah, Dr. Snuffles has had a hard time
finding that early ramp over the last
couple of games.
And now Beast Whites with an opening
here.
>> Conquer
>> just wants to get on the board
>> for me.
>> And seed of power in play will have that
ability to get some card advantage.
Yeah, I was just about to say the
successful conquer on the aspirin climb
is telling beast whites that that is a
green light. If there was another gust
or some sort of reactive thing, you
would have wanted to stop the tide
turner cuz that would have prevented the
seat of power from being in play. But
now you get both the move trigger from
the merchant as well as the card from
the seat.
Still looking at another couple turns
before that dazzling Aurora can come
down. We'll see how Beast Whites
develops here.
>> And it does look like we're seeing some
sideboard techs
in the trash because there is a rebuke
there.
>> Not typically in the main deck these
days. Also that ride the wind as well.
Perhaps the train of thought there is
using it to steal a victory. Or if you
don't have presence on both
battlefields,
you could also send one unit to the
other and gain an additional point on
your opponent's turn.
>> That could be clutch on these aspirant
climbs games because of the one
additional point needed to win.
Vex apathetic for beast whites
reinforcing at
>> aspirants climb.
Going to see that minds spplitter coming
out here.
>> Mindsplitter.
>> Now
>> taking a look at Beast Whit's hand. What
are you thinking here, Charmer?
Well, if I'm looking at Beastwise's
hand, I think that the only two things
worth considering are the turn to dust
or the star cross
spirit or excuse me, Sprite Fountain is
not something that you're really
concerned about at the moment. Ride the
wind is irrelevant when you have
presence on both battlefields. Stupify
is just a going to replace itself. So,
it just comes down to do you want to get
rid of the card? The answer is
equipment.
>> Like to write it down real quick,
though. And that is that is the choice.
>> Yeah, just get rid of the gear hate.
>> Yeah, the only other reason I was saying
that starcross could be considered there
is that
>> it does return this mindspplitter back
to the hand of Dr. Snuffles. So if Dr.
Snuffles wants to swing in and try to
clean up some of this might on the board
next turn, Beast Whites has the answer
in hand.
>> And again, because of the double recycle
when developing the mind spplitter, Dr.
Snuffles is now still at least two turns
away from playing the Aurora that we
know they have, but they have the option
to play it and have it potentially
survive because they've seen one losses
go to the discard pile and they just
stripped the turn to dust. So Dr.
Snuffles understanding that playing the
Aurora as fast as possible just to have
it removed is not as important as just
ensuring that it sticks.
Yeah, very heads up there for Dr.
Snuffles. Has that extra time as you
talked about with the aspirants climb,
but really is going to stretch that
battlefield as much as he can as Beast
Whites up to four points here. Double
hold on this turn. Traveling Merchant
back to base and we've got the move
trigger as he will continue to dig.
>> Another Vex here hitting the trash.
And it does look like the pickup for the
turn was a Raven Bloom student in the
hand of Beast Whites. The merchant does
go back to hand with the starcross
as I expected because you want to slow
down that mind spplitter and also put
Dr. Snuffles in a position where if the
next turn he just plays Mindsplitter
again, you know that they're still that
much further away from Aurora. But also
for beast whites, if they don't play
minds spplitter, then you're saying,
okay, they likely have the aurora and
they can't afford to
>> recycle runes and get that much farther
away. So you're going to gain some
information no matter what Dr. Snuffles
does if you're Beast Whites.
>> So now Beast Whites just fully
developing that backline, bringing out
the chosen champion and the student
Dr. Snuffles reaching for all of the
energy.
>> Is it going to be the mind spplitter
again? It will be another mindslitter.
>> And this time around because the turn to
dust was already stripped and you saw
the star cross get played. I think that
the choices are significantly worse
for Dr. Snuffles. Now the benefit is
again you do have seven might on the
board now and you're seeing the hand and
if there was maybe a backup star crossed
or something you could have stripped it
but in this case you see nothing that
really stops your splitter you want to
make sure it sticks around. I like this
choice of targeting the stupify because
even though it looks innocuous it
replaces itself. So taking away the
ability to dig deeper will hopefully
mean the mindsplitter sticks, but you do
still have to worry about their draw for
the turn as well as this merchant
trigger.
>> Beastwise holding to five
>> Diana trigger
>> going to get some serious card advantage
this turn. You have the Diana trigger
finding the stack deck and then that
seed of power is going to get yet
another card
>> as Beast Whites conquers up to six. You
see the power
>> and then we saw a stacked deck go into
the hand from the Diana trigger. So that
will be another filter or dig for
answers. And then as we pointed out,
there is still a move trigger looming
from the merchant. So yeah, the
mindsplitter may have given you some
information, but essentially Beast
Whites is going to have uh the
opportunity to put four new cards in
their hand and it's still going to be a
guessing game and you're no more closer
to your dazzling Aurora if you're Dr.
Snuffles. So we'll see if this gamble
pays off.
Yeah, quite the reload turn here for
Beast Whites. Finding several cards and
now we've got Fizz coming out.
>> And that is going to allow Beast Whites
to replay the Star Cross.
>> Starcross goes to the bottom.
>> Fizz back to hand. And so does the
Mindsplitter
go away into Dr. Snuffles's hand. And
that cleans out Snuffles side of the
board. And as you said, there's no
Aurora coming next turn. So he once
again will not be able to contest these
battlefields.
>> Yeah, this is very problematic for Dr.
Snuffles because you have nothing coming
next turn and then when you play or your
Aurora on the following turn with beast
whites likely at eight, you have to hit
Baron to prevent
>> draw from conquering alone. But the
Baron itself does not get rid of the
holds that beast has. So the other
direction is you have to hit Elder
Dragon, but that would only get rid of
two of these units on the battlefields.
Could not target both the merchant and
the Vex that are at the aspirin climb.
>> So that means that you would have to
somehow have one more rune on top of it
when you play the Aurora to then also uh
react to your triggers and do something
like Blade Flurry. But I don't think I
see the ramp in the hand right now cuz
you would have to ramp this turn so that
you're above nine next turn.
>> So as as you're going through your
options of the things you have to have
and then going actually that doesn't
work. Have to have actually that doesn't
work. I don't know if Dr. Snuffles has a
window here. Going backto back mind
spplitter instead of going up to Aurora
might cost this game.
>> Brutal situation here for Dr. Snuffles
and as you called that second
mindslitter really didn't even get a
good hit. So
>> not a massive amount of value there. The
>> Mhm.
>> Misfortune chosen champion
>> coming out.
>> She's stunned.
>> Y
>> and with Vex apathetic at that
battlefield
>> doesn't matter. Uh
>> I'm just Misfortune coming out you. I
don't think you will but
>> just want to make sure I'm acknowledging
the trigger.
there.
>> What a pickle.
>> Yeah, the one potential out even though
it would require
a very heavy investment from Dr.
Snuffles is there is bullet time.
So if there is a way where you can
conquer over one battlefield and then
bullet time the other power,
>> you can prevent yourself from losing,
but it's not what I would consider a
gamewinning path or a game-winning
strategy either.
>> We do see sabotage, but once again, Dr.
Snuffles
>> having to dramp here and the hard
bargain stopping the sabotage
>> cuz only one energy
>> was left available for Dr. Snuffles to
>> I think that hard bargain might have
actually just sealed it in Beast
Whites's favor. It's going to be very
difficult for Dr. Snuffles to deal with
both of these battlefields and prevent a
double conquer the following turn. The
number of runes recycled turn after turn
just to kind of deal with the board that
Beast Whites had developed means that
Dr. Snuffles is still way behind on
their endame plan.
And this is it. One more hold for
Beastwites and it's all over.
>> Dr. Snuffles will not be in that Aurora
range next turn either. Here comes
another Fizz. We know it was bounced
back to hand last turn.
>> Uh, play stack deck.
>> Just going to go digging.
I will say that we are kind of seeing
both the pros and the cons of the
Misfortune version of Dazzling Aurora
because the pro is obviously the
ganking. We saw that win with the Baron
in game too. It was very effective.
Also, this chosen champion can be very
relevant in the mid game if you need to
buy time. The cons are if you do any
sort of recycling and you don't find
your ramp or even if you find your ramp
but you're doing recycling,
>> you're setting yourself behind more than
if you play Civer. Civer's ability to
generate gold means that plays like Dr.
Snuffles backto back mind spplitters
>> wouldn't have recycled as much because
you would have had the gold. So you
would at least be one rune ahead of
where you were. It might open up some
more options. And that one rune ahead
means on that turn I was saying you'd go
to nine. instead would have had 10 for
maybe hitting a dragon and having that
blade flurry that I talked about.
>> Yeah, absolutely excellent point.
>> As a card is hidden at the northern
battlefield, Dr. Snuffles has his work
cut out for him. Has to bring these
whites off of both of these battlefields
or we are done here.
And unfortunately for Dr. Snuffles. The
first ramp option has finally showed up
in the form of Catalyst of Aons, but it
is not relevant. It is a dead draw in
the current game state. Again, Dr.
Snuffles has to clear both battlefields
to not lose on the spot and then has to
prevent a double conquer on the
following turn.
I do not see the options in the hand.
But I will also admit that I am not a
doctor. So I will trust Dr. Snuffles. If
anyone was to figure it out, it would be
them. I only have a master's degree. I
do not have a PhD. [laughter]
Well, this is it. The deciding game
three, a win and match.
Has has Beast Whites done it? Will Diana
be locking a spot in the top cut?
Diana the only legend so far to be in
each of the top cuts of the regional
qualifiers in the unleashed season.
Looking to continue that trend here in
the final regional qualifier of the
unleashed season.
>> And I think that the consideration that
Dr. Snuffles is making here is whether
you play something first and then move
misfortune or not just because you want
to get that ready trigger.
>> Flo run.
>> Yeah. And it does look like we're going
to see the float first and then
Misfortune will come in.
>> Misfortune.
almost committed. Wavering. [laughter]
>> This is like tempting. This is like very
tempting
>> chess matches where somebody has their
hand on a piece and they don't want to
take it off because they might want to
reposition it. They don't want to commit
100% yet.
>> And here.
>> And there we go. Dr. Snuffles has
committed the misfortune.
>> And [laughter]
five might unit. So I have a Diana
trigger.
>> Here we go. Five might to three.
>> Response to the Diana trigger. I will
use it.
>> See what Beast Whites finds off of that
Diana trigger
does predict first.
>> Now, I was just about to say if they're
taking that long, it either means it's
not a spell, but it's something that
they might want to save, or it's a
spell, but it's not the spell they were
looking for.
>> Wait.
>> Uh, sorry. So now Tide Turner, your
focus
>> being showed there.
>> It's Tide Turner. Spoilers.
>> I mean, that's what I was [laughter]
betting on it to be honest with you. So
[snorts]
>> all right, it's your focus.
>> Depending.
And
>> so Dr. Snuffle said, "Hey,
>> do you still have a response?"
>> Here comes the bullet time.
Dr. Snuffle is able to pay any amount of
power to deal that much damage to all
the enemy units at a single battlefield.
>> And so, as I said before, this is one of
the ways that Dr. Snuffles can try to
not lose
>> with bullet time. But a lot of runes are
going to have to be recycled here.
>> And I'll float.
This is not going to be an easy decision
because you have to have at least four
if you're going to try to get rid of
everything. And that's assuming that
there are no might bumps as well. So you
might try to go a little bit more over.
>> I'll float seven.
>> So floating. You're playing it on this
battlefield.
>> How much power does he end up paying
here?
>> Move X is dying either way. So,
>> well, the power doesn't have to
>> be paid until the resolution. That is
the one thing working in Dr. Snuffle's
favor. So,
>> we'll pay
>> just waiting to see what Beast Swites
throws back.
>> Four. Four. So, I'll pay four to deal
damage. Four damage to all units in this
battlefield.
>> They're dead.
>> Okay. So, successfully clearing out the
aspirin climb.
>> Dramping four is Dr. Snuffles.
>> All tie turner swap with Fizz.
And so Tide Turner revealed will try to
bring Fizz
>> to the battlefield which would be six
might
>> to the five of misfortune.
>> Dr. Snuffles again does still have seven
energy that has been floated to work
with.
>> So seven energy.
>> There is the option now for something
like blade flurry that we saw in hand
which would still clear the battlefield.
The biggest issue is then the Misfortune
also perishes. And if Misfortune dies in
this combat, Beast Whites will just win
because of the threatened double conquer
in the base.
>> Hand revealed. Dr. Snuffles doesn't have
it. There's the fist bump. Beast Whites
with Diana taking it here in the final
round and he will be advancing on to the
top cut in Hartford.
That was a very tough game
for Dr. Snuffles to navigate in game
three. We saw no ramp and then there was
that decision for the first
mindspplitter and I liked the first mine
spplitter. [music]
Uh again, if you want to potentially get
rid of something like an acceptable
losses or a turn to dust, taking a peek
seeing the status of the hand makes
sense. But then you saw that we're there
were really only two targets worth
mentioning, right? the turn to dust
>> and the star cross. You get rid of the
turn to dust and then you saw the
starcross played on your mind spplitter.
So unless they top decked something
really spicy, the commitment of the
second one is something that I think
when Dr. Snuffles goes back and looks at
this, they might say, "Okay, you know,
knowing what I know now, I probably
should have just set myself up for the
Aurora in the future." But it's also
easy for us to say it on the desk. We're
not in the moment. Uh, hindsight is 2020
and I again I'm not a doctor.
>> Yeah, absolutely. But one thing is for
sure, it's very tough for Dr. Snuffles
to win there without the Aurora. Did not
get that Aurora down in the final game.
But I want to say you talked about the
double mind spplitter, but the
Misfortune interaction with the Baron
Nasher, even though Dr. Snuffles didn't
take that match was extremely
interesting and he was just able to
completely control the battlefields with
that interaction.
>> Yeah, it was very problematic for
Beastweights. And as I had said when we
were calling it, once that Baron hits
the table, if you cannot get rid of it,
you're just going to lose the game at
that point. It can move around because
of the misfortune legend with the
ganking that's granted. It will clear
your board. And then there's also no way
that you'll be able to stick a hold
yourself until the Baron is gone. So, it
truly is a gamewinner when it hits the
table if you don't have an answer. And
because you can't target it, the answers
are that much harder to come by.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And now we know that
Diana will be finding a spot in the top
cut. And as I mentioned, it's the only
legend to be in the top cut of all four
regional qualifiers now in the Unleash
season. So, a deck that has proven to be
very consistent.
>> Yeah. And that doesn't surprise me. I
was very excited when Diana was
announced because I felt Ezreal was
already powerful in Spirit Forged. Yes,
we talk about the miracle version, but
even afterwards, I think that it had
legs, but when you take that card pool
and then you give it Moonfall, and then
when you also give it an extra energy
every showdown, it just feels
consistently in the running. It's one of
those decks that even with your bad
matchups, you feel like you have an out.
you feel like, hey, if I just do the
right thing, if I just play to my outs,
I have a shot. And I think that's why
all of these top players like the LNZQs,
like the Dewalies, like the Beastwites,
they're gravitating to this legend
because you always have game into
whatever your opponent brings to the
table.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We talked about it
earlier. It gives you a lot of agency
and that's what these top players in the
game want. And the other iteration in
this deck that is interesting is the
arena's greatest. We saw Beastwise
actually bringing in the arena's
greatest. So being a little bit more
aggressive with Diana, which I thought
was pretty neat.
>> Yeah, I think that might be an inclusion
to offset potential Aspirin Klein's
games. Uh we didn't see it used there.
It could also be an inclusion to get
underneath these uh combo lux decks. If
you expect the uh Limitless Lux to show
up and light up, upon very intended,
your game state, well, you want to get
ahead of it. So, uh, uh, I think I like
the arena's greatest. Uh, it is one of
those things where if you're, again, if
you're Diana, you feel like you have
game into anything. So, if you want to
be a bit more aggressive with your game
plan, then feel free. Run with it.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Well, that is going to
conclude our coverage from Swiss, but we
have the top cut looming, so don't go
anywhere. The top cut from the Hartford
regional qualifier coming up next.
>> [music]
>> Hey, [music]
[music]
>> [music]
heat. [music]
Heat.
Heat. [music]
[music]